WE WANT TO CALL THE
SELECT COMMITTEE ON POLICE
REFORM TO ORDER WEDNESDAY
DECEMBER SIXTEENTH. ONE IS A
GOOD MORNING TO EACH AND
EVERYONE OF YOU FOR JOINING US
ON OUR SECONDS- SELECT
COMMITTEE HEARING ON POLICE
REFORM BEFORE WE BEGIN WE WANT
TO STE- READ SOME HOUSEKEEPING
ROLLS INTO. THE RECORD. AND WE
ASK THAT MEMBERS OF THE PUBLIC
AS WELL AS ASSEMBLY MEMBERS
PLEASE GOVERN THEMSELVES OF
QUARTERLY. DUE TO THE
CONTINUOUS STAY AT HOME ORDER.
WE ARE PRACTICING PHYSICAL
DISTANCING HERE IN THE MEETING
ROOM AND THROUGHOUT THE STATE
CAPITOL BUILDING. SO WE ARE
ONLY ALLOWED. WE ARE ONLY ABLE
TO HAVE A LIMITED NUMBER OF
PEOPLE WATCHING AND
PARTICIPATING IN THE HEARING
ROOM. TODAY WE ARE ALSO
REQUIRING THAT MASS BE WARNED
AND PHYSICAL DISTANCING BE
MAINTAINED BY ALL MEMBERS OF
THE PUBLIC TESTIFYING WHETHER
IN THIS ROOM OR THROUGH OUR
VIDEO CONFERENCING SITE. IF YOU
DO NOT HAVE A MASS MASS WILL BE
PROVIDED TO YOU AT NO COST
THAT'S JUST A LITTLE JOKE.
BECAUSE OF OUR- SPACE
LIMITATION WE HAVE SOME
COMMITTEE MEMBERS I'M SITTING
ON THE DIETS AND OTHER SITTING
IN THE FIRST FEW ROLES. OF THE
AUDIENCE OF FOR THOSE COMMITTEE
MEMBERS WHO WOULD LIKE TO SPEAK
DURING THE HEARING PLEASE
APPROACH THE MIKE BEHIND THE
PLEXIGLAS. AND PLEASE REMEMBER
TO PRACTICE PHYSICAL DISTANCING.
WE ALSO HAVE A FEW DIFFERENT
OPTIONS FOR THE MEMBERS OF THE
PUBLIC. WHEN EACH WHEN REACHING
THE PUBLIC COMMENT PORTION OF
THE AGENDA. I WOULD ASK THAT
ANY MEMBER OF THE PUBLIC HERE
IN THE MOOD IN THE ROOM PLEASE
APPROACH THE MIKE ONE PERSON AT
A TIME AND PLEASE MAINTAIN
PHYSICAL DISTANCING AS YOU MOVE
THROUGHOUT THIS MEETING ROOM. I
WOULD ASK THAT THE PUBLIC DO
NOT TOUCH THE MICROPHONE IF
YOUR MOM IF YOU NEED A
MICROPHONE IT JUST AT ONE OF
OUR SERGEANTS WILL BE MORE THAN
HAPPY. TO ELEVATE IT TO YOUR
HOUSE TO YOUR REQUIRED LEVEL.
YOU NEED TO IF YOU NEED TO EXIT
THE MEETING ROOM ONCE YOU. HAVE
COMPLETED PROVIDING YOUR
COMMENTS- PLEASE DO SO. OR
PLEASE RETURN BACK TO YOUR SEAT.
PLEASE BE SURE TO OBSERVE
PHYSICAL DISTANCING UPON
LEAVING THE CAPITAL INCLUDING
LIMITING. ELEVATOR USE THIS TO
ONE PERSON AT A TIME ONCE AGAIN
ONE PERSON AN ELEVATOR AT A
TIME. IN ADDITION TO BEING ABLE
TO TESTIFY FROM INSIDE THE
HEARING ROOM WE HAVE SOME
PANELISTS AND OTHER MEMBERS OF
THE PUBLIC MAKING USE. OF ONE
OF OUR WITNESSING VIDEO
CONFERENCING ROOMS HERE IN THE
CAPITAL AND OR A REMOTE
TESTIMONY STATION LOCATED ON
THE CAPITOL GROUNDS AND IN A
FEW OTHER LOCATIONS THROUGHOUT
THE STATE. THOSE WITNESSING
THOSE WITNESSES WILL APPEAR ON
THE SCREEN SO MEMBERS CAN WATCH
THEIR TESTIMONIES LIVE FROM
OUTSIDE OF THE HEARING ROOM AND
ALSO ASK QUESTIONS OF THOSE
INDIVIDUALS. NEXT WE WILL ALSO
BE USING A MODERATED TELEPHONE
SERVICE FOR THE PUBLIC COMMENTS.
THE CALL IN NUMBER FOR THE
HEARING STUDENT. BUT THE
HEARING IS AREA CODE.
877-692-8957 ONCE AGAIN TOOK
THE CALL IN NUMBER IS.
877-692-8957 THE ACCESS CODE
WHICH IS IMPORTANT IS IT ONE OF.
THREE ONE FIVE FOUR TWO ZERO
TWO ONCE AGAIN THE ACCESS CODE
IS. ONE THREE ONE FIVE FOUR
TWO. ZERO TWO. THE OPERATOR ON
THE LINE WILL GIVE YOU
INSTRUCTIONS ON HOW TO BE
PLACED IN THE QUEUE TO PROVIDE
YOUR PUBLIC COMMENT. IF YOU ARE
CALLING IN. PLEASE ELIMINATE
ALL BACKGROUND NOISE ONCE AGAIN
IF YOU'RE CALLING IN PLEASE
ELIMINATE ALL BACKGROUND NOISE-THIS IS THIS INCLUDING A MUTING
YOUR LIVE STREAM BROADCAST AND
YOUR SMART DEVICE TO REDUCE THE
SOUND DISTORTION. AGAIN WITH A
THANK YOU VERY MUCH FOR YOUR
PATIENCE THESE ARE- YOUR
HEARING FOR THESE VERY
IMPORTANT RULES OF DECORUM.
THAT TAKES CARE OF A
HOUSEKEEPING. RESPONSIBILITIES
NEXT. MOVING INTO THE AGENDA.
AGAIN THE SELECT COMMITTEE ON
POLICE OFFICER. I'M PLEASE
REFORM WHILE OUR FIRST HEARING
WAS ON THE HISTORY OF POLICE
REFORM EFFORTS WE WILL FOCUS
THIS HEARING ON RECRUITMENT AND
TRAINING OF LAW ENFORCEMENT
WITHOUT WASTING ANYTIME WE WILL
HAVE OUR NEXT HEARING AGAIN ONE
UNDERSCORE OUR NEXT HEARING
WILL BE THIS FRIDAY FRIDAY
DECEMBER THE EIGHTEENTH AND THE
TOPIC OF DISCUSSION FOR THE
HEARING WILL BE A POLICE
OFFICER ACCOUNTABILITY AGAIN
WOULD BE THIS FRIDAY- AT TEN
O'CLOCK AM. ROOM FORTY TWO OH
TWO ON DECEMBER EIGHTEENTH AS
FOR TODAY'S HEARING. THANK YOU
ALL. IN ALL OF OUR PANELISTS
MAKE THEMSELVES AVAILABLE TO
PARTICIPATE IN TODAY'S HEARING
WE APPRECIATE YOU BEING HERE.
BUT THOSE IN THE AUDIENCE YOU
WILL HAVE AN OPPORTUNITY. FOR
PUBLIC COMMENT AT THE END OF
THE HEARING TODAY. BEFORE WE
BEGIN I WANT TO RECOGNIZE MY
COLLEAGUES. WHO ARE THE SELECT
COMMITTING AND THANK THEM FOR
JOINING ME AND HOLD THEM. AND
HOLDING HEARINGS ON THESE A
VERY IMPORTANT ISSUES AFFECTING
ALL OF OUR COMMUNITIES IN THE
STATE OF CALIFORNIA. I WOULD
NOW LIKE TO INVITE MEMBERS OF
THE SELECT COMMITTEE TO
INTRODUCE THEMSELVES AND MAKE A
FEW REMARKS STARTING WITH THOSE
PHYSICALLY IN THE MEETING ROOM
HERE TODAY- WE HAVE MEMBERS
WILL BE JOINING US BUT WE WANT
TO RECOGNIZE- ASSEMBLY WOMAN
ARE RUBIO FOR HER. INTRODUCTION
AND BRIEF REMARKS AS RUBIO.
THANK YOU ASSEMBLY MEMBER
GIPSON AND THANK YOU ALL FOR
JOINING US TODAY I LOOK FORWARD
TO A GREAT DISCUSSION- WHEN.
ASSEMBLY MEMBER GIPSON WAS
TALKING THE FIRST THING THAT
CAME TO MIND AS A FORMER
TEACHER THERE WAS A WHOLE BUNCH
OF- AB THINGS THAT SARAH. A
TEACHER NEEDS TO DO TO GET
CREDENTIALED SO HOPEFULLY I CAN
NOT INTRODUCTION OF THOSE-
IDEAS INTO OUR CONVERSATION BUT
I THINK IT'S VERY SIMPLE I
THINK- FIRST OF ALL THANK YOU
TO ALL OF THE LAW ENFORCEMENT.
COMMUNITY THAT IS WILLING TO
HAVE THIS DISCUSSION WITH US-
EARLIER TODAY I WAS SPEAKING TO
ASSEMBLY MEMBER GIPSON AND
ASKED SPECIFICALLY YOU KNOW WHO
HAS BEEN INVOLVED IN THESE
CONVERSATIONS. I THINK THAT
IT'S REALLY IMPORTANT THAT ALL
SIDES COME TO THE TABLE TO MAKE
SURE THAT THAT THAT ONCE WE'RE
DONE WITH THIS PROCESS WE PUT
FORWARD OUR POLICIES AND
PROCEDURES THAT WILL BENEFIT.
BOTH THE LAW ENFORCEMENT
COMMUNITY AND OBVIOUSLY OUR OUR
OUR COMMUNITIES OUR RESIDENTS
AND SO I JUST WANNA THANK
ASSEMBLY MEMBER GIPSON AGAIN
FOR THE OPPORTUNITY TO
PARTICIPATE AND I LOOK FORWARD
pCONVERSATIONS AGAIN WITH THE
COMMUNITY BUT ALSO THE LONG
FIRST MY COMMUNITY SO THAT WE
CAN. DO THIS TOGETHER I THINK-
IT'S TOO IMPORTANT NOT TO MAKE
SURE THAT- WE'RE ALL ENGAGE SO
THANK YOU FOR THE OPPORTUNITY
TO BEHERE. AND I LOOK FOR TALK
A GREAT CONVERSATION. THANK YOU.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH MISS RUBIO-
NEXT WE WILL GO TO MY
COLLEAGUES WHO ARE ON THE LINE-
THESE INDIVIDUALS ARE VIRTUALLY
ON WITH US. AND WE WANT TO GIVE
THEM OPPORTUNITY- ALSO TO SHARE
AND SAY A FEW WORDS. I HAVE A
LIST OF THOSE WHO. HAVE
INDICATED THEY WILL BE PART OF
THIS HEARING I WILL CALL YOUR
NAME AND I WILL ALSO ASK YOU
THAT IF MEMBERS WILL GET TO THE
Q. AND A PORTION. THAT YOU TEXT
ME AND I WILL CALL UPON YOU-
BASED ON- AS YOU TEXT ME. AND
SO YOU HAVE MY NUMBER I'M NOT
GOING TO GIVE IT TO HER RIGHT.
NOW GIVE IT OUT ARE YOU HAVE MY
NUMBER SO WE ASK THAT YOU
EXERCISE YOU WILL BE PLACE IN
THE QUEUE. IF YOU CAN PLEASE-
TEXT ME AND I WILL PLACE YOU IN
THE QUEUE WILL CALL UPON YOU-
DURING THAT- POINT IN TIME. SO
MEMBERS WHO INDICATED THEY WILL
BE WITH US REMOTELY. I WANT TO
CALL ON- ASSEMBLY WOMAN. ELOISE
RAYOS. OPERATE YOU CAN PLEASE.
MISS REYES PLEASE- ALLOW HER TO
INTRODUCE YOURSELF AND SAY A
FEW WORDS AND THE DOLLARS GO
DOWN THE LIST- FROM THERE.
THANK YOU SO MUCH. THANK YOU SO
MUCH GERMAN GIPSON I WANTED TO
THANK YOU FOR INVITING ME TO
PARTICIPATE IN THIS HEARING AND
I WANT TO THANK YOU STAFF ALSO
FOR ALL THE WORK THEY'VE BEEN
DOING ON THIS ISSUE. THIS
SUMMER PEOPLE ACROSS THE NATION
IT THROUGHOUT OUR STATE PROTEST
AGAINST RACIAL INJUSTICE AND
CALLED FOR REFORMS TOWARD LAW
ENFORCEMENT SYSTEM THESE
PROTESTS WERE A CALL TO ACTION
FOR US AS LEGISLATORS AS WE
LOOK AHEAD TO THE UPCOMING
SESSION WE HAVE TO CONTINUE TO
FOCUS OUR EFFORTS ON HOW WE CAN
IMPROVE THE RELATIONSHIP
BETWEEN OUR POLICE AND THE
COMMUNITY THEY SERVE. I AGREE
THAT IT'S OUR DUTY TO SERVE AND
PROTECT OUR COMMUNITIES AND
THIS HEARING ALLOWS US AS
LEGISLATORS. TO SEE WHERE THE
GAPS ARE IN SETTING BETTER
STANDARDS FOR LAW ENFORCEMENT
OFFICERS. TODAY I'M LOOKING
FORWARD TO LEARNING MORE FROM
OUR EXPERTS ABOUT LAW
ENFORCEMENT PROFESSIONALISM AND
HOW IT HAS CHANGED THROUGHOUT
HISTORY. SEPARATELY I'M REALLY
CURIOUS TO HEAR FROM OUR FIRST
PANEL ABOUT THE DEFINITION OF
PROFESSIONALISM IN THIS FIELD
AND WHETHER CURRENT PRACTICES
AND LAW ENFORCEMENT ALIGNED
WITH THE STANDARDS. I'M ALSO
INTERESTED IN LEARNING FROM OUR
SECOND AND THIRD PANELS ABOUT
HOW WE CAN IMPROVE RECRUITMENT
TESTING TRAINING AND EVALUATION
PROCESSES TO ENSURE OUR OFFICE
OUR OFFICERS ENGAGE WITH THEIR
COMMUNITIES IN A WAY THAT
PROMOTES MORE TRUST AND GREATER
SAFETY FOR ALL. ESPECIALLY FOR
COMMUNITIES OF COLOR WELL WANT
WHAT'S BEST FOR COMMUNITIES I
WANT TO THANK ALL OF OUR
PANELISTS HERE TODAY FOR THEIR
DEDICATION TO CREATING FAIR AND
EQUITABLE SYSTEMS THAT PROTECT
THE PEOPLE OF CALIFORNIA. THANK
YOU MR CHAIRMAN. THANK YOU VERY
MUCH. WE APPRECIATE YOUR
COMMENTS NEXT WE HAVE- ASSEMBLY
MEMBER- JORDAN CUNNINGHAM.
OPERATOR PLEASE ALLOW MISTER
CUNNINGHAM TO INTRODUCE HIMSELF
TO MAKE REMARKS. OKAY WE HAVE
ALSO DR SHIRLEY WEBER. OPERATOR
PLEASE RELEASE ALIVE DR WEBER
THANK YOU. DR WEBER IS YOUR
PHONE UNIT. NEVER BY PLEASE
BEAR WITH US WITH HIS
TECHNOLOGY WE'RE GOING TO WORK
OUT THE BUMPS IN THE KINKS AND
WE'LL MAKE IT FLOW. IS THAT I
NEED IT NOW YES WE CAN HEAR DR
WEBER THANK YOU VERY MUCH-
THANK YOU MISTER GIPSON AND TO
THOSE WHO ARE HERE TODAY ALL
CONCERNING THIS AND I'M REALLY.
I'M VERY PLEASED TO BE A PART
OF THIS PANEL- MOST OF YOU KNOW
I'VE DONE QUITE A BIT OF WORK
AROUND THE ISSUE OF SOCIAL
JUSTICE AND SO- IT'S ALWAYS
GOOD TO HEAR BOTH PARTS OF THE
OF THE STORY SO OFTEN WE HEAR
ONLY ONE SIDE. AND AND WE DON'T
GET A CHANCE TO HEAR ANALYSTS
WHO IN A CONFRONTATIONAL
SETTING WHERE WE'RE LOOKING AT
LEGISLATION. AND WHAT IS BEST A
WHAT IS NOT IN THE IMPACT OF
THAT SO THE ABILITY TO. GET
AHEAD OF THE LEGISLATION TO BE
ABLE TO HAVE CONVERSATIONS AND
MAYBE TO CRAFT LEGISLATION THAT
IS REASONABLE TO ALL SIDES
WOULD BE HELPFUL- NOT ALWAYS
POSSIBLE BUT WOULD BE HELPFUL
SO I LOOK FORWARD TO THE
CONVERSATION. FOR THOSE OF YOU
WHO ARE IN THE FIELD WHO ARE
GRAPPLING WITH THESE CRITICAL
ISSUES OF CERTIFICATION AND-
AND MAKING SURE THAT THOSE WHO
WHICH SELECT ARE. ARE ARE THE
KINDS F OFFICES WE WANT WE
KNOW THAT MAKES A TREMENDOUS
DIFFERENCE. AND IT ONLY TAKES
AS MANY OF YOU OFTEN SAY ONE
BAD APPLE IN THE BUNCH THAT
WOULD BASICALLY A RUNS A
REPUTATION. I COMMUNITIES NEED
LAW ENFORCEMENT THEY NEED
OFFICERS WHO ARE CONCERNED IF
YOU WANT TO KEEP THEM SAFE-
THAT IS A CONSTANT STATEMENT
THAT THEY MAKE SO THIS IS NOT
ABOUT THE ELIMINATION OF LAW
ENFORCEMENT. BUT IT REALLY IS
ABOUT MAKING SURE THAT THAT YOU
HAVE WE HEAR EACH OTHER. AND
THAT OUR COMMUNITIES FEEL THAT
YOU'RE DOING WHAT IS BEST TO
KEEP THEM SAFE TO PROVIDE AND
TO PROTECT AND TO SERVE. AND
THAT'S YOUR MODEL AND WE WANT
TO MAKE SURE THAT WE STAY
FOCUSED ON THAT AND THAT THAT
BECOMES A PART OF THE CULTURE
OF CALIFORNIA TO ONCE AGAIN
THANK YOU SO VERY MUCH MISTER
GIBSON. I LOOK FORWARD TO THE
CONVERSATION TODAY IN THE
CONVERSATION ON FRIDAY AS TO
WHAT WE CAN DO IN CALIFORNIA-
TO MAKE A DIFFERENCE IN
CALIFORNIA ALWAYS LEADS IN
EVERY AREA AND SO WE WANNA MAKE
SURE THAT WE'RE LEADING IN THIS
PARTICULAR AREA AS WELL. THANK
YOU SO VERY MUCH FOR YOUR
EFFORTS. THANK YOU DOCTOR
WHEREVER REPRIEVE SHEET JERRY
MARKS NEXT ASSEMBLY WOMAN. A
REBEKAH BAUR CARE. J. THE
NATURE OF. YOUR DEVICE AND-
WE'RE READY TO GO TO HEAR FROM
YOU. R. B. K. OKAY WELL SHE'S-
WORKING THAT PEACE OUT MR RUDY
SALAS. JUST ON MUTE YOURSELF
AND YOU CAN START. MR RUDY
SALAS. OKAY. MISTER JESSE
GABRIEL ASSEMBLY MEMBER JESSE
GABRIEL. GOOD MORNING MISTER
CHAIR CAN YOU HEAR ME. I CAN
HEAR YOU AND SEE YOU THANK YOU
WONDERFUL THANK YOU- THANK YOU
MISTER CHAIR AND THANK YOU
COLLEAGUES I'M PLEASED TO BE
JOINING YOU TODAY FROM- FROM
WOODLAND HILLS IN THE WEST SAN
FERNANDO VALLEY. WANT TO THANK
THE CHAIR- AND OFFICE STAFF FOR
THEIR HARD WORK IN PUTTING
TOGETHER THIS PANEL LOOKS LIKE
AN EXTRA EXTREMELY IMPRESSIVE
GROUP OF PANELISTS AND I WANT
TO THANK THE PANELISTS ALSO FOR
JOINING US- AND FOR SHARING
YOUR EXPERTISE AND YOUR
INTELLIGENCE IN YOUR WISDOM
WITH US AND ALSO THANK YOU FOR.
ALL THE WORK THAT ALL OF YOU DO
IN DIFFERENT CAPACITIES TO-
INFORM THE LEGISLATURE AND
SERVE THE PEOPLE THE STATE OF
CALIFORNIA. I THINK THIS
CERTAINLY IN IN AN
EXTRAORDINARILY IMPORTANT
CONVERSATION- ONE OF THE
REASONS WE KNOW WHAT'S
IMPORTANT IS THAT WE KEEP
HEARING ABOUT IT IN THE MIDST
OF A GLOBAL PANDEMIC A ONCE IN
A CENTURY HEALTH PANDEMIC IN A
SEVERE ECONOMIC CRISIS WE
CONTINUE TO HEAR FROM OUR
CONSTITUENTS AND THE PEOPLE
THAT WE SERVE ABOUT THIS ISSUE
AND SO. IT IS SOMETHING THAT I
KNOW MY COLLEAGUES AND I IN THE
LEGISLATURE ARE COMMITTED TO
CONTINUE WORKING ON- I AM I AM
VERY EAGER TO LEARN TODAY-
COULD REPROACH THIS
CONVERSATION WITH AN OPEN MIND
AND WANT TO ASSOCIATE MY MYSELF
WITH THE COMMENTS OF- OF MY
COLLEAGUE DR WEBBER- ABOUT THE
OPPORTUNITY TO LEARN IN IN
THIS- CAPACITY. I'M A TO TRY TO
CRAFT THINGS THAT WILL WORK FOR
ALL OF THE DIFFERENT
COMMUNITIES THAT WE SERVE AND
ALL THE STAKEHOLDERS INVOLVED-
IN PARTICULARLY INTERESTED IN
THE- IN THE ISSUE OF LAW
ENFORCEMENT TRAINING I SOME OF
YOU KNOW I'VE HAD A NUMBER OF
BILLS IN THAT AREA. AROUND
THINGS RELATED TO GUN VIOLENCE
RESTRAINING ORDERS AND HATE
CRIMES AND SO. EXCITED TO LEARN
MORE ABOUT POST- IN THE WORK IN
AND HOW WE CAN IMPROVE OUR OUR
LAW ENFORCEMENT TRAINING I TO
GET AT SOME OF THE ISSUES THAT
WERE TALKING ABOUT HERE- AND
CERTAINLY THESE ARE THESE ARE
EXTREMELY IMPORTANT ISSUE SO A
LOT TO UNPACK- MANY TOPICS THAT
I THINK ARE ARE OVERLAPPING IN
A RELATED BUT JUST WANT TO
THANK YOU. AGAIN MR TURN YOUR
STAFF FOR BRINGING TOGETHER
SUCH A- ANNEXING GROUP OF
PANELISTS AND LOOKING FOR TO-
TO DOING SOME LISTENING AND
LEARNING. LEARNING TODAY SO
THANKS FOR HAVING ME. THANK YOU
VERY MUCH MEMBER GAVE ROAD.
SHEET YOUR COMMENTS. WE WILL GO
TO MISTER JAMES ROMMEL'S. IF
YOU CAN PLEASE ON ME JUST SELF.
THANK YOU THANK YOU MISTER
CHAIR- THANK YOU FOR PUTTING
TOGETHER SELECT COMMITTEE THAT
LOOKS AT BOTH SIDES OF THE
EQUATION OF WHAT IT IS THAT
WE'RE HERE TO- HERE THE
DIFFERENT PANEL DISCUSSIONS.
AND THE SAFETY FOR ALL IN THE
STATE OF CALIFORNIA AND HOW TO
WORK TOGETHER TO LOOK AT
BUILDING MUTUAL RESPECT ON THE
ISSUES THAT FACE US HERE IN THE
STATE OF CALIFORNIA A MUTUAL
RESPECT BUILT ON KNOWLEDGE-
UNDERSTANDING AND SAFETY FOR
ALL SIXTY FOUR ALL ON THE
COMMUNITY AND SAFETY FOR THOSE
PROVIDING THE SAFETY FOR OUR
COMMUNITIES. WE HAVE TO KEEP AN
OPEN MIND ON ALL THE ISSUES
THAT AFFECT ON PUBLIC SAFETY
HERE IN THE STATE OF CALIFORNIA
AND WHEN IT'S WE COME TOGETHER
TO HEAR THE DIFFERENT PANEL
DISCUSSIONS AND KEEP AN OPEN
MIND THAT'S WHERE WE'RE GONNA
BE ABLE TO BUILD A MUTUAL
RESPECT TO MOVE FORWARD. AND
HOPEFULLY BE ABLE TO AGREE ON A
PIECE OF LEGISLATION ARE AGREE
ON LEGISLATION MOVING FORWARD
THAT HAS A WELL BALANCED
APPROACH TO ALL THOSE FACETS
THAT CREATES PUBLIC SAFETY IN
THE STATE OF CALIFORNIA THANK
YOU MISTER CHAIR FOR ASSEMBLING
THE SELECT COMMITTEE. THANK YOU
VERY MUCH REMEMBER RIVALS-
WE'RE GONNA GO BACK UP AND SEE
IF MISTER CUNNINGHAM HAS JOINED
US- MISTER CUNNINGHAM. PLEASE
UNMUTE YOURSELF AND BEGAN. OUR
BK. PLEASE IMAGES SEVENTY CAN
BEGIN SPEAKING. MISTER CHAD
MAYES. ASSEMBLY MEMBER CHAD
MAYES. I AM HERE CAN YOU HEAR
ME MISTER CHAIR WE CAN HEAR YOU
AND SEE THANK YOU VERY MUCH
WELL GREAT WELL I JUST WANT TO
BE- BE VERY BRIEF I WANT TO
THANK YOU MISTER CHAIR FOR
PUTTING TOGETHER THIS US SELECT
COMMITTEE- AND JUST THE URGENCY
OF THIS ISSUE I'M I THINK SOME
MIGHT THINK THAT BECAUSE IT'S
NOT. NECESSARILY HEADLINE NEWS
EVERY SINGLE DAY THAT THAT'S
SOMETHING THAT WE DON'T NEED TO
DEAL WITH AND WE KNOW THAT THAT
IS NOT TRUE- THAT OUR LAST A
HEARING- THIS ISSUE DURING A
DISCUSS TODAY CAME UP ON ITS
OWN AND SO I'M VERY MUCH
LOOKING FORWARD TO- TO HEARING
AT THE PANELISTS I WANT TO
THANK THE PANELISTS- FOR TAKING
TIME OUT OF YOUR BUSY SCHEDULES
TO A TO EDUCATE US I THINK
THERE'S AN ASSUMPTION THAT
BECAUSE WE'RE LEGISLATORS. THAT
WE'VE GOT IT ALL FIGURED OUT
YOU KNOW ALL THE ANSWERS AND I
CAN TELL YOU THAT IS NOT TRUE-
UNLIKE THE CHAIR MISTER GIBSON
AND ALSO- MR LACKEY WHO
ACTUALLY SERVED IN A LAW
ENFORCEMENT MANY OF US HAVE NOT
AND SO WHAT WE RELY AN AWFUL
LOT ON THOSE WHO ARE EXPERTS IN
TO BE ABLE TO EDUCATE EDUCATE
US AS LEGISLATORS AS
REPRESENTATIVES OF
REPRESENTATIVES OF THE PEOPLE
AND SO. IT'S GREAT TO BE HERE
AT TODAY AND- MISTER CHAIR
AGAIN THANK YOU FOR PUTTING
TOGETHER THE SELECT COMMITTEE
THANK YOU VERY MUCH MR REYES
FOR YOUR BRIEF COMMENTS WE WILL
GO BACK UP IN THE QUEUE. TO SEE
IF MISTER SALAS HAS JOINED US.
IF SO PLEASE ME JUST. AND WHICH
ARE INTRODUCTION. OKAY OUR BK
ONE MORE TIME CHAIR IN YES I
FIGURED OUT THAT I NEEDED THANK
YOU MISTER CHAIR. AND SAID
THANK YOU MISTER CHAIR FOR
CONVENING THIS HEARING I THINK
IT'S- CRITICAL THAT WOULD BE
HERE TODAY TO CONTINUE THIS
CONVERSATION AND LIKE
CALIFORNIA KNOW THAT WAY OUR
WORK IS FAR FROM DONE. WHEN IT
COMES TO POLICE REFORM THAT WE
KEEP OUR EYE ON. AND MAKING
SURE THAT OUR COMMUNITIES ARE
BOTH SAFE THAT TRUST IS BACK IN
THE SYSTEM BETWEEN THOSE IN LAW
ENFORCEMENT IN OUR COMMUNITY
AND THAT WE AND- THE CYCLE OF
VIOLENCE THAT HAPPENS ON OUR
STREETS SO. I'M I'M THRILLED TO
BE HERE AD BE A PART OF THIS
CONVERSATION I LOOK FORTY
HEARING THE PANELISTS TODAY
CONTINUING TO LOOK AT HOW WE
REFORM TRAINING AND HIRING AND
ENSURING THAT OUR POLICE- THE
MEN AND WOMEN IN POLICING. ARE
THE BEST PEOPLE FOR THE JOB
THANK YOU. THANK YOU VERY MUCH.
I DON'T KNOW IF WE HAVE- MISS
GONZALEZ AND- ASSEMBLYWOMAN.
LORENA GONZALEZ. YES SIR MR
CHERRY THANK YOU AND THANK YOU
FOR- PULLING THIS TOGETHER
AGAIN. I THINK THE LAST TIME WE
WERE TOGETHER- I WAS GETTING
WORRIED YOU KNOW WE HAD SO MANY
DIFFERENT ISSUES THAT WERE
COMING UP. AND YOU START TO
THINK IS THERE ANYWAY WE'RE
GOING TO BE ABLE TO SEPARATE
THIS AND TACKLE THIS AND YOUR
AGENDA TODAY SHOWS- I
RESPONSIBILITIES TO THAT THAT
WE ARE GOING TO BE ABLE. TO
TAKE THIS PIECE BY PIECE THESE
VERY IMPORTANT- HE SAYS TO
ENSURE THAT WE'RE DOING OUR
WORK TO HAVE. A RESPONSIVE
AFFECTED POLICE PRESENCE
ESPECIALLY IN COMMUNITIES LIKE
MINE THAT ARE PREDOMINATELY
IMMIGRANT. ON COMMUNITIES OF
COLOR WORKING CLASS COMMUNITIES
THAT HAVE HAD A LONG HISTORY
WITH PLACE THAT MIGHT NOT HAVE
BEEN- THE SAME AS EVERYBODY
ELSE'S SO WE WANT TO MAKE SURE
THAT CONTINUES I'M ESPECIALLY.
EXCITED TO HEAR ABOUT SOME OF
THE POSSIBILITIES IN TRAINING
WHAT WE'RE DOING NOW WHAT WE
COULD DO IN THE FUTURE. IN
REALLY- TAKE THAT IN WITH AN
EYE TOWARDS EQUITY AS WELL WE
KNOW AT LEAST OUR COMMUNITIES
THAT WE WANT OUR OFFICERS TO
COME FROM OUR COMMUNITIES. TO
COME FROM CERTAIN REGIONS OF
THE STATE- THAT MAYBE DON'T
HAVE THE SAME OPPORTUNITIES FOR
COLLEGE OR OR WE DON'T WANT
THEM TO WAIT TOO LONG- BE TOO
OLD SO WE HAVE TO. BALANCE OUT-
WHAT HAS BEEN TRADITIONALLY AN
OPPORTUNITY- FOR YOUNG MEN AND
WOMEN IN COMMUNITIES- THAT THEY
DID NOT WANT TO GO THE COLLEGE
ROUTE SO. I'M EXCITED TO SEE
HOW WE CAN I'M KIND MERE THOSE
TWO THINGS THE TRAINING AS WELL
AS A CAREER OPPORTUNITY- FOR
LOCAL. INDIVIDUALS WHO REALLY
DO WANT TO SERVE THEIR
COMMUNITY BECAUSE WE KNOW
THAT'S WHAT MAKES THE BEST
OFFICERS THOSE PEOPLE COME FROM
THE COMMUNITY AND CONTINUE TO
SERVE THERE. SO LOOK FOR
TODAY'S DISCUSSION AND FOR THE
ONGOING DISCUSSION AND- TAKING
A LOT OF HOURS THIS WEEK BUT I
THINK IT'S A SUBJECT THAT WE
ALL REALLY BELIEVE NEEDS- CLOSE
ATTENTION SO THANK YOU. THANK
YOU MUCH OF SOME WOMAN GONZALEZ
FOR YOUR REMARKS APPRECIATE IT-
WE HAVE MISTER RUDY SALAS WHO'S
JUST JOINED AS MUCH AS SALAS
YOU'RE UP TO BAT. I THANK YOU
CHAIRMAN GIVE SENATE
APPRECIATE- YOU PUTTING- I LOOK
FORWARD TO TODAY'S DISCUSSION
AND- REALLY. YEAH THIS IS A
ISSUE THAT IMPACTS ALL OF OUR
DISTRICTS AND I JUST READ EAGER
TO GET STARTED SO THANK YOU
VERY MUCH. THANK YOU VERY MUCH
WE WILL- ONE MORE TIME STEVE
MISTER CUNNINGHAM HAS JOINED
US- CUNNINGHAM HAS NOT JOINED
US SO AT THIS TIME WE'VE BEEN.
BLESSED TO HAVE JOIN US ON THE
DIET MISTER TOM LACKEY FOR HIS
COMMENTS MR LACKEY. WELL THANK
YOU CHAIR I JUST- WHEN I CALLED
THE COMMENTS OF SOME OF MY
COLLEAGUES HAVE INDICATED THE-
IMPORTANCE OF THIS ISSUE. IT
HAS BEEN A GROWING PROBLEM FOR
DECADES. AND- SOME OF THE- MORE
VISIBLE ABUSES HAVE. BUT THIS
IS THE ISSUE DESERVEDLY TO THE
FOREFRONT AND- I LOOK FORWARD
TO MAKING POLICY DECISIONS IT
HELPS RESTORE THE STE THE TRUST
THAT- ALL NEIGHBORHOODS
DESERVE- AS IT'S BEEN.
MENTIONED IN OUR PREVIOUS
GATHERING THAT THE LAW
ENFORCERS JUST WANTS TO BE AN
EXTENSION OF THE NEIGHBORHOODS
AND- UNFORTUNATELY OVER A
PERIOD OF TIME THAT ALIENATION
HAS BECOME A VERY HURTFUL
DISTANCE AND SO WE NEED TO
CLOSE THAT GAP AND I LOOK
FORWARD TO A CRAFTING POLICY
THAT. THAT HELPS BUILD BACK
CONFIDENCE AND TRUST. THANK YOU
VERY MUCH MR LACKEY WE
APPRECIATE EACH AND EVERYONE OF
YOU FOR GIVING OF YOUR TIME TO
BE PART OF THE SELECT COMMITTEE.
AND WE THANK YOU- THOSE IN THE
AUDIENCE AND THOSE WHO ARE ALSO
VIEWING. I WANT TO UNDERSCORE
AND THANK ON SPEAKER ANTHONY
RENDON BUT CERTAINLY- WITHOUT
HIM WE WOULD NOT BE HERE NO ONE
APPRECIATE ONE HIS LEADERSHIP-
HIM RESPONDING TO THE CALLS OF
THE COMMUNITY- AND ALSO THE
PEOPLE'S VOICES TO ALLOWING US
TO HAVE THE SELECT COMMITTEE ON
POLICE REFORM. AND I REALLY
APPRECIATE TWO ONE- HIS
LEADERSHIP IN THIS AREA SO.
AGAIN SPEAKER RENDON THANK YOU
VERY VERY MUCH FOR ALLOWING US
TO- TO BE HERE TODAY AND
CONVENE THESE MULTIPLE-
HEARINGS ON POLICE OFFICER OF
POLICE REFORMS THAT CALIFORNIA.
WITH THAT BEING SAID. LET'S
MOVE SWIFTLY- BEFORE WE BEGAN
OUR PANEL DISCUSSION. WE WILL
HEAR FROM THREE PERCENT-
PRESENTATIONS ALL THE NINE
PRINCIPLES OF POLICING BY SIR
ROBERT PEEL- SIR ROBERT PEEL
WROTE. A BOOK WITH RESPECT TO-
NINE PRINCIPLES OF A POLICING
AND WE WERE HERE- IN DEPT- FROM
SOME OF OUR PRESENTERS. THE
FIRST UP WE WANT TO- HAVE EACH
PRESENTER. WILL HAVE UP TO
EIGHT MINUTES TO SPEAK AND WILL
PRESENT IN THE ORDER NOTED ON
THE AGENDA BEFORE PRESENTING.
PLEASE INTRODUCE YOURSELF AND
THEN COMMENCE GOING INTO YOUR
PRESENTATION. THE FIRST PERSON
WE WOULD LIKE TO WELCOME IS- DR
ALI KHAN SKEWS ME- I. THINK
THAT'S RIGHT- NO I'M SORRY I
APOLOGIZE DR ERNEST ONE THREE.
ARE YOU WITH US YES I'M HERE
OUR SHARE GIPSON YES PLEASE
INTRODUCE YOURSELF AND- PLEASE
COMMENCE YOUR PRESENTATION
THANK YOU VERY MUCH FOR JOINING
US. THANK YOU VERY MUCH SHARPER
CHECK GIPSON NUMBER MISSED BOB
WHAT'S THE M. PART PURPOSE AND
SHE OF CRIMINAL JUSTICE AT
CALIFORNIA STATE UNIVERSITY
SACRAMENTO WOW SO THAT ARE
DISCONTENT FOR AFRICAN PEACE.
AND CONFLICT RESOLUTION. IT'S
SIX PLACE EUROPE TODAY TO WITH
YOU MY OWN. VIEWS ARE HAVING
TALKED FOR ALMOST THIRTY YEARS.
THE YOUNG PEOPLE GOING INTO A
VERY US AGENCIES OF THE
CRIMINAL JUSTICE SYSTEM. FROM
OUR DIVISION OF CRIMINAL
JUSTICE AT CALIFORNIA STATE
UNIVERSITY SACRAMENTO. I WOULD
ALSO THESE ARE MY PERSONAL
VIEWS. NOT NECESSARILY THOSE
HARPER MARI FIVE INSTITUTIONS
CALIFORNIA STATE UNIVERSITY
SACRAMENTO. I WOULD ALSO POINT
OUT THAT BEAST MOMENT WE ARE
IN. CALLS ON EACH AND EVERYONE
OF FORCE OUR STUDENTS NEEDS.
WHO ARE ENGAGED IN THE ARREST
JUSTICE MOVEMENT. TO BE SILENT
TO RESPOND ACT. THAT'S WHAT TO
DO IN ENGAGING POLICE FOR AT
THERE ARE JUSTICE REVIEW TO BE
PART MODEL THAT SQUARE SUPPORT
ARE FLOCKING FOR IS WHAT
HAPPENED AXED TO TALK ABOUT.
ACCORDING ON PURPOSE IN POLICE
IS OUR SCHOOLS ARE IN THIS FOR
OF POLICING. ARTICOLI IN STRONG
INSIDE KEY WAS PRESSED OF FOR
ARE EIGHTEEN NINE. WHICH FOR
THE CORNERSTONE OF THE POLICE
ARE. NORTH THE METROPOLITAN
POLICE LONDON BY REPLACED THE
PRE EXISTING LOCAL OP HARSH
WHAT SYSTEM OF CONSTABLES AFTER
THE POLICY WHICH ALSO REPLACED
THE TWELVE EIGHTY FIVE STATUTE
OFF WINCHESTER. ALSO WANTS TO A
COLONIAL INVASION OUR
POPULATION OPERATIVE. I SEE
EXISTENCE DAN SARASWAT PEEL
OFTEN REGARDED AS THE FATHER OF
MODERN POLICE USED HIM ON THE
BASIS OF THEIR REFERENCE TO THE
BRITISH POLICE ALL COPS ASK
BABIS. JOSHTHIS STATE OF
POLICING IN ADEQUATE THE
PROTECTION OF SOCIETY AT THAT
TIME. IN APRIL TEMPLE FOR THE
CHANGING ECONOMIC AND RELIGIOUS
GROUPS. ON SUSTAINABLE FORTY
GROWING INDUSTRIALIZATION. AT
THE TIME I'M NON RESPONSIVE TO
THE INCREASING INCIDENCE OF
CRIME BOTH PROPERTY AND
INTERPERSONAL VIOLENCE.
ARGUABLY THIS FORMER PRIME
MINISTER OF BRITAIN HOME
SECRETARY SCHOLAR POLITICAL
ACTIVISTS ARE REBEL I'M SOCIAL
REFORMER FORM A NOBLE CLASS WAS
A VISIONARY WHO SAW THE
CRITICAL NEED I'M ADVOCATE FOR
ORGANIZED POLICING ALWAYS
SYSTEM OF SOCIAL CONTROL IN
MORE THAN SUPPLY SOCIETY. I'M
NATION'S. FOR MOST NINE PRESS
OF LAW ENFORCEMENT SEEM TO BE
REFLECTIVE OFFICE VERREAUX'S
LIVE OPERATIONAL EXPERIENCE I'M
TO WE ARE QUITE INFLUENTIAL IN
THE CREATION AWFULLY SYSTEMS
OPPOSITION THROUGHOUT THE
WORLD. INCLUDING THE UNITED
STATES. IN FACT THE FORMER NEW
YORK CITY OUR POPULOUS
COMMISSIONER WILLIAM BRATTON
I'M OF COURSE IN THE UNITED
STATES HERE. WE GOT THE YORK
CITY I WAS THE FIRST MORE THAN
POLICE DEPARTMENTS IN THE
UNITED STATES. HE OFTEN COURTS
TO PEEL AS HE'S HERO ALL HIS
REPRESENTATION OFF MORE THAN A
FEW OF POLICING ESPECIALLY
CONCEPTUALIZING COMMITTEE
ORDERED THAT LISTING. NOT. TO
SUGGEST THAT THERE ARE NO
CRITICS. WITHOUT ANY CENTER ARE
PACKED TO PERSONALLY. A CAREFUL
ASSESSMENT OF PEEL'SNINE
PRINCIPLES WOULD REVEAL FALL
KEY POINTS OUR VIEWS ON THE
MISSION OF THE POLICE. FOR
EXAMPLE I'M NOT PARAPHRASING
HERE PRINCIPLE NUMBER ONE
ACCORDING IMPACTS THIS MISSION
IS TO PREVENT CRIME AND
DISORDER AS AN ALTERNATIVE TO
THE REPRESSION OF CRIME AND
DISORDER BY MILITARY FORCE. I'M
SIERRA T. OF LEGAL PUNISHMENTS.
THE AVAILABILITY OF PARTNERSHIP
BETWEEN THE POLICE AND THE
COMMUNITY ACCESS RIGHT IN
PRINCIPLE NUMBER SEVEN. YOU
FACE POLICE SHOULD MAINTAIN A
RELATIONSHIP WITH THE PUBLIC
BUT GIVES A REALITY TO THE
HISTORIC TRADITION. BUT THE
POLICE ARE THE PUBLIC AND THE
PUBLIC ARE THE POLICE THE
POLICE ARE THE ONLY MEMBERS OF
THE PUBLIC WHO ARE IT'S TO GIVE
FULL ATTENTION. TO DUTIES WHICH
ARE INCUMBENT ON EVERY CITIZEN
IN THE INTENT OF THE COMMUNITY
WELL FRET. PROMOTING FAIRNESS
AND HUMAN RELATIONS IN POLICING.
I'M NOT KEY PRINCIPLE FIVE. THE
POLICE SEEK ARMED RESERVE
PUBLIC FAVOR FOR. BY OFFERING
OF INDIVIDUAL SERVICE AND
FRIENDSHIP TO ALL MEMBERS OF
SOCIETY WITHOUT REGARD TO THEIR
RACE ALL SOCIAL STANDING. IT
ALSO TALK ABOUT THE USE OF
CONFLICT RESOLUTION SKILLS
AREN'T THE ESCALATION OF FORCE
PRINCIPLE NUMBER SEVEN. BUT A
POLICE USED PHYSICAL FORCE ONLY
WHEN THE EXERCISE OF COURSE
WISHIN ADVISE I'M WARMING IS
FOUND TO BE INSUFFICIENT TO
CHIEF POLICE OBJECTIVES. THE US
POLICIES OUT BALCONY PROVED
PEOPLE'S PRINCIPLES OF LAW
ENFORCEMENT ABOUT THE LATE
NINETEENTH CENTURY POST LIBRARY
AREA. BUT HE DIDN'T TOTALLY
IT'S KEPT THE PRE EXISTING
SOCIO ECONOMIC INEQUITIES AND
RACIAL DISCRIMINATION IN THE
COUNTRY. ESPECIALLY IN A LESS
DISORGANIZED AND LOCAL. POLICE
FORMATIONS. ATTEMPTS AT U. S.
POLICE. ASTRUM BY AUGUST FORM
THE FIRST POLICE CHIEF IN BO.
OUR REGARD AS THE FATHER OF
MODERN AMERICAN POLICE STATE.
AGAIN MARK WITHOUT SOME CRITICS
FOCUSED ON IF PROFESSIONAL
MODEL OF POLICING THAT HAS LED
TO THE CREATION OF CRIMINAL
JUSTICE PROGRAMS THROUGHOUT THE
COUNTRY. ESPECIALLY SINCE THE
TWENTIETH CENTURY. RESULTING IN
THE CREATION OF SPECIALIZED
MISSION USE OF TECHNOLOGY IN
POLICING HOW ARE THESE
PROFESSIONAL MODEL ALONG WITH
THE REQUIREMENTS OF FORMAL
HIGHER EDUCATION APPLICATION OF
CIVIL SERVICE FROM THAT'S IN
POLICE RECRUITMENT. AND HIRING.
BIG GAPS HOWEVER OF THE
PROFESSIONAL ERA OF POLICING IN
THE AREA OF CREATING PUBLIC
ALIENATION MOVING MORE TOWARD
REACTIVE AGAINST WERE ACTIVE
POLICING. ORGANIZED AS A PARA
MILITARY HOST CHORE ALL UNIT
PART OF MINISTRY'S POSTER. AND
THE PERSISTENT CRIME PROBLEM.
HAVE LED TO CALLS FOR A RETURN.
ALL REQUESTED. OFF P. O.'S
FUNDAMENTAL VIEW OFF POLICE
NOTABLY. I HASSIDIC ARE
PROMISING YOUR SECURITY SOME OF
THE NINETEENTH AND TWENTIETH.
WHAT IS BEING. IN TWO A TWENTY
FIRST POLICY. OFF IT OFFICE
SERVICE WITH A MISSION
OPERATIVE PROACTIVE POLICING IN
COLLABORATION AND COOPERATION
WITH THE COMMUNITY IN
DIFFERENT- PROTECTION OFF LIVES
AND LIVELIHOODS. ALTHOUGH THE
APPEALS OF LAW ENFORCEMENT CAN
BE CRITICS ASK OUR HISTORICAL
ALL LIMITED IN THE CURRENT
STOCK FOR RACIAL INJUSTICE OF
CRIMINAL JUSTICE IN THE UNITED
STATES. A CALIFORNIA ASSESSMENT
ANALYSIS UP THE PRINCIPLES WE
FIND THAT THEY RESULTED FROM
SIMILAR HORAN'S US
CIRCUMSTANCES OF HISTORIC
CHANGES AND TRANSFORMATIONS
RESISTANCE INCREASING
INEQUALITIES. HENCE IT COULD
SERVE AS A USEFUL LET THANKS
FOR THINKING OF THE WHAT ARE
CALLED THE FIVE CRITICAL PIECE.
OF ANY POLICE REFORM. POLICY
WHY POORLY WHAT ARE THE GOALS
OF. AS WE BE SHOULDN'T POLICE
PROCEDURES HOW DO WE ENFORCE
ALL CORRECTED IN KEEPING WITH
THAT MISSION ON. HOW DO WE
ENSURE ACCOUNTABILITY TO PUBLIC
INSTITUTIONS. ACCESS THIS. WHAT
ARE WE USUALLY ACTUALLY JOINT
WHAT ARE THE KEY LESSONS I'M
CHALLENGES. PERSONNEL WHO ARE
WE HIRING WHAT THE BACKGROUND
ONE OF THE ATTITUDES AND
APTITUDES WHAT TYPES OF SKILLS
AND EXPERIENCES. PROGRAMS WHAT
ARE WE DOING FOR RECRUITMENT
RETENTION RE APPLICATION
REPLACEMENT I'M TRAINING AS
WELL AS RETRAINING. IN
CONCLUSION THE PROBLEM OFFICE
LISTING OPTIMIZED DEMOCRATIC
SOCIETY BENEFITS FROM GLOBAL
THINKING IN LOCAL APPLICATIONS
ESPECIALLY WHEN THE
CIRCUMSTANCES ARE CONDITIONS
ARE SAME OR EQUIVALENT. WOW
RACIALIZED POLICING IS THE
UNIQUE EURAMERICA PROBLEM OKAY
LEGACY OF RACISM ANTI BLACKNESS.
POLICE BRUTALITY WHETHER FORMAL
OR INFORMAL IT'S MORE OF AN
ISSUE OF POWER IMBALANCE I'M
VULNERABILITY IN ALL CULTURES
AND COUNTRIES. ABDUCTING A
COMMITTEE OLYMPIC RESTORATIVE
JUSTICE APPROACH ALL DO ALL MIL
MORE HARM. I MISS MOST
PROMISING FOR SUSTAINABLE
JUSTICE REFORM BEYOND THE
APARTMENT GEORGE FLOYD MORMONS
I'M PUBLIC PRESSURE. FOR MANY
FOR REFORM TO A COURT. THERE
HAS TO BE THE POLITICAL WILL.
YEAH LEGISLATIVE MANDATES AND
BOTH PUBLISHED FOR LEADERSHIP
FOR POLICE ACCOUNTABILITY. I
CAUTION AGAINST IT WEEK FIX FOR
THE MORAL PUBLIC. ROBERT PEEL
HIMSELF ALSO THESE WHEN HE
DESCRIBED PUBLIC WHAT'S PUBLIC
OPINION IS A COMPOUND- FULLY
WEAKNESS PREJUDICE RANK FEELING
RIGHT FEELING OBSTINACY AND
NEWSPAPER HERACROSS ASKING HE-
REMINDED US THAT AT THE TIME. I
HAVE OBSERVED THAT TRUE DURABLE
CHANGES. MULTI DIMENSIONAL AND
DELIBERATE TO ACHIEVE THEIR
COLLECTIVE CONSCIENCE. ROBERT
PEEL IN CONCLUSION ALSO REMIND
SOFT INPUT OUTPUT AGITATION IS
THE MARSHALLING OF THE
CONSCIENCE OF THE NATION TO
MOLD IS LAWS SORRY BUT PEOPLE
BEGAN COMMENTING AT THE MOMENT
SIMILAR WHERE WE ARE AT THIS
POINT. THANK YOU FOR THE
OPPORTUNITY TO SHARE MY VIEWS
AND I LOOK FORWARD TO THE
EXCHANGES AND AB OPPORTUNITIES
FOR COLLABORATION AND
PARTNERSHIP. WITH CALIFORNIA
STATE UNIVERSITY SACRAMENTO I'M
ALL ABOUT STAKEHOLDERS. THANK
YOU IS THAT YOU. THANK YOU VERY
THANK YOU VERY MUCH DOCTOR
LOUSY- FOR YOUR TESTIMONY
REALLY APPRECIATES YOUR
ACADEMIC PERSPECTIVE ON- THE
NINE PRINCIPLES OF POLICING
THANK YOU VERY MUCH RECEIVED A
LOT FROM THAT. I ALSO WANT TO
MAKE A WAIT LET THE MEMBERS
KNOW THAT AFTER THESE
PRESENTATIONS- WE WILL HAVE NO
Q. AND A DURING THIS SEGMENT-
BUT THE FOLLOWING PRESENTATIONS
WE WILL HAVE Q. AND A- THIS IS
INFORMATION AND TO HELP BRING
US UP TO DATE IN TERMS OF THE
NINE PRINCIPLES OF POLICING SO
WITH THAT BEING SAID. I WANT TO
INTRODUCE WHO WILL BE WHO WAS
IN THE MEETING ROOM PHYSICALLY
MISS TANYA FAISON- WHO WILL
PROVIDE HER TESTIMONY HER
PERSPECTIVE IN THIS AREA. SO
PLEASE INTRODUCE YOURSELVES AND
THANK YOU YES PLEASE ENTITIES
OUT THANK YOU VERY MUCH FOR
BEING HERE- AND YOU HAVE EIGHT
MINUTES AS WELL THANK YOU. CAN
WE CUT OUR MICROPHONE ON OR DO
I.
JUST BEAR WITH US FOR A FEW
MOMENTS WE'LL GET TOGETHER.
WHAT IS THE TO CLEAN IT UP THE
SHOULD FINISH. TESTIS VERY GOOD
THANK YOU VERY MUCH. THANK YOU
FOR BEARING WITH US MISS MAYES
ALL NO PROBLEM CAN YOU HEAR ME
THAT WE CAN HERE WELL THANK YOU
FOR IT PLEASE PROCEED OKAY CELL
GOOD MORNING EVERYBODY AND
THANK YOU FOR ALLOWING ME TO BE
IN THE SPACE TODAY- I WANT TO
START OFF BY SAYING THAT I WANT
TO EMPHASIZE MY DISCOMFORT AND
RELYING ON- AN EXAMPLE OF A MAN
THAT HAS NOT EXPERIENCED TRAUMA
FROM POLICE VIOLENCE. AS AN
EXAMPLE OF WHAT WE SHOULD BE
USING AS POLICE STANDARDS- I
BELIEVE THAT THE COMMUNITY
SHOULD BE THE COMMUNITY THAT'S
MOST IMPACTED SHOULD LEAD THIS
BUT HE DID SAY SOME GOOD THINGS
SO I WILL ADDRESS SOME OF THE
STATEMENTS THAT HE MADE- THE
SECOND THING THAT I WANT TO
STATE TO IS THAT I AM AN
ABOLITIONIST AND WHILE I'M
AWARE THAT THE SYSTEM IS NOT
GONNA CHANGE OVERNIGHT AND- WE
DO NEED TO HAVE REFORMS THAT
ARE IN PLACE AND IT'S HARD TO
BREATHE AT THIS ON- THE REFORMS
NEED TO LEAN INTO COMMUNITY.
AND SO WHEN I SAY THAT I MEAN
THEY NEED TO PUT COMMUNITY ON A
PEDESTAL. THEY NEED TO- HAVE
COMMUNITY OVERSEEING EVERYTHING
AND- THEY NEED TO BE- THE DAY
COMMUTING TO BE LEADING IN THE
DETERMINANT FACTOR. THESE ARE
THE KIND OF REFORMS THAT ARE
GOING TO ACTUALLY MAKE THE
CHANGES THAT WE NEED. NOT IN
RESPONSE TO THE POLICING
PRINCIPLES BY SIR ROBERT PEEL
I'M GOING TO PROVIDE MORE
CONTEXT TO CONTEXT ON BEHALF OF
THE MOST IMPACTED. IN REGARDS
TO THE STATE OF POLICING AS IT
IS TODAY. RELATIONSHIPS BETWEEN
LOCAL LAW ENFORCEMENT AND OUR
ELECTED OFFICIALS SO WE HAVE
CHECKS AND BALANCES PUT IN
PLACE IN ORDER TO MAKE SURE
THAT OUR POLICE ARE HELD
ACCOUNTABLE. BUT IT IS VERY
PROBLEMATIC WHEN YOU HAVE FOR
EXAMPLE A SHERIFF AND A DA THAT
OUR FRIENDS. GOING TO BARBECUES
IN DOING THINGS OUTSIDE OF WORK
TOGETHER. BUILDING
RELATIONSHIPS IN BEING BEHOLDEN
TO EACH OTHER THERE'S NO
ACCOUNTABILITY THAT CAN BE HAD
WHEN RELATIONSHIPS ARE BUILT
LIKE THAT. ANOTHER EXAMPLE
WOULD BE THE CITY MANAGER AND
THE POLICE BUT THE POLICE CHIEF
SO. THOSE ARE EXAMPLES OF
RELATIONSHIPS. BETWEEN LAW
ENFORCEMENT AND IT'S CHECKS AND
BALANCES THAT ARE. NOT HELPFUL
TO GETTING ACCOUNTABILITY. ALSO
POLICIES AND LEGISLATION THAT
DOES NOT INCLUDE REPERCUSSIONS
ATTACHED TO THEM. SO WE'VE HAD
A LOT OF GOOD BILLS COME OUT
WE'VE HAD A LOT OF POLICY
CHANGES HERE LOCALLY IN
SACRAMENTO. BUT IF THEY'RE NOT
INCLUDING ANY TYPE OF
REPERCUSSION OR ACCOUNTABILITY.
INSIDE OF THOSE POLICIES IN
THEIR VIOLATED AND THERE'S
NOTHING THAT HAPPENS WE'VE SEEN
EVERYTHING THAT'S COME FORTH
SINCE I'VE BEEN DOING THIS WORK
GET VIOLATED AND THERE'S NEVER
ANY REPERCUSSIONS. IN THE
COMMUNITY NEEDS TO SEE THE
REPERCUSSIONS THE COMMUNITY
NEEDS TO IN ORDER TO BUILD THIS
TRUST THAT WE'RE TALKING ABOUT
BUILDING BETWEEN LAW
ENFORCEMENT AND CAR OUR
COMMUNITIES WE NEED TO BE ABLE
TO SEE THE ACCOUNTABILITY PIECE.
ALSO VETTING OFFICERS- FOR
INVOLVEMENT WITH. WHITE
NATIONALIST GROUPS AND OR
MALICIOUS I PERSONALLY KNOW TWO
OFFICERS IN THE SACRAMENTO
POLICE DEPARTMENT THAT ARE
ASSOCIATED WITH WHITE
SUPREMACIST GROUPS. ONE HAS AN
EIGHTY EIGHT TATTOOED ON HIS
HAND WITH THE DIAMOND TIPS
WHICH STANDS FOR IT'S A HOW
HITLER TATTOO. AND THEN OTHERS
USE LANGUAGE CALLED OUR ALLIES
REYES TRADERS SO IF WE'RE NOT
HAVING A PROCESS TO VET OUR
OFFICERS ON. THEIR INVOLVEMENT
WITH WHITE SUPREMACISTS EITHER
CULTURE ORGANIZATIONS THEN
WE'RE FAILING BECAUSE IT'S
ATTRACTIVE TO THOSE TYPES TO BE
IN LAW ENFORCEMENT AND TO HAVE
THE POWER TO KILL BLACK PEOPLE
AND NOT BE HELD ACCOUNTABLE FOR
IT. ALSO THE MENTALITY OF LAW
ENFORCEMENT THAT THEY'RE AT WAR
WITH THE PEOPLE. THEY'RE TAKING
THE SENTIMENT THE CENTER THAN
SENTIMENT TO THE STREETS WHEN
THEY'RE COMING TO OUR PROTESTER
COMING TO OUR MARCHES WERE
EXERCISING OUR FIRST AMENDMENT
RIGHTS. THEY'RE SHOOTING OUR
CHILDREN IN THE FACE WITH
RUBBER BULLETS. THEY'RE
SHOOTING OUR FOLKS IN THE HEAD
WITH A RUBBER BULLETS OVER THIS
LAST COUPLE MONTHS WE HAD THREE
MAJOR INJURIES AT THE HANDS OF
LAW ENFORCEMENT ONE WAS A
THIRTEEN YEAR OLD THAT WAS SHOT
IN THIS IS FACING HE BROKE HIS
CHEEKBONE. WITH A RUBBER BULLET
AND IT'S AND I JUST WANT TO
EMPHASIZE THE FACT THAT IT
SEEMS LIKE ALL OF THESE.
INCIDENTS OUR OFFICERS AIMING
AT THE FACE IN THE HEAD OF
PEOPLE WITH BULLETS THAT THEY
THINK ARE LEAST LESS LEGAL
FORMS OF FORCE BUT THEY CAN
BECOME. LEGAL IN THAT WAY. ON
THE SECOND WAS- A SACRAMENTO
RESIDENT. THAT WAS SHOT SIX
TIMES IN THE HEAD WITH RUBBER
BULLETS HAVEN'T HAD A- A
FRACTURED SCHOOL AND HAD TO
HAVE SURGERY. AND THEN LASTLY
AT ONE OF OUR PROTESTS- A
TEENAGE GIRL WAS SHOT IN HER
EYES SHE'S NO LONGER ABLE TO
pOF HER LIFE. SO THIS IS THE
KIND OF VIOLENCE THAT WE'RE
FACING ONE WERE. ACTUALLY
PROTESTING THE VIOLENCE THAT
WE'VE BEEN FACING. WHERE WERE
BEING MET WITH THE EXACT SAME
VIOLENCE THAT WERE THAT WERE
TRYING TO STOP HAVING HAPPENED.
AND I ALSO WANT TO EMPHASIZE
THE FACT THAT THERE HAVE BEEN
PROTESTS. FOR FOLKS THAT
SUPPORT DONALD TRUMP ON A
WEEKLY BASIS AND THEY ARE NOT
MET WITH THAT SAME BY VIOLENCE
SO THERE'S DEFINITELY A RACIAL
BIAS. WHEN IT COMES TO YOU KNOW
WHITE FOLKS GOING UP TO THE
CAPITOL AND ACTING VIOLENT
TOWARD COMMUNITY. THERE IS NO
NATIONAL GUARD BEING CALLED.
THERE IS NO RUBBER BULLETS
BEING SHOT. THERE IS NO
HELICOPTERS THERE IS NO
VIOLENCE FROM LAW ENFORCEMENT-
SO I JUST WANT TO EMPHASIZE
THAT AS WELL. ALSO UNITS LIKE
IN EVERY POLICE DEPARTMENT HAS
THESE BUT LIKE THE GANG TASK OR
GANG ENFORCEMENT TEAMS GETTING
TASK UNITS- TEAMS LKE POP
UNITS PROBLEM ORIENTED POLICING
UNITS. THESE UNITS GOING TO
THEY SPECIFICALLY AND
INTENTIONALLY GOING TO BLACK
AND BROWN COMMUNITIES TO
SPECIFICALLY AND INTENTIONALLY
RACIALLY PROFILE PEOPLE BASED
ON THINGS LIKE HAIRSTYLES AND
CLOTHING CHOICES THINGS THAT
AREN'T NECESSARILY PARTICULAR
TO GANG MEMBERS OR EVEN TO
BLACK AND BROWN PEOPLE. AND
THERE'S A LOT OF VIOLENCE IN
OUR COMMUNITY. THAT ISN'T
CONNECTED TO THE ACTIVISTS BUT
YOU KNOW THE VIOLENCE AN
ACTIVIST COMMUNITY BUT THERE'S
A LOT OF VIOLENCE IN OUR BLACK
AND BROWN COMMUNITIES BECAUSE
OF THESE TEAMS AND THEIR
AUTHORITY IN THEIR POWER AND
THEIR THEIR LACK OF ANY TYPE OF
CONNECTION TO THESE
COMMUNITIES. THEY DON'T LIVE IN
THESE COMMUNITIES THEY DON'T
CARE ABOUT THESE PEOPLE THEY
DON'T LOOK LIKE THE PEOPLE THAT
THEY'RE POLICING AND SO THAT
THAT HAS GOT TO BE SOMETHING
THAT IS REFORMED. ALSO WE SEE A
LOT OF. PROCRASTINATION AND IT
SEEMS VERY INTENTIONAL BY LOCAL
ELECTED OFFICIALS-
PROCRASTINATION AND GETTING ANY
TYPE OF RESOLUTION. AND THE
PROCRASTINATION COMES IN THE
FORM OF. COMMUNICATING WITH
EACH OTHER LET'S TALK ABOUT
THIS LET'S HAVE PUBLIC INPUT
AND THEN WE GIVE THE PUBLIC
INPUT AND THEN NO CHANGES ARE
MADE OR WE GET PROMISES AND
THEN NOT FOLLOWED BY CHANGES OR
WE GET YOU KNOW PERFORMATIVE
TYPE OF REACTIONS TO WHAT'S
GOING ON IN THE WORLD BUT AND
THEN WE GET PROMISES AFTER THAT
AND THERE ARE NO CHANGES WE'VE
GOT. WE'VE GOT MAYORS AND OTHER
ELECTED OFFICIALS GOING INTO
BLACK COMMUNITIES AND GOING TO
BLACK CHURCHES AND KNEELING
WITH BLACK PEOPLE AND THEN
THEY'RE NOT DOING ANYTHING
AFTER THAT AND THEN THAT NIGHT
SOMEBODY MAY GET SHOT IN THE
FACE OF THE RUBBER BULLET. SO
THOSEARE THE- TYPES I DON'T
KNOW WHAT REFORM COULD BE PUT
IN PLACE FOR THAT BUT- THERE
NEEDS TO BE. ACCOUNTABILITY ON
EVERY SINGLE LEVEL- IN THE
STATE THAT KILLS THE MOST
PEOPLE BY LAW ENFORCEMENT. YOUR
ONE ONE MINUTE ONE MINUTE THANK
YOU- OKAY SO. THE OLICE WILL
CONTINUE TO MURDER US AS A
FIRST RESORT AS LONG AS THEY
ARE NOT BEING PUNISHED FOR
THEIR ACTIONS- WE'VE DANCED
AROUND EVERY SUGGESTION BUT FOR
SOME REASON INTENTIONALLY AVOID
THE ONE THING THAT WILL STOP
THIS ALL AND THAT'S ANY TYPE OF
PUNISHMENT FOR THE ACTIONS OF
JUST LIKE A CIVILIAN IF THEY
KILLED SOMEBODY AND IT WAS
WRONGFUL THEN THERE WOULD BE A
PUNISHMENT. I'M A LOT OF TIMES
YOU HEAR PEOPLE SAYING GET RID
OF THE UNIONS AND THAT IS
SOMETHING THAT'S NECESSARY WE
STILL HAVE WE WILL STILL HAVE
INTERNAL RELATIONSHIPS. AT THAT
WILL CONFLICT WITH THAT. A LOT
OF PEOPLE ARE SAYING- OR I'M
SAYING RIGHT NOW WE SHOULD
LIMIT INTERNAL INTERNAL
RELATIONSHIPS AS NECESSARY BUT
EVEN IN DOING THAT WILL STILL
NEED POLICIES THAT HAVE
REPERCUSSIONS INCLUDED. I'M A
LOT OF FOLKS WILL SAY THAT
DIVERSITY AND TRAINING IS
NECESSARY TO FIX THESE PROBLEMS
AND I'D LIKE TO LASTLY QUOTE- A
MEMBER OF OUR GROUP HIS NAME IS
VICTOR BRAZELTON AND ONE OF THE
DEMANDS THAT WE GAVE TO. OUR
MAYOR IS THAT. THE COMMISSION
SHOULD NO LONGER BE USED AS A
TOOL OF THE POLICE DEPARTMENT
TO SEE DIVERSITY TO POLICING
WHEN WE KNOW THAT THIS IS
POLICING ITSELF THAT IS THE
ISSUE. COMMUNITY MEMBERS
GETTING MURDERED BY BLACK
POLICE OFFICERS IS NOT THE
ANSWER TO THE COULD THAT THE
COMMUNITY IS LOOKING FOR- AND
THEN LASTLY. I KNOW THAT WE
HAVE A NEW APPOINTMENT OF AN
ATTORNEY GENERAL THAT'S GOING
TO HAPPEN SOON BY THE MAYOR.
I'M SORRY THE GOVERNOR AM I
LIKE TO EMPHASIZE THAT WE NEED
TO HAVE SOMEBODY PUT IN THAT
POSITION. THAT WORKS HARD IN
STANDS FOR ACCOUNTABILITY. OF
OUR POLICE DEPARTMENTS AND LAW
ENFORCEMENT AGENCIES THANK YOU
THANK YOU VERY MUCH MISS PHASE
ON FOR YOUR- FOR YOUR
TESTIMONY- IN YOUR POWERFUL
VOICE FOR THE COMMUNITY WE ARE
REALLY REALLY APPRECIATE THAT.
MEMBERS I JUST WANTED TO. THIS
WAS SETTING THE STAGE- THAT'S
WHY THESE INDIVIDUALS FROM THE
COMMUNITY SPOKE. SO WE'LL BE
MOVING. THE PORTION WE CAN DO
QUESTIONS AND ANSWERS- AS WE
MOVE THROUGH THE AGENDA SO WITH
THAT BEING SAID ALSO- MISTER-
THE PATENT OF THE PREVIOUS
SPEAKERS SPOKE THIS IS NOT A
QUICK FIX AYE ONE UNDERSCORE
THIS IS NOT A QUICK FIX WE'RE
GOING THROUGH THIS AND WE'RE
GOING THROUGH THIS IN ORDER TO
TEACH HIM WITHOUT A GOAL WAY-
TO BRING COMMUNITY AND OTHERS
INVOLVED INTO TRYING TO HELP US
RESOLVE SOME OF THESE ISSUES
SO. I JUST WANTED TO UNDERSTAND
OR- THE GOOD DOCTOR FOR SAYING
THIS IS NOT A QUICK FIX IS
GOING TO TAKE SOME TIME AND
WE'RE GOING TO INVEST THE TIME
INTO MAKING THIS HAPPEN SO WITH
THAT BEING SAID AGAIN THANK
THOSE- FOR SPEAKING ON BEHALF
OF THE COMMUNITY WE WILL HEAR
FROM OUR THIRD PRESENTER-
MISTER. ALI KHAN I WANT TO
THANK YOU VERY MUCH FOR- THIS
IS THE SECOND TIME- THIS HE WAS
AT OUR VERY FIRST HEARING SPOKE
VERY TORRENTE HARDLY THERE IS
EXPERTISE AND WE'RE HAPPY TO
HAVE YOU BACK AGAIN- FOUGHT FOR
THIS PADDLE- FOR THIS- FOR THIS
SEGMENT- WHO WILL BE JOINING US
I PARTICIPATING VIRTUALLY
SOMALI CON AGAIN WELCOME YES.
EIGHT MINUTES AND PLEASE
PROCEED. THANK YOU MISTER. AND
MEMBER OF THE SLOW COMMITTEE-
FEEDBACK DISCUSS. THE ISSUE OF
POLICE REFORM. HOW
PROFESSIONALISM IS AT THE CORE
OF AFFECTED POLICING AND
IMPORTANTLY THE STATE'S ROLE IN
CREATING THE SYSTEMS NECESSARY
TO ENABLE PROFESSIONALISM. THAT
CAN HELP BUILD PUBLIC TRUST
REDUCE USES OF FORCE TO PROTECT
COMMUNITIES CRIME. THROUGH MY
PROFESSIONAL AND ACADEMIC
EXPERIENCE AS A FORMER FEDERAL
PROSECUTOR A SENIOR POLICY
OFFICIAL A LAW SCHOOL GRADUATE
SCHOOL PROFESSOR AND DIRECTOR
OF SPECIALIZED POLICE AGENCY
AND ALSO WAS AN LAPD OFFICIAL
RESPONSIBLE FOR REFORM EFFORTS.
I HAVE LEARNED IN BELIEVE THERE
ARE THREE ESSENTIAL COMPONENTS
TO MEANINGFUL REFORM. FIRST
MEANINGFUL REFORM MUST ADDRESS
THE CORE FUNCTIONS OF POLICING
AND FOCUS ON THE QUALITY OF
OFFICERS WHO WERE RECRUITED AND
CERTIFIED TO SERVE IN THESE
IMPORTANT ROLES. THE STANDARDS
WHILE AN OFFICER IN THE
ACCOUNTABILITY AND OVERSIGHT
NECESSARY TO ENSURE COMPLIANCE.
SECOND REFORMS MUST ENABLE
AGENCIES TO PERFORM ITS CORE
FUNCTION OF PROTECTING
COMMUNITIES FROM CORPORATE FROM
CRIME. WELL STRENGTHENING THE
PUBLIC'S TRUST THROUGH
COMMUNITY PARTNERSHIPS
CONSTITUTIONAL POLICING AND
PURSUING JUSTICE FOR VICTIMS
THROUGH FAIR AND UNBIASED
ENFORCEMENT OF THE LAW. IN
MEANINGFUL REFORMS MUST BE
BASED ON PROVEN EVIDENCE BASED
SOLUTIONS THAT ARE PRACTICAL
AND CAN BE APPLIED FOR LONG
TERM IMPACT. AS I MENTIONED IN
MY TESTIMONY ON OCTOBER
FOURTEENTH PROFESSIONALISM IN
THE SYSTEMS AND STRUCTURES OF
PROFESSIONALISM THAT ALREADY
EXIST FOR THE PROFESSIONS WE
KNOW AND RESPECT SUCH AS BEING
IN SUCH AS DOCTORS. LAWYERS
ENGINEERS AND THE TEACHERS AND
TEACHERS ARE THE KEY TO
ACHIEVING THESE ELEMENTS OF
MEANINGFUL REFORM IN POLICING.
WE KNOW THIS BOTH FROM OUR OWN
COLLECTIVE EXPERIENCE THE
EXPERIENCE OF AGENCIES THAT
HAVE MADE PROGRESS ON REFORM
THROUGH CONSENT DECREES IN
ORGANIZATIONAL LEADERSHIP LIKE
THE LAPD. AND WITH OVER FORTY
YEARS OF SOUND ACADEMIC
RESEARCH. WHY IS IT THAT
PROFESSIONALISM POLICING IN
ESSENCE IS SO IMPORTANT AND I
STRONGLY BELIEVE WILL HAVE A
POSITIVE IMPACT ESPECIALLY THE
EDUCATIONAL QUALIFICATIONS TO
BE CONSIDERED. AND WHY ARE THEY
SO IMPORTANT. IS BECAUSE AT ITS
CORE THE DISCIPLINE OF POLICING
IS NOT ABOUT USING FORCE MAKING
ARRESTS CONDUCTING SEARCHES OR
EVEN ISSUING CITATIONS THOSE
ARE THE TOOLS AND THE POWERS
THAT WE AS A SOCIETY GIVE TO
POLICE OFFICERS AND ARE
AVAILABLE TO THEM. BUT AT ITS
CORE THE DISCIPLINE OF POLICING
IS ABOUT SOLVING PROBLEMS AND
MAKING CONSEQUENTIAL DECISIONS
TO USE THOSE TOOLS AND POWERS.
USING KNOWLEDGE IN CRIMINOLOGY
PSYCHOLOGY HISTORY THE LAW IN
THE MANY OTHER PHYSICAL AND
SOCIAL SCIENCES THAT ACTUALLY
FORM THE FOUNDATION OF
POLICING. AND THE SKILLS THAT
ARE NEEDED TO BE A GOOD POLICE
OFFICER IN SOLVING THOSE
PROBLEMS. WHETHER YOU TO MAKE
AN ARREST ISSUE CITATION SEARCH
IN INDIVIDUAL SOLVE A CRIME IT
REQUIRES CRITICAL THINKING IT
REQUIRES ANALYSIS AND MOST
IMPORTANTLY IT REQUIRES
EXERCISING GOOD JUDGMENT TO
MAKE THE RIGHT DECISION.
ESPECIALLY THE DECISION TO
PRESS THE TRIGGER OF A FIREARM.
AND USE DEADLY FORCE POLICING
IS A SOPHISTICATED IN COMPLEX
JOB AND ITS COMPLEXITIES ARE
INCREASING EVERY DAY. YET THE
POLICING PROFESSION IN THE
STATE OF CALIFORNIA DOES NOT
REQUIRE THE EDUCATIONAL
FOUNDATION THAT DEVELOPS THESE
CAPABILITIES AND INSTEAD RELIES
TOO MUCH ON A SIX MONTH ACADEMY
FOR INDIVIDUAL AGENCIES
DEVELOPING THE STRUCTURES
NECESSARY. TO PROMOTE
PROFESSIONALISM. THE OF A SUS
TRUST. LIKE DOCTORS ENGINEERS
TEACHERS NURSES AND YES EVEN
LAWYERS. IS TO HELP US WITH
THESE MANY SENSITIVE
INCONSEQUENTIAL PROBLEMS LIKE A
MEDICAL EMERGENCY A LEGAL
CLAIM. WE'RE TEACHING CARING
FOR OUR CHILDREN ALSO APPLYING
POLICING WE PLACE OUR TRUST IN
THOSE PROFESSIONS BECAUSE THERE
ARE REQUIREMENTS AND
EXPECTATIONS. THAT DOCTORS
LAWYERS AND ENGINEERS ARE
EDUCATED AT THE COLLEGE OF
GRADUATE LEVEL IN THEIR FIELD
OF STUDY BEFORE THEY'RE GRANTED
A LICENSE THAT THEY'RE ONLY
LICENSE AFTER PROVEN
UNDERSTANDING OF THEIR
DISCIPLINES. THAT THEY'VE
ESTABLISHED PROFICIENCY IN
THEIR KEY PROFESSIONAL SKILLS
AND CAPABILITIES. THAT THEY OWN
THERE ARE WELL DEFINED
PERFORMANCE STANDARDS THERE
WERE ENFORCEABLE REQUIREMENTS
TO ADHERE TO ETHICAL CODES AND
THAT THERE ARE SYSTEMS OF
ACCOUNTABILITY AND OVERSIGHT.
NOT JUST AT THE MICRO LEVEL
WITHIN THE COMMUNITY BUT
THROUGHOUT THE STATE. WE ALSO
HAVE PROFESSIONALS BECAUSE THEY
ARE EXPECT WE ALSO RESPECT
PROFESSIONALS BECAUSE THEY ARE
EXPECTED TO BE UNBIASED ACT
WITH INTEGRITY EMPATHETIC TO
OUR NEEDS AND CONCERNS AND
EXERCISE EXCELLENT JUDGMENT
BASED ON THEIR- EXPERTISE. THE
CHALLENGES THE REFORM WE ARE
FACING CURRENTLY ARE NOT SIMPLY
A FUNCTION OF ROOTING OUT THE
BAD APPLES WITHIN AN AGENCY IT
IS MUCH BROADER AND WE NEED TO
RECRUIT CERTIFY AND FURTHER
DEVELOP OFFICERS TO MAKE GOOD
DECISIONS UNDER VERY DIFFICULT
CIRCUMSTANCES. THEY'D USE
CRITICAL THINKING SKILLS TO
DIFFERENT THE TO CONSIDER
DIFFERENT OPTIONS IDEAS AND
PERSPECTIVES THAT COMMUNICATE
AND COLLABORATE WITH OTHERS AND
THAT HAVE VERY GOOD DECISION
MAKING SKILLS IN MAKING THESE
POWERFUL. EXERCISING THEIR
DISCRETION TO TAKE AWAY- THE
LIBERTY OR LIFE OF SOMEONE. WE
OF COURSE NEED OFFICERS WITH
DEEP KNOWLEDGE AND SKILL
EXPERTISE RESILIENCE PATIENCE
AND PROFESSIONAL MATURITY BUT
MOST IMPORTANTLY CRITICAL
THINKING AND PROBLEM SOLVING
SKILLS AND CAPABILITIES. ARE SO
CRITICAL ARE SO ESSENTIAL. SO
THE MOST SIGNIFICANT ELEMENT OF
PROFESSIONALISM THAT IS LACKING
IN THE ENTRY LEVEL STANDARDS IS
OF COURSE A COLLEGE EDUCATION.
A HIGH SCHOOL DIPLOMA IS
INSUFFICIENT FOR ANY PROFESSION
LET ALONE A PROFESSION OF SUCH
A VAST DISCRETION COMPLEXITY
AND THE NEED FOR PUBLIC TRUST
AS POLICING. AND WHILE SOME
INCENTIVES EXISTING AGENCIES IT
IS NOT UNIFORM IT ONLY FORMS A
SMALL PERCENTAGE OF MANY
AGENCIES. AND MOST IMPORTANTLY
THIS IS NOT A NEW NOVEL OR
SPECULATIVE IDEA IT IS BASED ON
EVIDENCE AND RESEARCH THAT
SPANS ALMOST FORTY YEARS. THE
SITE THERE'S MANY CITATIONS IN
THE WORK OF WILLIAM TERREL IN
OTHER PROFESSORS AND SOME OF
THE PROPOSED LEGISLATION AND
FRAMEWORKS WILL OR ACT IN THE
CALIFORIA POLICE CHIEFS
ASSOCIATION WHICH IS REALLY
PROMISING. BUT THE EMPIRICAL
RESEARCH HAS FOUND THAT
OFFICERS OF THE FOR YOUR
COLLEGE EDUCATION HAVE MORE
POSITIVE RELATIONSHIPS WITH
COMMUNITIES THAN THOSE WITH
ONLY A HIGH SCHOOL EDUCATION.
ARE BETTER PROBLEM SOLVERS AND
INNOVATORS A BETTER
COMMUNICATION SKILLS BOTH
VERBAL AND WRITTEN. ARE MORE
OPEN MINDED TO DIFFERENT
PERSPECTIVES AND IDEAS RECEIVE
BETTER PERFORMANCE EVALUATIONS
FROM THEIR SUPERVISORS AND
POLICE LEADERSHIP HAVE FEWER
CITIZEN COMPLAINTS AND
DISCIPLINARY ACTIONS. AND VERY
IMPORTANTLY YOU SIGNIFICANTLY
LESS FORMS OF FORCE IN OTHER
FORMS OF COERCION TO GAIN
COMPLIANCE. THERE IS MORE
EVIDENCE THAT A FOUR YEAR
COLLEGE EDUCATION CAN ADDRESS
THE ISSUES WE ARE DISCUSSING IN
AMERICA TODAY. THAN ANY OTHER
POLICY TACTIC OR RESTRICTION
CURRENTLY BEING CONSIDERED. AND
IF COUPLED WITH THE SYSTEM OF
STANDARDS ACCOUNTABILITY
OVERSIGHT IT CAN MAKE A
MEANINGFUL LONG TERM DIFFERENCE
IN POLICING. YEAH THIS IS
NEITHER EASY NOR FREE AND IT
HAS TO BE THOUGHTFUL MEASURED
AND AT A PACE THAT AGENCIES CAN
ADAPT TO THEIR VARYING SIZE AND
CAPABILITIES. IT MUST MAKE SURE
TO MITIGATE UNINTENDED
CONSEQUENCES SUCH AS THE
DISPARATE IMPACT ON MINORITIES
AND OTHER RECRUITMENT. YOU'LL
HEAR IT SOON AND THEN X. ALL
ABOUT RICK. AND THEM SO WE'LL
TALK ABOUT THE CHALLENGES AND
THOSE CHALLENGES ARE REAL. BUT
THERE ARE FINANCIAL PATHWAYS IN
WAYS TO MITIGATE THOSE ISSUES
BY PROVIDING EDUCATIONAL
OPPORTUNITIES FOR PLEASE
CANDIDATES AND LOOKING AT OTHER
MODELS LIKE THE U. S. MILITARY.
IN CONCLUSION I JUST WANT TO
SAY THE POLICING CAN BE SEEN AS
A JOB A CAREER OR WHAT BUT I
BELIEVE IT IS WHICH IS A
PROFESSIONAL CALLING. IT IS AND
SHOULD BE A PROFESSIONAL
CALLING SIMILAR TO WHAT. WE'VE
SEEN IN MANY INDIVIDUAL
OFFICERS AND SOME AGENCIES IN
CALIFORNIA AND THROUGHOUT THE
COUNTRY. BUT IF POLICING IS
TRULY TO BE A PROFESSION AS ALL
COMMUNITIES EXPECT AND DESERVE
THEN WOMEN WE MUST ESTABLISH
THE ESSENTIAL REQUIREMENTS OF
PROFESSIONALISM. THAT WE
HAVEN'T EXPECT FOR OUR TEACHERS
DOCTORS LAWYERS AND ENGINEERS.
IT IS THE MOST ESSENTIAL METHOD
TO NOT ONLY ADDRESS THE ISSUES
OF REFORM BUT WILL ALSO RESULT
IN SAFER COMMUNITIES WITH THE
STRENGTH OF THE PUBLIC'S TRUST.
THAT WE ARE ALL SEEKING TO
ACHIEVE. THANK YOU VERY MUCH
THANK YOU THANK YOU VERY MUCH
MISTER ALI KHAN FOR YOUR- YOUR
PRESENTATION FOR YOUR- YOUR
COMMENTS THEY ARE STARTING TO
BELIEVE THEY WERE ABSOLUTELY ON
POINT AND YOU TALKED ABOUT EVEN
THIS TIME AROUND THE
EDUCATIONAL LEVEL THAT ONE MUST
HAVE A MOVING IN THIS NEW
GENERATION AND NEWAGE OF
PUBLIC SAFETY SO WE APPRECIATE
THAT I KNOW MY COLLEAGUES AND I
HAD MUCH DISCUSSION AROUND- THE%
EDUCATION. A STANDPOINT OF
OFFICERS SO AGAIN THANK YOU
VERY MUCH AND WE ASK ALL THE
PRISONERS THAT YOU CAN JUST
STICK AROUND JUST BRIEFLY- WE
OPEN UP FOR THE Q. AND A SO MY
COLLEAGUES MAY IN FACT HAVE
SOME QUESTIONS IF YOUR YOUR
SCHEDULE ALLOW YOU STAY ON WE
CERTAINLY APPRECIATE YOU- BEAR
WITH US IN THAT REGARD SO WITH
THAT BEING SAID- WE WANT TO NOW
BEGIN THE PANEL DISCUSSION
AROUND RECRUITMENT. OF LAW
ENFORCEMENT OFFICERS EACH PANEL
WILL HAVE AGAIN UP TO EIGHT
MINUTES TO SPEAK AND PART OF
THAT- WE ASK THAT YOU INTRODUCE
YOURSELVES AND YOU WILL BE
CALLED UPON- IN THE ORDER ON'T
NOTED ON THE AGENDA. SO WITH
THAT BEING SAID. WE WANT TO
MOVE- AND INVITE DR- SUTHERS-
TOOL WILL BE JOINING US
VIRTUALLY- DOCTORS OTHERS ARE
YOU WITH US. YES I AM GOOD
MORNING MR CHAIRMAN THANK YOU
VERY MUCH GOOD MORNING AND MAKE
YOU MAY PROCEEDS THANK YOU.
THANK YOU AND AGAIN I'D LIKE TO
THANK YOU AND THE TEAM MEMBERS
OF THE COMMITTEE FOR INVITING
ME THIS MORNING- MY COLLEAGUES
AND ALL OF YOU WHO ARE WITH US.
SUGGESTED TREMENDOUS
OPPORTUNITY I MD PROFESSOR
PRACTICE IN NATIONAL HOMELESS
CHARITY. AT THE UNIVERSITY
STUDY CALIFORNIA'S TOP PRICE
SCHOOL OF PUBLIC POLICY. AND
DIRECTOR OF THE STATE
COMMITTEES INSTITUTE. AND WHAT
I'D LIKE TO STAY IN OPENING IS
THAT THERE'S THREE AREAS I LIKE
TO COVER DURING THE TIME FRAME
THAT I HAVE THE FIRST WILL BE
RECRUITMENT PROGRAMS THE SECOND
WILL BE. EDUCATION REQUIREMENTS
AND THE LAST FIGHT WILL BE A
LATERAL RECRUITMENT. THE
LEGISLATIVE I COME TO THE SPACE.
OUR HUMBLE BUT ON WITH DEEPER
YOU BACK- I STARTED MY CAREER
FORTY YEARS AGO IN SANTA MONICA
POLICE DEPARTMENT. ENDED MY
UNIFORM CAREER TEN YEARS AGO AT
THE LOS ANGELES WORLD AIRPORTS
POLICE DEPARTMENT ASSISTANT
CHIEF OVER HOMELAND SECURITY
AND INTELLIGENCE. IN BETWEEN I
WAS REALLY HONORED TO SERVE.
THE FBI SPECIAL AGENT WORKING
FOR COUNTER INTELLIGENCE AND
TERRORISM AS A MEMBER THEIR
SWATI. SO ALL THAT HAPPENED HE
SAID. I DIDN'T GROW UP ANY
DIFFERENT THAN AN AFRICAN
AMERICAN. BEING SUBJECTED TO
POLICE MISCONDUCT AND ABUSE IS
A YOUNG MAN WHICH IS ONE OF THE
REASONS THAT I BECAME A POLICE
OFFICER. BECAUSE MY DAD USED TO
SAY YOU CAN'T CHANGE THE
CAPSICUM OUTSIDE TOMORROW. SO
PART OF THAT CHANGE. WHAT I
WANT TO TALK ABOUT FIRST IS
THAT AS WE TALK AS WE DISCUSS.
CHANGE AND REFORM REFORM HAS TO
BE A TOP TO BOTTOM EFFORT.
WE'RE GONNA TALK ABOUT
RECRUITMENT IN AN ATMOSPHERE OF
THIS MENTION THAT I WAS A
BACKGROUND INVESTIGATOR
ESTIMATES APPEAR VERY FAMILIAR
WITH RECRUITMENT. I WAS ALSO A
LITTLE STRUCTURE AND ACADEMY
FACULTY MEMBER WE ARE HONDA
POLICE ACADEMY SO I UNDERSTAND
THAT VERY WELL. AT THE SAME
TIME WE GOT A WHOLE CHIEF
ACCOUNTABLE. SHE'S ARE
APPOINTED BY MAYORS AND CITY
COUNCILS WE DIDN'T MAKE NEED TO
MAKE SURE THEY GOT THE BEST
PERSON. WHEN YOU'RE MAKING THAT
SELECTION. SO HAVING SAID THAT
LET'S TALK ABOUT PROGRAMS. AS
MENTIONED PREVIOUSLY WE NEED
PROGRAMS THAT ENGAGE THE
DESIRED DEMOGRAPHIC OF PEOPLE
THAT WE'RE LOOKING FOR. IT'S
TIME FOR US TO MINIMIZE THE
TERM CRIMINAL JUSTICE AND MOVED
TO A TERM OF TRANSFORMATIVE
JUSTICE BY THAT I MEAN BUILDING
COMMITTEE. FROM A PLACE OF
POWER. WE HAVE TO MOVE AWAY
FROM AN OFFENDER BASED PLATFORM
OF EDUCATING PEOPLE IN THAT
SYSTEM. THAT'S SOMETHING WE'RE
GONNA BE DOING THIS COMING YEAR
AND THE STOCK PRICE SCHOOL OF
PUBLIC POLICY. ONE OF THE
REASONS THAT WE HAVE CHALLENGES
THAT QUITE OFTEN. THE
INTERACTION BETWEEN YOUNG
PEOPLE IN THE POLICE ARE ALWAYS
INTERACTS THE CONFLICT. ALWAYS
INTERACTIONS OF DISPUTE.
FORTUNATELY I WAS. POWER PIECE
ACT OF POLICE ACTIVITIES LEAGUE
KID WHEN I GREW UP IN NEW
JERSEY AND I HAD THOSE
INTERACTIONS WITH OFFICERS THAT
WAS MORE POSITIVE I PLAY
SPORTS. ENGAGED IN OTHER
ACTIVITIES I'M REALLY PROUD TO
SAY I'M ONE OF THE FOUNDERS CO
FOUNDERS. OF THE PAL PROGRAM IN
SANTA MONICA PD. I THINK THESE
PROGRAMS ARE REALLY IMPORTANT
AS WE TRY TO HAVE. A
DEMOGRAPHIC OF LAW ENFORCEMENT
AGENCIES THAT REFLECT THE
COMMUNITIES THAT THEY SERVE.
ADEPT PROGRAMS BUT MORE
IMPORTANTLY IT SPEAK ABOUT THIS
I'M NOT GOING TO EXCLUDE
PROGRESSIVES YOU KNOW TOO MANY
QUESTIONS THE SUGGESTION TO
JOIN THE POLICE DEPARTMENT
MAYBE CHARITY INTUITIVE OR EVEN
OFFENSIVE. BUT IF THERE WERE
MORE POLICE OFFICERS WHO CARED
ABOUT THE THINGS PROGRESSIVE
WALK LIKE MINIMIZING POLICE
VIOLENCE. FINDING ALTERNATIVES
TO INCARCERATION AND ENSURING
THE RIGHT TO PEACEFUL PROTEST
WE ALL BENEFIT. A NEW
GENERATION OF PROGRESSIVE
LEANING POLICE OFFICERS WOULD
HARDLY BE A NEW TO SAY RACIAL
BIAS BUT THESE OFFICERS MIGHT
BE OPEN TO SCRUTINIZING THEIR
BEHAVIOR FOR EVIDENCE OF BIAS.
WE HAVE TO HAVE A PUBLIC HEALTH
PARTNERSHIP AS WE TALK ABOUT
RECRUITING AND PROGRAMS THAT
ENGAGE THE PUBLIC. SO WITH THAT
LET ME MOVE ON TO EDUCATION HAS
BEEN MENTIONED BY MY ESTEEMED
COLLEAGUE ARAFAT THE CONVOY OF
NORTH MANY YEARS. AND I WANT TO
MENTION THAT I ALSO SERVING THE
INTERNATIONAL SO SHE'S OF
CHIEFS OF POLICE RESEARCH
ADVISORY BOARD AND DATA IS
IMPORTANT HIS COMMENTS ABOUT
THE FACT IT. EDUCATED OFFICERS
USE FORCE ARE LESS LIKELY TO
USE FORCE IS VERY TELLING. WE
HAVE DIFFERENT STANDARDS FOR
DIFFERENT DEPARTMENTS SO THE
FBI AS YOU KNOW REQUIRES A
BACHELOR'S DEGREE. AND A PERSON
IS TWENTY FOUR THREE YEARS OF
AGE TO APPLY TO BUREAU. IT WILL
BE INTERESTING TO NOTE THAT THE
AVERAGE AGE OF AN INCOMING.
AGENT AT NEW AGENTS CLASS
QUANTICO IS THIRTY YEARS OF
AGE. THAT IS VERY TELLING
BECAUSE WHAT THAT MEANS IS THEY
GOT A LIFE EXPERIENCE THAT ALSO
ADDS TO THE ACADEMIC EXPERIENCE
WHICH MAKES THEM MORE IN TUNE
PERHAPS TO DEALING WITH THE
PEOPLE THAT THEY HAVE TO
ADDRESS. WE TRIED THAT MODEL
SANTA MONICA PD OVER FORTY
YEARS AGO. WE HAD TEN
APPLICANTS WHO ALL HAVE
BACHELOR'S DEGREES.
SUCCESSFULLY COMPLETED THE
ACADEMY WHEN THEY GOT TO THE
FIELD TRAINING OFFICERS PROGRAM
OR FTO PROGRAM NINE OF THEM
FAIL. I JOKINGLY ALWAYS SAY TO
PEOPLE THERE'S A DIFFERENCE
BETWEEN BEING INTELLIGENT BEING
SMART. AND AS WAS PREVIOUSLY
MENTIONED. THE ACADEMY TIME
FRAME. IN MANY OTHER COUNTRIES
IS FAR MORE EXTENSIVE THAN THE
SIX MONTHS WE ALLOWED HERE IN
CALIFORNIA AND THE UNITED
STATES. OFFICERS PROBABLY SPEND
ABOUT 223% OF THEIR TIME IN THE
FIELD MAKING A DECISION ON
WHETHER OR NOT TO USE DEADLY
FORCE YEAH AN EXTRAORDINARY
AMOUNT OF TIME SPENT TRAINING
IN THAT AREA. 90% OF THEIR TIME
SPENT ON DISCRETIONARY DECISION
MAKING YOU KNOW JUST BECAUSE
SOMETHING WITH AN POLICY.
DOESN'T MEAN IT IS NECESSARY.
WE NEED ANALYTICAL THINKERS. I
WANNA START ADVOCATE OF COLLEGE
DEGREES WE DON'T WANT TO
ELIMINATE PEOPLE FROM
OPPORTUNITIES AND LAW
ENFORCEMENT BECAUSE YOU'RE
LIMITED BY SOCIAL ECONOMIC
OPPORTUNITIES FOR EDUCATION SO
I WANT TO BE VERY CAUTIOUS AS
WE TALK ABOUT EDUCATION
REQUIREMENTS MOVING FORWARD.
FOR LAW ENFORCEMENT OFFICERS.
LASTLY I WANT TO TALK ABOUT
LATERAL. AND FOR THOSE OF YOU
AS I DON'T WANT IT SO WE WANT A
CHALLENGES BUT I WANNA MAKE
SURE ALL ON THE SAME PAGE
LETTER LAWSUIT FOR THOSE
OFFICERS WHO HAVE SERVED IN
OTHER AGENCIES IN THE STATE AND
MOVED TO ANOTHER DEPARTMENT
OFTEN FOR VERY POSITIVE
REASONS. BUT SOMETIMES NOT. AS
YOU KNOW. WHEN YOU'VE GOT A
PERSON WITH EXPERIENCE THERE'S
A COST SAVINGS. ON TRAINING. ON
THE ACADEMY THE FIELD TRAINING
OFFICERS PROGRAM IT'S A VERY
BENEFICIAL PROGRAM. TO
DEPARTMENTS GET LETTERS FROM
OTHER PLACES. THE SAD PART IS
WE ARE TRACKING OPTIONS OF HAD
PROBLEMS AT OTHER PLACES.
PARTICULAR OFFICES THAT HAVE
BEEN FIRED. AND I'M REALLY
DISAPPOINTED TO SEE THAT THEIR
ADVERTISEMENTS ACROSS THE
COUNTRY. SEEKING TO HIRE POLICE
OFFICERS WHO WERE FIRED OR
RESIGNED OVER MISCONDUCT AND
OTHER AGENCIES. WITH THAT I
WANT TO MENTION THE WORK WE'RE
DOING AT THE STOCK PRICE
SCHOOLS SAFE COMMITTEES
INSTITUTE WE ARE LAUNCHING. IN
THE FURTHERANCE OF THE LEGACY
OF TRANSFORMATIVE JUSTICE
REPRESENTATIVE JOHN LEWIS.
WE'RE GOING TO BE CREATING THE
LUIS. REGISTRY LEWIS STANDS FOR
THE LAW ENFORCEMENT WORK IN
QUERY SYSTEM IT'S ENDORSED BY
COMMITTEE STAKEHOLDERS
ACADEMICS LAW ENFORCEMENT.
BIPARTISAN LEGISLATIVE SUPPORT
AND WE JUST COMPLETED A
NATIONALLY REPRESENTATIVE
SURVEY. THAT SAID THAT 80% OF
THE PEOPLE THAT WE SERVE DATE.
SUPPORT A REGISTRY FOR OFFICERS
FIRED FOR MISCONDUCT 74%
REPUBLICANS 76% INDEPENDENCE
AND 90% DEMOCRATS. SO WITH THAT
I'M GOING TO JUST CLOSE BY
SAYING THIS FIRST OF ALL THE
PUBLIC DEBT GEORGE FLOYD IS AN
UNDENIABLE INFLECTION POINT AND
HISTORICAL ARC OF THE
RELATIONSHIP BETWEEN LAW
ENFORCEMENT AND THE CITIZENS
THEY ARE SWORN TO BOTH PROTECT
AND TO SERVE. ARGUABLY NEVER IN
THE HISTORY OF THE UNITED
STATES HAS THERE BEEN A MORE
OPPORTUNE TIME FOR LAW
ENFORCEMENT AND COMMUNITIES
THAT CONSIST PREDOMINANTLY OF
RACIAL AND ETHNIC MINORITIES TO
RESOLVE TO IMPROVE THESE
ESSENTIAL RELATIONSHIPS TO
ACHIEVE SAFE COMMUNICATION AND
INTERACTION THAT NECESSITATE
TRANSPARENCY AND ACCOUNTABILITY.
I THINK THIS WAS MADE THE
COMMENT MADE EARLIER BY THE
ASSEMBLY MEMBER THE CALIFORNIA
LEADS I ABSOLUTELY AGREE AND WE
SHOULD ASSUME THAT ROLE AT THIS
TIME. I LOOK FORWARD TO AGAIN
ANY COMMENTS ANY QUESTIONS
SUGGESTIONS AND MOST
IMPORTANTLY. CONTINUE
COLLABORATION AND PARTNERSHIP
WITH THE COMMUNITY AND LAW
ENFORCEMENT PARTNERS AND
AGENCIES THAT WE WORK WITH
EVERY DAY THANK YOU FOR YOUR
TIME. THANK YOU VERY MUCH
DOCTORS OTHERS FOR YOUR-YOUR
REMARKS YOUR COMMENTS MESS
AROUND EDUCATION- PLEASE IF YOU
COULD STICK AROUND FOR A LITTLE
BIT WE WANT TO POSSIBLY REFER
BACK TO YOU AT SOME POINT FROM
MY COLLEAGUE STASSEN FOLLOW UP.
QUESTIONS AND CERTAINLY THE
ISSUE OF- YOU KNOW LET ME JUST
SAY AS WE AS WELL I'M GETTING
READY TO PIVOT AND ASKED MR-
ASSEMBLY MEMBER OF MCCARTY TO
INTRODUCE HIMSELF WE WANT TO
MAKE SURE THAT WE DON'T HER
COMMUNITIES OF COLOR BY. BY
REQUIRING A BACHELOR'S DEGREE
OR MAKE IT IS SO UNREACHABLE
FOR- INDIVIDUALS WHO ARE IN THE
IN THE COMMUNITY TO ABSOLUTELY-
BECOME CHANGE AGENTS AND BECOME
POLICE OFFICER THAT'S WHEN THE
REASONS WHY. I BECAME A POLICE
OFFICER IT'S BECOME A CHANGE
AGENT AND I KNOW THAT WOULD BE
POSSIBLE IF IN FACT WE REYES OF
THE REQUIREMENT ARMS EDUCATION-
BROUGHT BY REQUIRING YOU TO
HAVE A BACHELOR'S DEGREE- BUT I
WANNA EXPLORE THE ASSOCIATE OF
SCIENCE DEGREE. HE'S OUT WITH A
FOLLOW UP QUESTION WITH YOU SO
WITH THAT I WANT TO POSSIBLE
MEANT AND HAS- ASSEMBLY MEMBER
KEVIN MCCARTY JOIN IS TO REDUCE
HIMSELF SAY A FEW WORDS AND
THEY WERE GOING TO GO RIGHT TO.
OUR NEXT PANELIST MISTER
MCCARTY THANK YOU AT THE MISTER
CHAIRMAN AND ALL INTRODUCE OUR
NEXT SPEAKER ACTUALLY IS OUR
POLICE CHIEF HERE IN SACRAMENTO
OKAY PLEASE DO CHIEF ON BUT I
JUST WANT TO SAY I APPRECIATE
IT YOU KNOW THERE IS A GREAT
APPETITE. FOR POLICE REFORM AND
CERTAINLY I'VE WORKED ON A FEW
BILLS FROM A BECOME LAW BUT I
DON'T HAVE ALL THE ANSWERS SO
YOU KNOW I THINK THAT WE COUNT
ON- HAVING ROBUST DISCUSSIONS
LIKE THIS AS OPPOSED TO JUST
READING A BILL AND MOVING ON
SO. I REALLY APPRECIATE DIGGING
INTO THE WEEDS AND ENGAGING ON
THIS SO WE CAN BETTER INFORM
US- I THIS IS A VERY- TIMELY
TOPIC RIGHT NOW AND ONE THING
I'M GONNA ENGAGE WITH ART PARTY
FUN LITTLE LATER IS THAT. THIS
THIS POLICE DEPARTMENT HERE HAS
A REQUIREMENT TO SHARE A LITTLE
BIT DIFFERENT SO I WANT TO SEE
WHAT WE'VE SEEN SO FAR ON ON
THAT AND NOT AND I CONCUR THAT
THE A VERSES THE- BE A IS
SOMETHING. THAT I CAN I
CONSIDERED IMPORTANT IF WE WANT.
DIVERSIFY FAR TO PLAY
DEPARTMENT AS SOMEONE GETS ALL
SAID HOUR SO NOT SO. OF COURSE
WATCHING. EARLY ON MY IPAD- IN
YOUR JUST BEAT UP. YOU LASTLY.
OUR RESIDENTS YOU HAVE FOR MY
CONSTITUENTS HERE DOCTOR WAZEE
TANYA FAISON. JIM IN THE LAND
OF COURSE- CHIEF HAN SO WITH
THAT. WELCOME TO FINE AND THANK
YOU FOR JOINING US TODAY AND
SO- PLEASE BEGIN. THANK YOU MR
MCCARTY AND- THANK YOU ASSEMBLY
MEMBER GIPSON AND THE
COMMITTEE. TO HONOR TO BE HERE
AND I APPRECIATE- THE
COLLABORATIVE APPROACH TO
TRYING TO IMPROVE. OUR
PROFESSION AND OUR SERVICE TO
THE COMMUNITY. I'M I THINK IT'S
VERY RELEVANT TO TALK A LITTLE
BIT ABOUT- MY BACKGROUND IN
REGARDS TO- RECRUITING BEFORE I
GET INTO. SOME OF MY THOUGHTS
ON RECRUITING BUT- YOU KNOW
I'VE I WAS BORN HERE IN
SACRAMENTO AND HAVE LIVED IN
THIS COMMUNITY MY ENTIRE LIFE I
WAS GIVEN UP FOR ADOPTION AT
BIRTH AND- WAS EXTREMELY LUCKY
TO HAVE MY- MOM AND DAD ADOPT
ME AT THREE MONTHS OLD. I GREW
UP IN OAK PARK I WAS ARRESTED
FOR ASSAULT ON AN OFFICER WHEN
I WAS SIXTEEN. MY YOUNGER
BROTHER WAS MURDERED AFTER HE
GOT INVOLVED IN- THE DRUG
BUSINESS HERE IN SACRAMENTO- I
NEVER PLANNED ON BEING A POLICE
OFFICER NEVER EVEN CROSSED MY
MIND TO BE A POLICE OFFICER- I
GOT INTO IT BY ACCIDENT THAT'S
A LONG STORY- I DID NOT. PLAN
ON MAKING LAW ENFORCEMENT MY
PROFESSION INTEL I'VE BEEN A
POLICE OFFICER FOR ALREADY
ABOUT EIGHT YEARS. MY DEGREE IS
NOT IN CRIMINAL JUSTICE MY
DEGREES IN BUSINESS
ADMINISTRATION. I DON'T HAVE
ANY DEGREES IN CRIMINAL
JUSTICE. AND I'VE BEEN A POLICE
OFFICER NOW FOR OVER THIRTY
THREE YEARS THE LAST THREE PLUS
YEARS AS CHIEF IN SACRAMENTO
AND SIX PLUS YEARS BEFORE THAT
AND ROADS WILL. SO RECRUITING-
I THINK IT'S IT WAS MENTIONED
EARLIER BY ONE OF THE SPEAKERS-
BUT IT'S IMPORTANT TO NOTE.
THAT I SPEAK TO- THE MAJOR
MAJOR CITY CHIEFS ACROSS OUR
COUNTRY ON A REGULAR BASIS
PROBABLY ON A WEEKLY OR- EVERY
OTHER WEEK BASIS. ONE OF THE
CHALLENGES ONE OF THE BIGGEST
CHALLENGES ACROSS OUR COUNTRY
FOR THE LAST SEVERAL YEARS IS
RECRUITING. IS RECRUITING AND
HIRING HIGHLY QUALIFIED PEOPLE
I'M JUST IN SHEER NUMBERS BUT
ALSO WITH DIVERSITY- AND THAT
IS ONE OF THE LARGEST
CHALLENGES THAT EVERY CHIEF
ACROSS THIS COUNTRY TALK ABOUT
ESPECIALLY THE- MAJOR CITY
CHIEFS. AND SO. I HAVE
SOMETHING OF NOTE OVER THERE
AND WE STRUGGLE WITH THAT SAME
ISSUE IN SACRAMENTO. BUT OVER
THE LAST COUPLE OF THE OVER THE
LAST YEAR THAT HAS CHANGED AND
I'D HASN'T CHANGED TO THE POINT
WHERE WE WANT IT. BUT OUR
RECRUITING HAS IMPROVED OUR
APPLICATIONS ARE UP THE
DIVERSITY IS UP SO I WANT TO
TALK A LITTLE BIT. ABOUT HOW WE
ACCOMPLISHED IN SOME OF THE
CHALLENGES THAT WE FACE IN
TERMS OF HIRING HIGHLY
QUALIFIED. GOOD EXPERIENCE
PROPER PEOPLE TO SERVE OUR
COMMUNITY SO AND TWO THOUSAND
AND THIRTEEN- WE HAD SIXTY SIX
HUNDRED APPLICANTS FOR POLICE
OFFICERS. AND BY THE WAY WE
REQUIRE TWO YEARS OF COLLEGE TO
BE A POLICE OFFICER- AND I
STARTED WHEN I WAS NINETEEN
YEARS OLD- SO I DIDN'T HAVE A
DEGREE AND I WASN'T. NINETY SO
AGAIN ABOUT SEVEN YEARS AGO WE
HAD SIXTY SIX HUNDRED
APPLICANTS LAST YEAR TWO
THOUSAND AND NINETEEN. WE ONLY
HAD TWENTY EIGHT HUNDRED OUT.
AND OUT OF THOSE TWENTY EIGHT
HUNDRED APPLICANTS WE FOUND
SEVENTY THREE PEOPLE. SUITABLE
FOR BEING HIRED AND SENT TO THE
ACADEMY. THEY GIVE YOU A LITTLE
BIT OF IDEA OF HOW MANY PEOPLE
HAVE TO APPLY JUST TO FIND SAY
SEVENTY THREE. AND WE HAVE
DROPPED. OVER HALF THE NUMBER
OF APPLICANTS THAT APPLIED IN
THE TRADITIONAL WAY. THIS YEAR
THROUGH NOVEMBER SO STILL WITH
ANOTHER MONTH TO GO. WE'VE HAD
TWENTY NINE ALMOST THREE
THOUSAND APPLICANTS AND WILL
PROBABLY GET MAYBE A HUNDRED OR
TWO HUNDRED MORE BEFORE THE END
OF THE YEAR. AND OUT OF THOSE
APPLICANTS WE FOUND EIGHTY
THREE THAT MAKE IT THROUGH THE
PROCESS AND MAKE IT THROUGH THE
BACKGROUND. SO PEOPLE ARE NO
LONGER APPLYING THE TRADITIONAL
WAY TO BE POLICE OFFICERS- YOU
YOU SAW I WAS OVER SIX THOUSAND
ALMOST SEVEN THOUSAND PEOPLE
SEVEN YEARS AGO AND WHEN I
APPLIED IT WAS THOUSANDS AND
THOUSANDS MORE THAN THAT- SO IS
DRAMATICALLY CHANGED. SO WE HAD
TO RETHINK HOW WE RECRUIT AND
HIRE. MEMBERS OF OUR DEPARTMENT
SO IN REGARDS TO RECRUITING. WE
DEVELOP THE DIVERSE RECRUITING
STRATEGY WITH THE NEW CAMPAIGN
THAT INCLUDED BILLBOARDS-
CAMPAIGN THAT- SPOKE TO- BEING
THE DIFFERENCE AS OPPOSED TO
TRADITIONAL CAMPAIGNS OF
EXCITEMENT. PURSUITS WHAT. WE
ONE OF OUR OFFICERS AS A RAPPER
AND HE RECORDED A SONG TITLED
BE THE DIFFERENCE THAT WENT
NATIONWIDE. AND JUST COMPLETELY
CHANGED OUR RECRUITING CAMPAIGN
AND RECRUITING ON IVERSE RADIO
STATIONS BILLBOARDS THINGS LIKE
THAT. WE ALSO HAVE OVER THE
LAST COUPLE YEARS PARTNERED
WITH SAC STATE TO CREATE A
PROGRAM AT SAC STATE THAT'S A
LACK OF GROW YOUR OWN PROGRAM
CALLED LAX LAW ENFORCEMENT
CANDIDATES SCHOLARS. ARE ALSO
WORKING WITH SACKS CITY COLLEGE
SOME OF OUR JUNIOR COLLEGES TO
ATTRACT. PEOPLE IN COLLEGE TO
THIS JOB AND GET THEM
EXPERIENCE THAT HELPS THEM
THROUGH THE HIRING PROCESS AND
HELPS THEM THROUGH THE
BACKGROUND PROCESS IS ALSO
IMPORTANT TO NOTE ONE OF THE
REQUIREMENTS. OF THEIR PROGRAMS
IS IT CAN'T JUST BE THERE
CRIMINAL JUSTICE SCHOOL. SO WE
GET A LOT OF PEOPLE FROM OTHER
SCHOOLS WITHIN THE UNIVERSITY
BETTER NOT JUST CRIMINAL
JUSTICE BECAUSE IT'S IMPORTANT
TO HIRE WITH- DIVERSE
EXPERIENCES NOT JUST GENDER AND
RACE- IS ALSO IMPORTANT TO KNOW
MANY OF YOU I'M SURE I'VE HEARD
OF OFFICER CHARLES SOLOMON. WHO
WAS KILLED AS ONE OF OUR POLICE
OFFICERS IN OUR CITY BUT SHE
WAS ONE OF THE FIRST PEOPLE WE
HIRED TO THE SAC STATE LET'S
PROGRAM AND HER DEGREE WAS
INJURED EARLY CHILDHOOD
DEVELOPMENT AND THAT'S REALLY
THE PURPOSE. OF THAT PROGRAM TO
GET DIVERSE. APPLICANTS
INTERESTED IN LAW ENFORCEMENT.
WE HAVE ALSO IMPROVED SPEED. OF
THE HIRING PROCESS THROUGH
ONLINE- TEST TAKING AND
SPEEDING UP THE PROCESS THAT WE
GET THE NAMES BECAUSE EVERYBODY
IS LOOKING FOR HIGHLY QUALIFIED
CANDIDATES. AND WE DON'T WANT
TO LOSE PEOPLE BECAUSE THEY GET
STRUNG OUT IN THE PROCESS AND-IT TAKES TOO LONG. WE ALSO
CREATED ENTRY LEVEL POSITIONS
WHICH IS IT WHICH IS REALLY
WHAT WHERE I WANT TO SPEND THE
REST OF MY TIME ON. IS WE CAN
NO LONGER EXPECT TO GET
APPLICANTS THE WAY WE
TRADITIONALLY HAVE AND AS A
POLICE OFFICER POSITIONS
TYPICALLY IN THEIR MID
TWENTIES. THEY'RE JUST NOT
APPLYING IN THOSE NUMBERS
ANYMORE- AND WE STILL HAVE THE
CHALLENGE OF GETTING PEOPLE
FROM BACKGROUNDS THAT ARE
QUALIFIED. SO WE CREATED I AND-
GROUP POSITIONS LIKE INTERNS
STUDENT TRAINEES. I MEAN
SERVICE OFFICERS ARE ARE YOU MY
HERE MCCOLLUM CSOS THESE ARE
ALL ENTRY LEVEL POSITIONS. OUR
TIME POSITION THAT ARE BUILT TO
WORK AROUND- PEOPLE'S COLLEGE
SCHEDULES- AND THEY'RE REALLY
THE ENTRY LEVEL THAT WE USED TO
GET PEOPLE TO BE ABLE TO LOOK
AT LAW ENFORCEMENT FROM THE
INSIDE. AND DETERMINE WHETHER
THEY WANT TO BE A FULL POLICE
OFFICER DISPATCHER AND THOSE
POSITIONS ARE WAY MORE DIVERSE.
THAN WHAT WE TYPICALLY HAVE IN
OTHER PLACES. BUT ALSO PART OF-
THIS IS LEARNING NEW WAYS TO DO
THINGS SO WE'VE INVITED OUR
I'VE INVITED STANFORD
WASHINGTON STATE CENTER FOR
POLICING EQUITY. AMERICAN
LEADERSHIP FARMS THE DEPARTMENT
OF JUSTICE ALL TO REVIEW OUR
DEPARTMENT. ALL SOME OF THEM
ARE TEACHING HISTORY AND
IMPLICIT BIAS IN OUR
DEPARTMENT. AND THEY HAVE ALL
COMING BACK WITH
RECOMMENDATIONS OF HOW WE CAN
IMPROVE THE RELATIONSHIP IN OUR
COMMUNITY. BUT ALSO WE HAVE TO
PAY CLOSE ATTENTION TO
RETENTION. AND WHO DO WE SELECT
THIS LEADERS SO ON OUR
PROMOTION PANELS- WE ALWAYS
INCLUDE COMMUNITY MEMBERS ON
THOSE PROMOTION PANELS AND WE
NOW REQUIRE. REQUIRE FOR
PROMOTIONS- READING MATERIAL
SUCH AS POST TRAUMATIC SLAVE
SYNDROME FROM DOCTOR JOIN YOUR
GROUP BLINDSPOT REQUIRE PEOPLE
TO TAKE THAT BLESSED
ASSOCIATION TASK TO HARVARD.
AND SO WE CAN EXPAND THE
EXPERIENCE OF OUR LEADERS
BECAUSE PEOPLE WANT TO JOIN A
GOOD DEPARTMENT THAT VALUES
THEIR COMMUNITY. AND HAS
DIVERSE LEADERSHIP SO THOSE ARE
ALL PART OF IT BUT I WANT TO
GIVE YOU SOME OF THE RESULTS.
SO ARE IF YOU LOOK AT OUR
CURRENT POLICE OFFICERS IN OUR
DEPARTMENT AND YOU- LOOK AT
THEM IN TERMS OF RACE AND
GENDER- IN TERMS OF RACE AND
GENDER WE ARE 42% VERSUS. OUR
CURRENT POLICE OFFICERS. BUT IN
OUR CSO ACADEMY THAT WE HAD
THIS YEAR IT'S 75% VERSED. IN
OUR STUDENTS TRAINEES IS 73% OF
OURS. AND SO YOU'RE STARTING TO
SEE OUR- OUR POLICE OFFICER
ACADEMIES ARE NOW SEVENTY
SIXTIES AND 70% THE FIRST
BECAUSE A LOT OF THEM ARE
COMING THROUGH THOSE ENTRY
LEVEL PROGRAMS. WHERE THEY
START WHEN THEY'RE EIGHTEEN
NINETEEN TWENTY YEARS OLD I
STARTED AT THIS YEAR'S SHOW AT%
TWENTY YEARS OLD. AND MY GOAL
WAS TO- LEAVES- AND THIRTY
THREE YEARS LATER I'M HERE- AS
POLICE CHIEF WE ALSO HIRED A
MASTER'S LEVEL SOCIAL WORKERS
IS ALSO A PROFESSOR AT SAC
STATE. SHE TEACHES A LOT OF
MENTAL HEALTH AND OTHER THINGS
IN OUR DEPARTMENT BUT SHE ALSO
RUNS OUR SOCIAL SERVICES
DIVISION WITHIN THE POLICE
DEPARTMENT WHICH IS OUR MENTAL
HEALTH TEAM. AND HOMELESS
SERVICES TEAM BUT BECAUSE
SHE'S- THAT LEVEL OF THE SOCIAL
WORKER WE ALSO HAVE SOCIAL WORK
INTERNS. WHICH IS A REQUIREMENT
OF BOTH UNDERGRADUATE AND
GRADUATE DEGREES THAT WORK IN
OUR DEPARTMENT UNDERNEATH HER.
AND A LOT OF THEM HAVE CHOSEN
TO BECOME POLICE OFFICERS AFTER
WORKING HERE SO AGAIN GETTING A
DIVERSE. POOL OF PEOPLE TO
SERVE OUR COMMUNITY WITH
DIFFERENT NOT ONLY RACE AND
GENDER BUT DIFFERENT
BACKGROUNDS DIFFERENT
EDUCATION. AND I ALSO TEACH- AN
EIGHT HOUR COURSE ON HISTORY OF
OUR COUNTRY THAT'S BEEN.
THROUGH RESEARCH OVER THE LAST
THREE YEARS INSIDE OUR
DEPARTMENT AND OUTSIDE OUR
DEPARTMENT. JOINT CLOSING WE
CANNOT. WE CAN NO LONGER EXPECT
TO RECRUIT AND HIRE HIGHLY
QUALIFIED PEOPLE IN OUR POLICE
DEPARTMENT THE SAME ALL THE
WAY. THERE JUST NOT APPLYING
ANYMORE SO WE HAVE TO EXPAND
THE ENTRY LEVEL- WAYS THAT ARE
MUCH MORE DIVERSE NOT ONLY IN
RACE AND GENDER BUT IN
EXPERIENCE. AND GET PEOPLE AND-
LOOK AT THE DEPARTMENT AND SO
THAT WILL THAT IS WHAT HAS
ENABLED US TO GROW OUR
RECRUITMENT FROM. THE LAST
SEVERAL YEARS OF DECLINE AND I
EXPECTED TO CONTINUE TO GROW AS
WE EXPAND THOSE ENTRY LEVEL
POSITIONS. I AT THAT OUR FUTURE
PROGRAMS TO OUR SWORN POSITIONS
SO WITH THAT. WELL. CLOSE AND
SAY THANK YOU YOU FOR YOUR TIME
AND- I LOOK TO HEARING SPEECH.
THANK YOU VERY. A CHEAP HIGH
FOR- YOU AND YOUR EXPERTISE IN
RECRUITMENT WE REALLY
APPRECIATE THAT- WE WANT TO
MOVE ON TO OUR NEXT. PRESENTER
MISTER YEA WHO JOINING US
VIRTUALLY- TODAY AND SOME
MISTER EA. ARE YOU WITH US.
RIGHT YES I AM I'M HERE THANK
YOU VERY MUCH IF YOU CAN
PLEASE- AND IT IS A SELF AND
THEN PROCEED YOU HAVE EIGHT
MINUTES. AND WE THANK YOU FOR
YOUR TIME. THANK YOU OF MY
NAME'S GREG YEMEN THE DEPUTY
CHIEF OF ADMINISTRATION FOR THE
SAN FRANCISCO POLICE
DEPARTMENT. THANK YOU FOR THIS
OPPORTUNITY. FOR ME TO SPEAK
TODAY. IN OCTOBER TWENTY
SIXTEEN THE US DEPARTMENT
JUSTICE. COPPS OFFICE RELEASED
AN ASSESSMENT OF THE SAN
FRANCISCO POLICE DEPARTMENT.
AND PROVIDED NINETY FOUR
RECORDS FINDINGS AND TWO
HUNDRED AND SEVENTY TWO
RECOMMENDATIONS FOR IMPROVEMENT
WITHIN THE DEPARTMENT. THE
REPORT WAS COMMISSIONED AT THE
REQUEST OF THE LATE. MAYOR ED
LEE. IN RESPONSE. IN THEM. IN
RESPONSE HIGH PROFILE
COMMUNITIES ARE. FOR POLICE
REFORM AS RESULT ALSO INVOLVE
SHOOTINGS AND OTHER PUBLIC
EVENTS THAT LEFT A VOID. IN
TRUST BETWEEN THE SAN FRANCISCO
POLICE DEPARTMENT AND THE
COMMUNITY. THERE IS ASSESSED
INCLUDING USE OF FORCE BIASED
MEDIA POLICING. ACCOUNTABILITY
AND HIRING AND PERSONNEL
PRACTICES. IN SEPTEMBER OF
TWENTY SEVENTEEN THE US
DEPARTMENT OF JUSTICE ANNOUNCED
ITS WITHDRAWAL FROM THE
COLLABORATIVE REFORM PROCESS
WHAT DOES YOUR CISCO POLICE
DEPARTMENT AND THE CITY OF SAN
FRANCISCO MADE A COMMITMENT TO
OUR COMMUNITY THAT THESE
RECOMMENDATIONS WOULD BE
IMPLEMENTED IN OUR DEPARTMENT
IT GATES IN A NEW WINDOW AND IT
OVERSIGHT BODY TO CONTINUE TO
WORK. DECEMBER OF TWENTY
EIGHTEEN- CALIFORNIA DEPARTMENT
OF JUSTICE ANNOUNCED ITS
AGREEMENT. PUBLICLY VIOLATE AND
REPORT ON THE IMPLEMENTATION OF
pTELL DOJ'S INDEPENDENT REVIEW
HAS HELPED THE DEPARTMENT IN
ITS CONTINUED EFFORTS TO
PROMOTE TRUST TRANSPARENCY AND
SAFETY. AS WE MOVE ON TO OUR
RECRUITMENT EFFORTS OF THROUGH
THE ASSESSMENT THE ASSESSMENT
GAVE US SOME VALUABLE
INFORMATION AND INSIGHT ON HOW
THIS DEPARTMENT COULD IMPROVE
AND AS WE KNOW THAT. ALONG WITH
ALL OF THESE PROBLEMS IN THE
BAY AREA AND THE COUNTRY WE'RE
FACING A- TIGHT COMPETITION FOR
NEW RECRUITS. SO OVER THE LAST
SEVERAL YEARS THE DEPARTMENT IS
TAKING A PROACTIVE STEP TO
FURTHER INCREASE DIVERSITY
EXPAND ACCORDED ELEMENT
OPPORTUNITIES AND THREATS TO
GAP BETWEEN THE NUMBER OF MALE
AND FEMALE SWORN POLICE
OFFICERS. THE FOCUS OUR
RECRUITMENT EFFORT IS TO
CONTINUE TO CREATE A DIVERSE
POLICE DEPARTMENT THAT MIRRORS
THE STAFF CISCO AT MEARS. SAN
FRANCISCO'S DIVERSE POPULATION.
SOME OF THE CHALLENGES THAT
WE'RE FACING. AND THEY'RE JUST
CHALLENGES THAT WE CAN OVERCOME
OF C. THE CODE PANDEMIC- AS SHE
HAN MENTIONS A REDUCTION OF
APPLICATIONS IN TWENTY FIFTEEN
WE HAD- CLOSE TO FIVE THOUSAND
APPLICANTS BECOME POLICE
OFFICERS SAN FRANCISCO. BUT IN
TWENTY NINETEEN. IT IS CUT IN
HALF TO ABOUT TWENTY SIX
HUNDRED- HIGH PROFILE LAW
ENFORCEMENT RELATED SHOOTINGS
AND INCIDENTS ACROSS THIS
NATION. I HAVE REALLY. TURN
SOME FOLKS AWAY TO BECOME
POLICE OFFICERS BECAUSE OF THE
LACK OF FAMILY SUPPORT YOUR
LOVED ONES BEING HURT. WELL
THERE'S ALSO THE FEAR OF THE
POTENTIAL BUCKLED EXPOSURES
THAT WE HAVE HEARD FROM OUR
RETREATS ARE APPLICANTS YOU.
NOT ONLY. APPLYING TO BE POLICE
OFFICERS OR OR HASN'T TO BECOME
POLICE OFFICERS BUT ALSO THOSE
WHO HAVE ACTUALLY GONE THROUGH
OUR ACADEMY AND AT THE END OF
COME TO DETERMINATION THAT THEY
CAN'T DO THIS JOB BECAUSE OF
WHAT'S GOING ON IN THIS COUNTRY
AND INDEPENDENT. WELL ONE OF
OUR BIGGEST HURDLES AND BIGGEST
CHALLENGES THAT- WE NEED TO
REALLY OVERCOME IS THAT THE
STEREOTYPING THE PUBLIC
PERCEPTION OF THE POLICE
PROFESSION. AND REALLY IT'S
ABOUT EDUCATING AND LETTING
PEOPLE UNDERSTAND THE PURPOSE
AND THE WHY WHAT THESE
PROFESSION NEEDS AND FOR THEM
TO LOOK BEYOND THE UNIFORMS AND
THAT THERE'S A PERSON BEHIND
THE PERSON IN THAT UNIFORM
THEY'RE WILLING TO SERVE. AND
PROTECT THEM. BUT WHAT IS
WORKING FOR US IN OUR
RECRUITMENT EFFORTS ARE REALLY
A CANDIDATE MENTORSHIP PROGRAM
WHERE OUR RECRUITERS. MAKE
CONTACT WITH OUR WITH
APPLICANTS CANDIDATES AND HELP
THEM ALONG THE PROCESS PROVIDE
THEM WITH WORKSHOPS TO SYSTEM
IN TESTING AND PHYSICAL TESTING
COMPONENTS ALONG WITH THE
PHYSICAL ABILITIES COMPOUNDS.
WE HAVE FOCUSED CAMPAIGNS- SUCH
AS OUR FOCUS IN TWENTY
SEVENTEEN ON FEMALE APPLICANTS.
AND THEN IN TWENTY EIGHTEEN
I'LL CONTINUE ON WITH NOW IS
THE TIME TO COME POLICE
OFFICERS. ARE WHITE G. FOUR
MENTIONED WE'RE GOING AWAY FROM
THE TRADITIONAL SWATCH AND THE-
MILITARISTIC. IMAGE BULK
LEASING REALLY SHOWING THE
DIVERSE MAKE UP OF SAN
FRANCISCO POLICE OFFICERS. AND
CHANGE THE WAY WE TREAT ALSO
INCLUDES THE PAOK. AND AN
ASSAULT ALSO ARE PAID POLICE
CADETS. WHO ARE GROWING UP
THROUGH THIS DEPARTMENT AND
THEN. AFTER FINISHING COLLEGE
MAKING A TERMINATION THAT YOU
WANT STANCES FOR POLICE
OFFICERS. WELL IN ADDITION TO
THAT- WE STILL. HAVE A
RELATIONSHIP WITH COLLEGES
BECAUSE WE UNDERSTAND THAT WELL
COLLEGE RECRUITING PUTS US IN
CONTACT WITH A DIVERSE GROUP OF
HIGHLY EDUCATED CANDIDATES-
TAKING OUR TESTING. PRE
PANDEMIC TAKING OUR TESTING AND
ARE JUST GO BUILD THESE
PROGRAMS ARE WORKSHOPS INTO THE
COMMUNITIES- SO WE BRINGS WE
BRING SERVICES TO THE COMMUNITY
MOST OF THEM COMING TO OUR
FACILITIES TO. TAKE UP TO. WE
ARE INTESTINE ASSISTANCE AND
MORE- MENTORSHIP. WE ALSO
ANALYZE OUR PRACTICES IN OUR
AND OUR. NEXUS LOOK AT ARE WE
CREATING ANY BARRIERS FOR
CANDIDATES AND RECRUITS. ALL OF
THE OLD TRIGGER PULL WELL THAT
WAS AROUND FOR MANY MANY YEARS
NO AS A GROUP TRIP. STRENGTH
ASSESSMENT WAS THAT REALLY REAL
ISN'T REALLY RELEVANT TODAY'S
OF. AND HOW DID THAT IMPACT
MALE VERSUS FEMALE CANDIDATES
SO WE MADE SOME CHANGES AFTER
LOOKING AT THAT DATA LOOKING AT
THE TESTING PROCESS IS TO MAKE
SURE THAT. YOU KNOW WHAT THERE
IS EXISTENCE AND WORKERS CAN
YOU TAKE AWAY. BUT LOOKING AT
OUR MODEL FOR POLICING. IT
STARTS WITH OUR STRATEGIC STATE.
ANTISEPSIS COMPLETE PRODUCT
STANDS FOR SAFETY WITH RESPECT
FOR ALL ENGAGING IN JUST
TRANSPARENT UNBIASED AND
RESPONSE RESYNC. DOING SO IN
THE SPIRIT OF DIGNITY IN AND
COLLECT IN COLLABORATION WITH
COMMUNITY MAINTAINING AND
BUILDING TRUST AND RESPECT. AS
GUARDIANS OF THE COST OF
CONSTITUTIONAL RIGHTS. AS AS
THAT IS OUR STRATEGY STATEMENT
ALONG WITH OUR FIVE STRATEGIC
INITIATIVES OF COLLABORATION
GROUP RESPONSIVENESS MEASURING
AND COMMUNICATING STRENGTHENING
OUR DEPARTMENT. FIND IN THE
FUTURE. THAT'S THE STANDARD AND
THAT'S THE MODEL WHICH ARE
RECRUIT. WORKERS FROM OUR
NUMBER ONE PRIORITY IN OUR
RECRUITMENT MODEL BUILDING AND
STRENGTHENING OUR PARTNERSHIPS.
IN ADDITION AND IN AN FOR US TO
DO THAT OTHER SERVICES GO
PLEASE FARM HAS A FULL TIME
RECRUITMENT STAFF WITH ONE
SERGEANT FREE POLICE OFFICERS
INTO PROFESSIONAL STAFF
RECRUITERS. GROUP WHO HAVE
WORKING FIRST AT. THE SPANISH
PACIFIC ISLANDER AFRICAN
AMERICAN FILIPINO LOCATION NH.
WELL IN ADDITION OUR TIME STAFF
WE HAVE OVER EIGHTY. OF
SERGEANTS AND POLICE ARE LEASE
OFFICERS AS A PART TIME
RECRUITERS 60% MALE 40% FEMALE
OUR BY OUR RECRUITERS ARE
BILINGUAL- FOR EXAMPLE HE
SPEAKS ARABIC CANTONESE
MANDARIN MAND MANDARIN JAPANESE
KOREAN RUSSIAN SPANISH TAGALOG
VIETNAMESE. NOW THESE THIS
RECRUITMENT TEAM IN BODIES IN
VARIOUS STRATEGIC STATEMENT AND
OUR MISSION OF CLUSTERS WITH
THAT. THEIR HEART AND MINDSET
THEY REACH OUT AND RECRUIT AND
SPREAD THE MESSAGE OF WHAT SAN
FRANCISCO MEANS WHAT SAM CISCO
VALUES AND ARE THEY WILLING AND
ARE THEY ABLE ARE THEY
COMMITTED TO BODY THOSE THOSE
SAME VALUES SAN FRANCISCO
POLICE OFFICERS. IN ADDITION
TO. YOUR TALK ABOUT DATA WE
ESTABLISHED A STAFF INTO ONE
UNIT AND HAS ANALYSTS IN IT TO
REALLY TRACK OR DATA TRACK OUR
PROGRESS IN IN. STATE
INDETERMINATE. ARE THERE. ANY
IS THERE ANYTHING ELSE WE CAN
DO TO DIVERSIFY THIS POLICE
DEPARTMENT WHAT WHAT IS THE
RESULT OF OUR TESTING WHAT'S
THE RESULTS SO FAR ACADEMY
PROCEDURES- ARE WE DOING AND
HOW DO WE HOW DO WE IMPROVE ON
OUR PRACTICES WHAT A BIG
COMPONENT THAT WE STARTED THIS
YEAR. BUT WAS HAMPERED BY THE-
AND THEN IT WAS OUR COMMUNITY
AMBASSADOR PROGRAM. WHERE OUR
RECRUITMENT UNITS REACHING OUT
TO COMMUNITY MEMBERS THROUGHOUT
THE CITY- ELICITING THEIR
SUPPORT AND WE HAVE THEIR
SUPPORT TO HOST RECRUITING
EVENTS RECOMMENDING RECRUITING
LOCATIONS WITHIN THEIR
COMMUNITIES. AND ALSO REFERRING
CANDIDATES OR RECRUITERS BUT
THE GENIE. IS A BIG COMPONENT
OF. OUR BIG IS AN EXTENT AN ARM
OF WAR EFFORTS TO RECRUIT THE
MOST QUALIFIED AND MOST
DIVERSITY SERGEANTS AT SAN
FRANCISCO. LASTLY I JUST WANT
TO AND THAT YOU KNOW THE
DEPARTMENT IS REFLECTIVE OF THE
COMMUNITY WITH LOCALS. AND WE
STRIVE FOR DIVERSE POLICE
DEPARTMENT WHAT PROFESSIONAL
BODIES RETALIATES. WE
UNDERSTAND THAT OFFICERS YOU
CAN COMMUNICATE IN SPANISH
CHINESE AND RUSSIAN TO BETTER
ASSIST THE COMMUNITY. OFFICERS
UNDERSTAND CULTURAL TRADITIONS
AND BELIEFS THAT EXIST WITHIN
YOU CAN BETTER ASSIST. TO AS OF
TODAY THE SAN FRANCISCO POLICE
DEPARTMENT. SWORN MEMBERS. IS
50% PEOPLE OF COLOR.
APPROXIMATELY THREE HUNDRED
FIFTY FOUR OFFICERS ARE
CERTIFIED IN SPANISH MANDARIN
CANTONESE TELL GOLOVKIN RUSSIAN.
THERE ARE SWORN STAFF IS 8585%
MALE 50% FEMALE. IN A RECRUIT
CLASSES ARE 70% OF GROUPS OF
PEOPLE CALLING. AND THAT'S ALL
HAPPENED I APPRECIATE YOUR TIME
AND OPPORTUNITIES ALL LOOK
FORWARD TO ANYTHING ELSE WE CAN
DO BETTER THIS PROFESSION IN
THE FIRST FIVE MEMBERS OF
OFFICE DEPARTMENTS ACROSS THIS
GREAT STATE. SERVE OUR
COMMUNITIES THANK YOU. THANK%
YOU VERY MUCH MR YE WE REALLY
APPRECIATE YOUR TESTIMONY. AND
YOUR- YOUR EXPERTISE AND
JOINING US- TO- GIVE US- BIRDS
EYE VIEW IN TERMS OF
RECRUITMENT. AGAIN I THINK OUR
RESPONSIBILITY IS CERTAINLY TO
ASSESS THE THAT THE PAST AS
WELL AS LOOK AT THE- THE
CURRENT STATE WE'RE IN TO TRY
TO REACH SOME KIND OF. POSITIVE
CONCLUSION- MOVING FORWARD SO
MEMBERS OF THOSE WHO ARE
VIRTUALLY JOINING US I WOULD
ASK IF YOU WANT TO GET IN THE
QUEUE WE ARE AT THE POINT NOW.
WHERE WE'RE GOING TO TAKE
QUESTIONS AND ANSWERS FROM ANY
OTHER PRESENTERS WHO ARE STILL
HOPEFULLY ON THE LINE WITH US-
WE DO HAVE- RB K. REBEKAH. CON
JOINING US IN A FEW MOMENTS BUT
AGAIN PLEASE TAX ME- I SEE YOU
ALL RECOGNIZE YOU HAVE TO ASK
QUESTIONS SO WE WOULD ASK. OUR
B. K. WOULD YOU PLEASE PROCEED
ASK YOUR QUESTIONS. THANK YOU
MISTER CHAIR SO I THINK THIS IS
DIRECTLY THIS DROUGHT CON IN
CHIEF HìNH. BUT AND THE CHIEF
MENTIONED THAT IT'S FROM
APPLICATION TO THE- ELIGIBILITY
HE LOSES ABOUT 90% OF
APPLICANTS I THINK THAT WAS THE
DATA THAT HE CITED. AND I'VE
HEARD THAT BEFORE THAT MANY
pMAKE IT TO ACADEMY I WANT TO
TALK ABOUT THAT PIECE OF THE
PUZZLE PEOPLE WHO ARE FLYING.
BUT DON'T MAKE IT TO EVEN BE
POTENTIALLY IN THE RANKS OF OUR
POLICE FORCES. I WANT
UNDERSTAND WHAT THOSE FACTORS
ARE THAT DR 90% OF PEOPLE TO
NOT BE ELIGIBLE. ARE THOSE
THINGS HAVING A DISPARATE
IMPACT ON WOMEN AND PEOPLE OF
COLOR. ARE SHOULD WE BE LOOKING
AT THAT PIECE OF THE PUZZLE TO
MAKE THOSE ELIGIBLE MORE
DIVERSE OUR LITTLE ALL OF
THOSE. THINGS CRITICAL TO A
SAFE AND EFFECTIVE AND
TRUSTWORTHY POLICE FORCE
EVERYTHING'S. WE SHOULD HOLD ON
TO- AS MISS VICE ON MENTIONED
ARE THERE OTHER FACTORS WE
SHOULD BE LOOKING AT THAT
SHOULD MAKE FOLKS INELIGIBLE TO
MAKE IT TO THAT FINAL PHASE FOR
EXAMPLE- EXPERIENCE OR TIES TO
WHITE SUPREMACY GROUPS SO. I
PUT IT BACK TO YOU BUT I'D LIKE
YOU TO SPEAK FURTHER ABOUT THAT
PIECE OF THE PUZZLE THANK YOU.
I COULD SPEAK UP AT THE THANK
YOU ASSEMBLY MEMBER- I CAN
SPEAK. FROM THE PERSPECTIVE MY
EXPERIENCE THE ONLY POLICE
DEPARTMENT THE BIGGEST FACTOR I
THINK IN Y. CANDIDATES WILL
WILL MAYBE DROP OFF DURING THE
PROCESS IS A LARGE PART TIME.
THE TIME REQUIRED TO CONDUCT A
BACKGROUND INVESTIGATION AND GO
THROUGH ALL THE DIFFERENT STEPS
AND PROCESS THESE CAN BE VERY
LENGTHY. IT COULD BE A MATTER
OF YOU KNOW. TWO THREE MONTHS
TO SIX MONTHS TO A YEAR
DEPENDING ON. WHAT NEEDS TO BE
DONE AND MANY PEOPLE JUST CAN'T
WAIT THAT LONG FOR A JOB. I'M
IN TERMS OF THE FACTORS THERE
VARIETY OF FACTORS WHY PEOPLE
MAY SCREEN OUT AND DEPARTMENTS
HAVE GOTTEN BETTER AT MAKING
SURE THEY MEET THE MINIMUM
REQUIREMENTS BEFORE EVEN
APPLYING. ONE BUT IT'S A VERY
RIGOROUS PROCESS IN TERMS OF
TESTING YOU KNOW LOOKING AT
THEIR PHYSICAL CAPABILITIES-
I'VE WRITTEN AND ORAL TASKS-
PSYCHOLOGICAL SCREENING WHICH
TAKES A GREAT DEAL OF TIME-
THOSE TYPES OF THINGS LOOKING
AT SORT OF THOSE MINIMUM
OCCUPATIONAL QUALIFICATIONS. I
THINK THE ONE AREA THAT IS
WORTHY OF EXPLORATION IN TERMS
OF THE PROCESS IS DEPARTMENTS
TO CONTINUE TO USE HOLOGRAPH
EXAMINATION- THE POLYGRAPH. HAS
ITS UTILITY BUT I'VE ALWAYS
QUESTIONED IT BOTH AS WHEN I
WAS A PROSECUTOR IN THE PROCESS
NOW ABOUT ITS VALIDITY. THE
SCIENTIFIC WAY. TO BE ABLE TO
TRULY FIND DECEPTION. IT COULD
BE USED AND CERTAINLY PEOPLE
WILL CONFESS TO THINGS- BEFORE
THEY- I'M TO THE POLYGRAPH BUT
THE CHANCES OF FALSE POSITIVES
AND FALSE NEGATIVES ARE ARE
STILL VERY HIGH. IN IT'S NOT
THAT IT'S NOT A- IT'S NOT A
USEFUL TOOL BUT I REALLY WANT
TO THE AMOUNT OF TIME EFFORT
MONEY. WOULD BE BETTER SPENT ON
MORE THOROUGH BACKGROUND
INVESTIGATIONS LOOKING AT-
TALKING TO MORE SO SEE IT'S
LOOKING ESPECIALLY IF A
CANDIDATE LIVES ELSEWHERE- IN
THE VALUE OF THAT TO FIND THOSE
ASSOCIATIONS THAT YOU. YOU
ALLUDED. TO OF BIAS AND OTHER
THINGS. THANK YOU VERY. BOB
I'LL JUMP IN- YEAH THERE'S ALL
SORTS OF RE WHY DON'T MAKE IT
THROUGH- BUT THE BIGGEST FACTOR
IS THE GROUPS THAT WE ARE LOW
ON WHICH YOUR- TO BE MORE
SPECIFIC IS AFRICAN AMERICAN
HISPANIC WOMEN. IS STARTS FROM
THE VERY BEGINNING WE HAVE VERY
FEW OF THOSE GROUPS A PLOT- AND
SO PART OF IT IS HOW DO WE
CHANGE THE PERCEPTION AND THOSE
SORT OF THINGS AMONGST GROUPS
THAT START OUT BEHIND BECAUSE
THEY DON'T APPLY- BUT THERE'S
ALL SORTS OF REASONS WHY THEY
GET KICKED OUT WITH THE
BACKGROUND IS A VERY EXTENSIVE.
THEY'LL GO OT OF STATE IF
YOU'RE FROM OUT OF STATE THEY
TALK TO YOUR NEIGHBORS THEY GO
TO YOUR SCHOOLS THEY LOOK AT
YOUR PERSONNEL FILE IF YOU'RE
FROM ANOTHER DEPARTMENT OR EVEN
APPLIED AT ANOTHER DEPARTMENT
SO IF YOU'VE APPLIED FOR THREE
OTHER DEPARTMENTS ARE
BACKGROUND INVESTIGATORS GO
LOOK AT YOUR BACKGROUND PACKET
THOSE DEPARTMENTS AND IF YOU
TOLD THEM SOMETHING YOU DON'T
TELL US THAT'S A MAJOR PROBLEM
YOU'RE PROBABLY NOT. SO THAT-
I'LL JUST THE- A LITTLE BIT
IT'S A INVALUABLE TOOL SOME
PEOPLE USE A VOICE. STRESS TEST
WE USE A POLYGRAPH WE FOUND OUT
A LOT OF THINGS TO THE
POLYGRAPH THAT. WE DIDN'T YOU
DIDN'T TELL US. BEFORE THE
POLYGRAPH SO IS CRITICAL PART
OF THE PROCESS. I MEAN YOU GET
OTHER CHANCES TO TAKE POLYGRAPH
IF YOU DON'T PASS A QUESTION TO
SEE IF WELL MAYBE JUST LEFT
SOME OUTLETS WILL RECHECK IT.
AND THEN SOME PEOPLE PASS AT
THAT POINT. I'M BUT THE OTHER
THING AND- MANY ALVAREZ IS ON
HERE SO HE AND I HAVE TALKED
ABOUT THIS AND POST IS WORKING
ON THIS. BUT THE OTHER THING
THAT- IS CRITICAL IN THE HIRING
PROCESS IS OBVIOUSLY. YOU DON'T
MAKE IT THROUGH THE ACADEMY YOU
GOT HIRED BUT- LIKE YOU'RE
STILL NOT AN OFFICER ON THE
STREET BECAUSE YOU DIDN'T MAKE
IT TO THE ACADEMY SO. TO ME
THAT'S SORT OF PART OF THE
HIRING PROCESS. AND WHAT WE
FOUND IN YEARS PAST THAT- LIKE
THE TWO ACADEMIES PRIOR TO ME.
BEING SWORN IN AS CHIEF HERE IN
SACRAMENTO WE LOST AND I THINK
IT'S SOMEWHERE BETWEEN SIXTEEN
OR EIGHTEEN PEOPLE WERE KICKED
OUT OF. A TOTAL OF TWO
ACADEMIES. EVERY ONE OF THEM
WAS DIVERSE. SO THE EVERY
SINGLE PERSON WE KICKED OUT WAS
EITHER- RACIAL RACIALLY DIVERSE
OR GENDER DIFFERS. IN EVERY
SINGLE ONE OF THEM WAS KICKED
OUT FOR SHOOTING RANGE. OR
DRIVING. TWO THINGS THAT I
THINK ARE LEARNED- SKILLS SO WE
DON'T WANT TO LOWER THE
STANDARDS- BECAUSE YOU NEED TO
KNOW HOW TO DRIVE AND YOU NEED
TO KNOW- THE RANGE. BUT TO ME
PRETTY MUCH ANYBODY CAN LEARN
THOSE SKILLS BUT WE DON'T ALL
START AT THE SAME SPOT FOR
EXAMPLE. WHEN I WAS IN THE
ACADEMY I WAS NINETEEN YEARS
OLD I'VE NEVER TOUCHED A GUN
BEFORE. MY ROOMMATE WAS FIFTY
THREE YEARS OLD AND- JUST SPENT
THIRTY YEARS IN THE MILITARY. I
THINK YOU CAN JUST HAVE CLASS
TOMORROW WE'RE GONNA BE OF THE
SAME SPOT. I MEAN I'M LEARNING
HOW TO PUT THE MAGAZINE IN THE
GUN AND HE CAN SHOOT IT THROUGH
A ONE INCH HOLE OR THIRTY
ROUNDS. IN SO IT MIGHT TAKE ME
A MONTH TO GET THAT SKILL
WHERE'S HE. STARTS OUT WITH
THAT SKILL. BUT THE RULES
ALWAYS HAD S. THIS IS. ACT THE
SAME. LIKE I HAVE LEARN IT IN A
CERTAIN OF TIME. SO ONE WE'RE
WORKING ON A LOT OF THOSE
THINGS WITH POST. BUT THE OTHER
THING WE DID IS INSTEAD IT
WOULD BE FOR THE SIX MONTH
ACADEMY WE NOW HAVE A PRE
ACADEMY. OR WE PUT ALL OUR
PEOPLE THROUGH A MONTH TO A
MONTH AND A HALF OF A PRE
ACADEMY. WHERE IT'S HEAVY ON
RANGE AND DRIVING AND WE HAVE
KICKED VERY FEW PEOPLE OUT OF
THE ACADEMY DUE TO THOSE
THINGS. BUT PRIOR TO THAT WE
WERE LOOSE THE THAT LITTLE BIT
OF DIVERSITY THAT WE WERE
GETTING AT THAT TIME. BEFORE
WE'VE REVAMPED OUR RECRUITING
AND SOME OF THE OTHER THINGS
AFFECT STATE THAT WE'VE DONE-
THE LITTLE BIT THAT WE RECRUIT.
AT WHERE WE'RE HIRING A LOT OF
IT WE WERE KICKING OUT AN
ACADEMY FOR THOSE TWO ISSUES
AND THAT HAS BEEN SOLVED SO.
SOME OF THESE THINGS YOU JUST
HAVE TO LOOK AT THE PROCESS AND
SEE IF THERE'S SOME OTHER WAY
WE CAN ACCOMPLISH THIS. AND
THAT'S WHAT WE GET. THANK YOU
CAN I ASK ONE FOLLOW UP
QUESTION MISTER CHAIR. SURE OF
HIS BRIEF YES OKAY THANKS- SO
THANK YOU AND I APPRECIATE THAT
THAT WAS- HELPFUL INFORMATION
BOTH OF YOU AND I THINK IT
REALLY SPEAKS TO THE FACT THAT
WE NEED TO ADDRESS THE CULTURE
OF POLICING SO THAT MORE PEOPLE
OF COLOR AND WOMEN WANT TO JOIN
THE RANKS FROM THE GET GO AND
LOCAL EYES CHIU HUNT POINTED
AT. MY LAST QUESTION IS- DEBTS
WHAT ROLE DOES THAT PLAY IN-
THAT BACKGROUND IN HOW DOES
ITEM AND IS ESSENTIALLY
DISPROPORTIONATE. THANK YOU.
YEAH I'LL I'LL- DO THAT
EVERYTHING IS- LOOKED AT
COLLECTIVELY SO MEANING THAT
ISN'T THAT BIG OF A DEAL BUT IF
YOU HAVE EVERY SINGLE COUNT
YOU'VE HAD OVER THE LAST TEN
YEARS. IN COLLECTIONS. AND THAT
SHOWS IN THEIR RESPONSIBILITY
AND THAT'S THAT'S GOING TO BE A
PROBLEM. BUT EVEN IF YOU HAD
COLLECTIONS FIVE YEARS AGO
PRETTY MUCH ANYTHING THAT YOU
HAVE IN YOUR PAST. IF YOU HAVE.
A TRACK RECORD AFTER THAT THAT
MEANS OKAY YOU LEARN FROM THOSE
MISTAKES THAT YOU MADE. AND NOW
YOU'RE MAKING GOOD DECISIONS
THEN YOU'RE FINE SO DEBT ITSELF
DOESN'T REALLY MEAN ANYTHING.
BUT IF YOU'RE NOT PAYING YOUR
BILLS IF YOU AREN'T COLLECTIONS
IF YOU HAD DONE FOR COMPUTERS.
THOSE SORT OF THINGS DO MATTER.
THANK YOU THANK YOU VERY MUCH-
NEXT WE WILL HAVE A MISTER A
MEMBER REYES. AND THEN AFTER
THAT WE HAVE MISTER- A MEMBER-
MCCARTY AND THEN MAYES RUBIO
AND THEY MISS GONZALEZ IN THAT
ORDER. THANK YOU MISTER CHAIR I
DO WANT TO THANK ALL OF OUR
PRESENTERS THIS IS WONDERFUL I
APPRECIATE- THE RECOGNITION
THAT THIS ISN'T A QUICK FIX.
AND SO THAT THAT WITH OUR CHAIR
PUTTING TOGETHER. AND NOT JUST
ONE HEARING BUT A NUMBER OF
HEARINGS OTHER WILL
PROGRESSIVELY TALK ABOUT THE
ISSUES IDENTIFYING THEM AND
THEN TRYING TO FIGURE OUT HOW
WE ADDRESS THEM. OF THIS BASED
ON I APPRECIATE. YOUR COMMENT
THAT THE COMMUNITY THAT IS MOST
IMPACTED SHOULD LEAD THE
DISCUSSION- MY QUESTION TO YOU
IF YOU WERE STILL WITH US IS
HOW DO YOU SEE THAT
SPECIFICALLY HAPPENING. WHERE
AT WHAT POINT DO YOU SEE THAT
HAPPENING. SHE'S COING TO THE
MICROPHONE NOW YES YOU MAY
PROCEED. NO I THINK HE'S GOING
TO ADJUSTING MICROPHONE. AND
WE'LL TRY TO SEE IF THAT WORKS.
YES IT'S ON. MAKE SURE YOUR
CLOTHES YEAH CAN YOU HEAR ME
YES WE CAN OKAY ALL RIGHT SO
THE QUESTION IS SPECIFICALLY
HOW- YOU ASKED HOW DO I HI
INVISION COMMUNITY OVERSIGHT
AND COMMUNITY LEADING IN THE
MOST IMPACTED LEADING I THINK
THAT WE NEED INPUT FROM THE
COMMUNITY WE NEED- WE NEED
SPACES WHERE COMMUNITY CAN GIVE
SUGGESTIONS WE NEED THE PEOPLE
THAT ARE THE MOST IMPACTED. TO
TELL YOU THEIR EXPERIENCES SO
THAT OUR LEGISLATORS CAN MAKE
DECISIONS THAT ARE BASED ON
THOSE EXPERIENCES- WE HAVE I'VE
I WORK WITH A LOT OF PEOPLE IN
COMMUNITY AND THERE'S A LOT OF
COMMONALITIES IN OUR
COMMUNITIES AND COMMUNITIES OF
COLOR. AND AS LONG AS THOSE
THINGS CONTINUE TO HAPPEN THEN
THOSE THINGS NEED TO BE
ADDRESSED AND IF WE'RE NOT
HEARING. HOW YOU KNOW A
THIRTEEN YEAR OLD BOYS BEEN
PULLED OVER TWICE. AND HAD GUNS
DRAWN ON HIM BY POLICE WHEN HE
HASN'T BEEN DOING ANYTHING
WRONG IF YOU'RE NOT HEARING THE
STORIES THEN. YOU DON'T KNOW
THEY'RE HAPPENING IN THE
EXAMPLE THAT I GAVE EARLIER. I
SAW THE EXPRESSIONS OF SOME OF
THE FOLKS IN HERE WHEN THEY
HEARD YOU KNOW THE EXAMPLES OF
WHAT'S WHAT'S HAPPENED WELL
WE'VE BEEN DOING ACTIVIST WORK
IN THE STREETS. AND THEY WERE
SURPRISED TO EVEN HEAR THAT A
THIRTEEN YEAR OLD BOY GOT SHOT
WITH A RUBBER BULLET WHILE AT A
PROTEST BY A POLICE OFFICER. SO
I THINK BASICALLY IT ALL BOILS
DOWN TO LISTENING TO. THE
COMMUNITY AND THEIR EXPERIENCES
AND THEN. CREATING LEGISLATION
AROUND THOSE EXPERIENCES AND
SEEING THE COMMONALITIES IN ALL
OF THESE EXPERIENCES. WHILE
YOU'RE- YES AND WHILE YOU'RE
THERE ONE OTHER QUESTION A
FOLLOW UP YOU ALSO TALKED ABOUT
THIS RELATIONSHIP BETWEEN OUR-
ABOUT BETWEEN LAW ENFORCEMENT
SPECIALLY POLICE CHIEFS AND
SHERIFFS AND OUR ELECTED. DO
YOU SEE A PARTICULAR WAY TO-
AND LET WEATHER LET THAT
THROUGH LEGISLATION OR THROUGH
RULES OF- PROMULGATED AT THE
COUNTY OR THE CITY LEVEL THAT
WOULD ASSIST IN. SEPARATING
THESE RELATIONSHIPS BETWEEN LAW
ENFORCEMENT- CHIEFS AND
SHERIFFS AND ELECTIVES. SO I AM
NOT AN EXPERT ON LEGISLATION-
SO I THINK THAT IT WOULD BE
GREAT FOR LEGISLATORS TO GET
CREATIVE IN THAT AREA- I JUST
WANTED TO MAKE SURE TO MENTION
THAT THESE ARE REALLY BIG.
OBSTACLES IN COMMUNITY RIGHT
NOW. AND I CAN ONLY SPEAK TO
SACRAMENTO IN PARTICULAR- ARE.
OUR SHERIFF HAS A VERY STRONG
ANTI POLLUTION SHOULD WITH OUR
DISTRICT ATTORNEY. AND AS A
RESULT HER RECORD OUR DISTRICT
ATTORNEY'S RECORD HAS NEVER
SERVE THE PEOPLE- ALSO YOU KNOW
OUR POLICE CHIEF AND OUR MAYOR
AND OUR- OUR- CITY MANAGER THEY
ALL HAVE A VERY. GOOD
RELATIONSHIP WITH EACH OTHER WE
OFTEN SEE THE CITY MANAGER
INTERMINGLING WITH DIFFERENT
POLICE OFFICERS YOU KNOW WHILE
HE'S OUT DOING HIS WORK. AND
YOU KNOW THERE ARE CASUAL
CONVERSATIONS I'VE SEEN OUR
COUNCIL MEMBERS HAVE BACKDOOR
YOU KNOW COME OUT OF A ROOM
WITH OUR- THE SACRAMENTO
POLICE. OFFICERS ASSOCIATION- I
WANT TO SAY IS TITLES EXECUTIVE
DIRECTOR'S NAME IS TIM DAVIS
I'VESEEN THEM COME OUT A ROOMS
PETTING EACH OTHER'S BACKS AND
I THINK ALL OF THAT IS
PROBLEMATIC BECAUSE THEY'RE
BUILDING RELATIONSHIPS WITH
EACH OTHER. AND AS A RESULT
THEY'RE BEHOLDEN TO EACH OTHER
AND THEY'RE NOT BUILDING
RELATIONSHIPS WITH COMMUNITY
AND FINDING OUT WHAT'S
HAPPENING TO COMMUNITY- I JUST
THINK IT'S REALLY IMPORTANT TO
KEEP ALL THAT IN MIND WHILE
MAKING LEGISLATION BUT I
WOULDN'T KNOW HOW TO TELL YOU-
WHAT THAT LEGISLATION AS TO HOW
HOW THE KID. HOW REFORM COULD
BE MADE THROUGH LEGISLATION TO.
MAKE SURE THAT THE CHECKS AND
BALANCES ARE ACTUALLY AFFECTED
OF. THANK YOU KNOW WHAT IS A
WISE FRIEND ONCE TOLD ME THAT
IT ISN'T JUST THE YEAR
PROPRIETY BUT THE APPEARANCE OF
IMPROPRIETY. THAT WE HAVE TO BE
CONCERNED WITH. THANK YOU SO
MUCH.MISTER CHAIR ONE LAST
QUESTION- IF IT'S QUICK YES.
GREAT HAVE ALL RIGHT- IT'S- IN
THE END OF THE QUESTION IS- DO
ANY LAW ENFORCEMENT AGENCIES.
DO ANY KIND OF PERSONALITY AND
PSYCHOLOGICAL EVALUATIONS
BEFORE HIRING AN OFFICER OR
ALLOWING SOMEONE TO TRAIN-
TYPICALLY THESE ARE DONE AFTER
THERE'S BEEN USE OF A WEAPON-
OR OR OR OR SOMETHING OF THE
SORT BUT MY QUESTION IS. I
DON'T DO IT DON'T DO ANY OF OUR
LAW ENFORCEMENT AGENCIES DO
THIS BEFOREHAND- IN THE
RECRUITMENT PROCESS. CHIEF
HARVESTER WITH US OR ANYONE OUR
PRESENTERS THAT YOU CAN ADDRESS
THAT QUESTION OF MYSTERIOUS.
WELL JUST ASSEMBLY MEMBER GETS
YES WE DO IN THE HIRING PROCESS
YOU HAVE TO. GO FAR
PSYCHOLOGICAL EXAM AND WE'VE
DONE THAT. FOR AT LEAST THIRTY
THREE YEARS BECAUSE I HAD TO DO
IT AND WE ARE ACTUALLY
EXPLORING THE POSSIBILITY OF
DOING GREG OUR EXAM ON OUR
EXISTING OFFICERS. BUT
OBVIOUSLY THERE'S STILL A LOT
OF WORK TO DO ON THAT
NEGOTIATIONS AND THINGS BUT YES
EVERY OFFICER THAT IS FIRED ON
THIS POLICE DEPARTMENT. FOR
SEVERAL THE LAST SEVERAL
DECADES HAS HAD TO HAVE A
PSYCHOLOGICAL. THANK YOU VERY
MUCH THANK YOU NEXT WE WANT
MISTER CHAIR ABSOLUTELY THANK
YOU FOR YOUR QUESTION. WE WANT
TO GO TO MR MCCARTY AND THEN
MISS RUBIO AND THEN MISS
GONZALEZ IN THAT ORDER. I THANK
YOU MISTER CHAIR I HAVE A
COUPLE COMMENTS AND A QUESTION-
THE FIRST IS I WANT TO JUST
NOTE THAT THE ICE I GREATLY
APPRECIATE OUR OUR POLICE
CHIEF. DANIEL HAHN- CHIEF ON
SOME OF OUR COLLEAGUES ARE ARE
JUST SAID WELL WE NEED MORE OF
WHAT YOU'RE TALKING ABOUT HERE
IN SACRAMENTO. AND I REALIZED
TO THAT'S NOT JUST WHAT LAWS WE
RIGHT HERE AT THE CAPITOL ALL
THIS IS BASED UPON LEADERSHIP
WE HAVE. IN OUR COMMUNITY SO
THE EXAMPLE THAT YOU TALKED
ABOUT. A CHANGING THE- THERE
RICK THE RECRUITMENT AND
TRAINING PROCESS TO TAKE MAKING
SURE WE DON'T WEED OUT PEOPLE.
WHO GOT AS YOU SAID THAT WAS
VERY STRIKING THAT ALMOST ALL
THE SEGMENTS ALL JUST ABOUT ALL
OF THAT- TWENTY OR SO
APPLICANTS WERE YOU KNOW WOMEN
OR PEOPLE OF COLOR AND THOSE
THAT THAT'S A WORD THE MORNING
pSTREETS AND SO. NO THAT'S
THAT'S NOT LAWS THAT WE CAN
RIGHT HERE PER SE I'M CERTAINLY
MAYBE- POSTED SOME DIRECTION
THERE BUT THAT'S BUT FOR
LEADERSHIP ACROSS THE STATE- I
WANTED TO NOW TALK ABOUT. THE
RECRUITMENT AND THE
REQUIREMENTS FOR OFFICERS AND
ASK- IT YEAH CHIEF HAN AND ALSO
WGP IF YOU CAN LIGHT IS A
LITTLE BIT OF A BAD. SO I I'VE
ALL I'VE OFTEN WONDERED ABOUT
ABOUT OFFICERS AND THEIR-
EDUCATION REQUIREMENTS AND WE
TALKED ABOUT OFFICER SULLIVAN
WHO'D WHO TRAGICALLY WAS SHOT
MURDER HERE. IN SACRAMENTO AND
SHE HAD A DEGREE IN EARLY
EDUCATION I ALWAYS A MEMBER AT
THE UNIVERSITY PRESIDENT SACKS
STATE HE MET HER. AND HE SAID
YOU'RE GOING TO BE A POLICE
OFFICER WHY DID YOU DECIDE TO
STUDY EARLY EDUCATION AND NOT
CRIMINAL JUSTICE AND SHE SAYS
WELL BECAUSE I MEAN WORKING
WITH PEOPLE. AND I WONDER
UNDERSTAND PEOPLE SO I'VE
ALWAYS THOUGHT THAT MAYBE
THAT'S THE RIGHT ANSWER ME WE
NEED MORE PEOPLE STUDYING.
HUMAN DEVELOPMENT PSYCHOLOGY
SOCIAL WORK ETHNIC STUDIES-
BECAUSE WE'RE GONNA LEARN THAT
CRIMINAL JUSTICE STUFF IN THE
ACADEMY SO. I'M NOT SURE IF
THAT'S AN ISSUE AS FAR AS WHAT
YOUR DEGREE IS I WOULD THINK
THAT. YOU KNOW LEARNING. ABOUT
THE HUMAN ELEMENT BECAUSE LET'S
FACE AND OF THE POLICE. THAT
PEOPLE ARE RISK. TO ARE ABOUT
HUMAN CRISIS SO MUCH. YOU KNOW
HE DOMESTIC VIOLENCE CALLS AND
MENTAL ILLNESS AND PEOPLE AND
THAT IS WAY MORE. OF THE ISSUE
FOR CALLS FOR SERVICE. THEN
ALWAYS TACTICAL LAW ENFORCEMENT
ISSUES- SO YOU KNOW THAT'S JUST
ABOUT SOMETHING I ALWAYS.
WONDER IT IS SHOULD THAT BE A
PRIORITY AS WELL MAYBE YOU CAN.
UPON ON THAT. BUT BUT THE OTHER
THE BIG QUESTION I WANTED TO
ASK IN OF COURSE TODAY. WE'RE
NOT WRITING BILLS WERE NOT
MAKING LAWS WERE UNDERSTANDING.
SOME OF THESE PROPOSALS OUT
THERE. THAT MAYBE IT IT'LL
BILL. THAT SOME CITIES ALREADY
DO SO MY UNDERSTANDING HERE AT
SAC CITY AS OUR TEAM SAID. WE
HAVE A REQUIREMENT THAT YOU
MUST HAVE AN EIGHT AND A. EIGHT
DEGREE. TO ENTER THE ACADEMY
AND THE SACRAMENTO COUNTY
SHERIFF. THERE'S NO REQUIREMENT
JUST- YOU HAVE TO BE EIGHTEEN
YEARS OF AGE. AND RESEARCH HAS
SHOWN AS WE SAID EARLIER. THAT
PEOPLE WHO ARE OLDER AND HAVE
MORE EDUCATION. HAVE BETTER
RESULTS IN THE FIELD AND LAST-
UNLESS PROBLEMS- SO. SHOULD WE
HAVE. AN AGE REQUIREMENT. AND
SHOULD WE HAVE. AN EDUCATIONAL
REQUIREMENT A. STATE WIDE
STANDARD- THOSE ARE MY FIRST
QUESTIONS THANK YOU. CHIEF OR
WHOEVER WANTS TO RESPOND. I
GUESS I'LL GO FIRST- SO YEAH I
THINK THAT ANY SIGNIFICANT
CHANGE IN WHETHER IT'S AGE
REQUIREMENT RIGHT NOW WE HAVE
TWENTY ONE YEARS OLD IF THAT
WAS TO MOVE TO SAY TWENTY FIVE
AND SWITCH FROM HAVING A HIGH
SCHOOL DIPLOMA OR GED TO A
BACHELOR'S DEGREE WHICH WHAT IT
WOULD BE FOR MOST DEPARTMENTS.
OURS WE LIKE I SAID WE REQUIRE
TWO YEARS OF COLLEGE I THINK
WOULD HAVE A SIGNIFICANT IMPACT
AND SO WE NEED TO BE VERY
CAREFUL WITH THAT- NO LIKE I
SAID I START AT NINETEEN YEARS
OLD AND NOW I'VE DONE THIRTY
THREE YEARS AND I'M THE POLICE
CHIEF CHAU. IF I WAS REQUIRED
TO BE TWENTY FIVE YEARS OLD AND
HAVE A BACHELOR'S DEGREE I
WOULD NEVER. AND IT WILL
DISPROPORTIONATELY IMPACT
GROUPS THAT WE ARE TRYING TO
RECRUIT BECAUSE WE ARE TRYING
TO GET THEM AT A VERY EARLY
AGE. IN JOBS THAT MANY OF THE
LIKE THIS- SOME OF THOSE JOBS
LIKE STUDENT TRAINEE THEY'RE
REQUIRED TO GO TO COLLEGE TO
MAINTAIN THE JOB. SO I THINK
THE EDUCATION WISE- I REALLY
LIKE WHERE WE'RE AT WITH TWO
YEARS OF COLLEGE I DO THINK
EDUCATION MAKES A DIFFERENCE.
BUT YOU SEE MOST OF OUR
OFFICERS ESPECIALLY ONCE HIRED
IN THE LAST TEN FIFTEEN YEARS.
VAST MAJORITY OF THEM HAVE
BACHELOR'S DEGREES THAT DOESN'T
MEAN THEY STARTED WITH A
BACHELOR'S DEGREE. BUT WE OFFER
INCENTIVE PAY. FOR BACHELOR'S
DEGREES SO THERE'S OTHER WAYS
TO GET TO THE EDUCATIONAL
REQUIREMENT THAT MIGHT WORK
BETTER. IN THIS PROFESSION AND
FOR US YOU GET- MORE PAY IF YOU
HAVE A BACHELOR'S DEGREE SO.
YOU MIGHT NOT START WITH ONE
BUT THEN YOU'LL GET ONE TO. ONE
OF THE REASONS BEING YOU WANT
MORE PAY. CHECK CAN I ALSO WAY
I'M SORRY. PLEASE OUR- A COUPLE
OF PUBLIC COMMENTS- IT WHICH
QUESTION I ALSO CONCORD THE
NEED FOR MINIMUM IF YOU CAN
BACKUP YOUR DISCUSSION AS TO
WHAT THAT LOOKS LIKE ALREADY
MENTIONED BY SOME OF MY
COLLEAGUES ON THIS PANEL ARE WE
NOT CONSISTENTLY ONE MAJOR
INDICATOR OUR SUCCESSFUL
POLICING IF I'M STOP REDUCTION
IN POLICE CITIZEN COMPLAINTS IS
EDUCATION ABOUT HOUSE OR
LISTENING VERY CONSISTENT- YOU
KNOW THROUGHOUT. AND WE HAVE
ALSO NOTICED I KNOW I'D THIS
MOMENT WHERE WHERE IN OUR- WE
ALSO WANT TO KIND OF MESS WHERE
WE WHERE- EVEN YOU KNOW TWENTY
FIFTY SIXTY YEARS AGO THE
COMPANY SENDS ALL OF THE THINGS
WE KNOW HALF WALK HALF MAKE
PROGRESS AND EDUCATION
CONSISTENTLY ASKING MODEL IN
TERMS OF THEIR ABILITY TO MAKE
THESE QUESTIONS ARE OF COURSE
FULLY I'M I'M FAIRLY WHICH WE
KNOW IS 90% OF TIME WHAT POLICE
OFFICERS DO TO BE ABLE TO
ATTACK WITH EMPATHY MOTIONAL
INTELLIGENCE. CRITICAL THINKING
AND PROBLEM SOLVING. ALSO TO MY
TO ARGUE NO COMMENT AND IT WAS
OF HOW. WHAT THAT. MINIMUM
EDUCATION WHO LOOKS LIKE OR IF
WALKER I AGREE WITH SOME MEMBER
AT MCCARTY ARE REPRESENTED-
THAT DOESN'T HAVE BE CRIMINALS-
I'M AND- IT COULD ANY OTHER
MEMBER OF YOUR- THINK SEASON.
TO WE RECOGNIZE OUR ASSIST
PROGRAM WHICH THIS LETTER COULD
BE JUST PROGRAM IN THE- HE- IS
A VERY MULTI JUST. IN APPROVED.
OUT WHERE WE DRAWN A LOT FOR
YOU KNOW MAJOR. TECH ACCORD
THESE INPUT IS COMING LISTEN.
ARE MINORITY CENTRIC JUSTICE IN
PUBLICATION IN OUR KNOW OUR
CRIMINOLOGY. TO JUSTICE
RESOLUTION. SO IT YOU KNOW THE
END OF COPPER IS A VERY. MULTI
DISCIPLINARY OP YOU KNOW AFTER
I'M ONE BACK WE DEFINITELY
RIGHT MY VERY PROUD OF I I'M
I'M- GONNA STUDENTS TO CALL
FROM ARE BACK IF NEXT. SO WHAT
I SPOKE ABOUT SOME. FINALLY I
WITH ARE BASED FACING RESPECT
HOW KIND REALLY POP NICE THE
SUN CLUB FOR TWELVE JUST. I
THOUGHT ACCOUNTABILITY. IS
BROKEN- THE BASE POLICE OFF
WOULD ALWAYS HAVE TO BE IN. BUT
IT DOES MEAN THAT IT ACTION HE
OR SHE DOES COME OUT THE BEST
WAY. IT WAS HIS HOUSE
RECOGNIZED BACK WHO GOT MARC.
BACK WITH BE CORRECT THAT COULD
BE RESTORED. AND BE REST. ARE
TO THE NEEDS OF THE COMMUNITY.
I'M GLAD THAT YOU DID SHE FROM
SAN FRANCISCO EASIEST HERE ARE
ALWAYS IN OUR ARMED BOB WHAT
I'M IMPRESSED WITH THE PROGRESS
OF FRANCISCO CITY POLICE
DEPARTMENT HAS MADE. AND I
THINK POP OUTFIT YOU KNOW THIS
IS MY PERSONALVIEW. IS BECAUSE
AFTER THE SOONEST OF LAWSUITS
AND BACK COURT CONTRAST I'M
CONSENT DECREES YOU WEBER TO
TAX ON BOTH STEPS MAKE FROM
BOTH STEPS ARE PART OF THAT
EASE THE USE ARE FOR YOUR- APP
KNOW THE POLICE ACCOUNTABILITY.
IN A SYSTEM I BELIEVE MISTER
PAUL HENDERSON- IS THE EXPECTED
DIRECTOR YOU KNOW READ QUITE
SOME OF HIS WORK OUR- TRYING
FROM USE BY THE EXPERIENCES.
AND ASK EARLIER ON I'M HOPING
THAT THE NEXT OPPORTUNITY R.
FIVE POINT IN THE NEXT HOUR
CALIFORNIA'S DEPARTMENT. OF
GENERAL. WOULD A PROJECT UPDATE
SOMEBODY WHO IS REALLY TECH
WHO'S VOTE WAS FOR. WITH THE
SCENT PACHAMAMA. ON GUARD ARE
BEHIND US AND HAS- I'M I'M NOT
SAYING THAT HAS TO BE HERE BUT
DOES GOT V. AND STOP ME ACTING
WOULD DO A LOT OF GOOD. I'M
SORRY THE ACCOUNT TO LOOK BACK
WE NEED TO TRY TO CLOSE IN
START FOR. OUR DIRECT FIT
PROPERLY THROUGH THANK YOU VERY.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH OF WILL-
WAS AS IT WAS A- MISTER MIKE
COMPLETE. YEAH JUST IT JUST NO
MORE QUESTIONS HERE JUST TO
KIND OF THAT I DON'T UP WORDS I
OUR CHIEF MEDICAL THINK HE'S-
IS THAT. HE WHAT THEY HAVE YOUR
SAC. WHICH IS MMHM SO AN A
PROBABLY TWENTY TWENTY ONE TO A
WAS YOU. DO UNTIL ROMAN YOU'RE
IN HIGH WHICH IS. A HOLLOW THAT
IS- TODAY. BUT- I THINK THAT WE
HAVE TO AT OUR DOOR. A DAY
WORKED OUT. PLEASE AND- IN. OF
EXCESS FOR AND VIOLENCE IN IT
CAN. AND SO WE KNOW THAT MORE
AND THE HIGH THE AGE. A RECAP
THAT OFF. LAST LIKE TO HAVE.
THOSE NEGATIVE. INCIDENTS IN
THE COMMUNITY WHAT ELSE KNOW WE
WANT FOCUS THE PERSON SO. YOU
KNOW WE DON'T I SEE. RIGHT
THERE. FOR THE OFF. AND SO HAVE
BEEN CENTER PAY FOR BATCHES
DEGREES SOME DEL. YOU KNOW
MAYBE SOMETHING THAT WE COULD
CONSIDER IN CALIFORNIA. IS
HAVING LIKE A CONDITIONAL
LICENSE LIKE YOU START AND THEN
LIKE THE CHIEF SAID. YOU HAVE A
CERTAIN AMOUNT OF YEARS TO
REQUIRED ADDITIONAL EDUCATION
SO. YOU START AT A AND THEN.
FOR A NUMBER OF YEARS HE IF HE
IF TO HAVE YOUR YOUR FULL
LICENSE YOU HAVE THE NUMBER OF
BECAUSE PERIOD OF TIME TO GET.
THAT ADDITIONAL TWO YEARS TO
GET YOUR BE A SO. THERE'S WAYS
YOU CAN DO IT WITHOUT I THINK-
HARMING THE DIVERSITY.
ABSOLUTELY THANK YOU VERY MUCH
FOR YOUR COMMENTS I THINK
EVERYTHING'S ON THE TABLE
THAT'S WHAT WE HAVE IN THIS
DISCUSSION- WE'RE NOT-
CONCLUDING OR- ARE ARE ARE
CREATING ANY KIND OF- POSITION
ON ANY. ONE WAY OR THE OTHER
IT'S ABOUT DIALOGUE WE HAVE
THAT DIALOGUE HERE TODAY A VERY
GOOD HAPPY. WE HAVE A NUMBER OF
TORRENTE OF EXPERTS- LENDING
THEIR VOICES IN THIS AREA SO
NEXT UP WE HAVE MISS RUBIO.
MISSED GONZALEZ AND IN MR
LACKEY. THANK YOU MISTER DIPS-
WILL FIRST OF. THANK FOR OF FOR
ALL OF THE MEMBERS OF THE
PANEL- APPRECIATE ALL OF THE
DISCUSSION- I WOULD DIE. WANT
TO JOIN JUST JUMP IN I. GREW UP
IN DOWNTOWN LA SPECIFICALLY IN
THE PICO UNION. AREA OF LOS
ANGELES I VENTURE TO SAY BY FAR
THE MOST DANGEROUS- AREA IF NOT
JUST IN THE COUNTY BUT IN THE
STATE I AND I AM CONCERNED I
WITH THE- EDUCATION COMPONENT
OF THIS- WHEN I WENT TO HIGH
SCHOOL I WANTED TO GO TO
COLLEGE AND MY COUNSELOR
ESSENTIALLY SAID- AND I WON'T
BE SPECIFIC BUT DATA. SAID THAT
I WAS NOT I SHOULD NOT GO TO
COLLEGE BECAUSE I WAS ONLY
GOING TO GET MARRIED AND HAVE
CHILDREN. THAT'S ESSENTIALLY
WHAT HE SAID I DON'T KNOW IF IT
WAS BECAUSE I'M A WOMAN-
BECAUSE I'M A LATINO OR BOTH-
AND SO. I SEE THAT I ALSO TO
REITERATE I THE FACT THAT A LOT
OF OUR COMMUNITIES DON'T HAVE
OF POLICE OFFICERS THAT LOOK
LIKE THEM. AND I IN MY CASE
AND- WHEN I WAS GROWING UP IN
THE PEOPLE UNION AREA OF
DOWNTOWN LA I DIDN'T SEE MANY.
SAFETY PERSONNEL OR POLICE
OFFICERS THAT LOOKED LIKE ME
NOW AND I USE THE EXAMPLE OF.
HOW I WANTED TO GO TO COLLEGE
AND WAS TOLD THAT I WAS THAT I
SHOULDN'T BECAUSE I SHOULD.
ACTUALLY JUST GOING TO HOME
ECONOMICS BECAUSE I WAS GOING
TO GET MARRIED HAVE CHILDREN-
THAT STOP ME FOR THE TEMPORARY
LEAVE FROM FROM GETTING AN
EDUCATION. AND WHEN WE ARE
REQUIRING. MORE EDUCATION IF
THE PHONE EXAMPLE IS A FOUR
YEAR DEGREE. FROM OUR POLICE
OFFICERS LESS AND LESS ARE
GOING TO LOOK LIKE ME IF WE
DON'T CHANGE THE EDUCATIONAL
POLICIES WITHIN OUR HIGH
SCHOOLS THE K. TWELVE SYSTEM AS
WELL. TO ENCOURAGE NOT
DISCOURAGE- MINORITIES AND
PEOPLE OF COLOR TO GO TO SCHOOL
NOW I KNOW THAT THAT FOR ME IT
WASN'T IN THE FIFTIES IT WAS
THIRTY YEARS AGO. AND THINGS
HAVE CHANGED I HAVE CHANGED
DRAMATICALLY BUT I VENTURE TO
SAY THAT THERE'S A WHOLE BUNCH
OF- ACADEMICS BUT STILL FEEL
THAT MINORITIES SHOULD NOT- OR
CAN NOT NOT THAT SHOULD NOT
THEY CANNOT ATTAIN. ARE THE
LEVEL OF EDUCATION THAT YOU
KNOW OTHER PEOPLE CAN UNTIL WE
CAN FIX THAT. WE'RE NOT
ENCOURAGING FOLKS- THAT LOOK
LIKE ME TO GOING TO. A POLICE
WORK FOR EXAMPLE I KNOW WE'VE
BEEN TALKING ABOUT I TO YOUR-
COLLEGE DEGREE AND THAT SOUNDS.
THAT SOUNDS GREAT I WILL ALSO
TELL YOU THAT I WAS A TEACHER-
ERRAND I DID NOT HAVE A
TEACHING CREDENTIAL WHEN I
STARTED TEACHING I WAS HIRED
UNDER THE- THE- EMERGENCY
PERMIT. AND WAS ALLOWED TO
TEACH I'M GOING TO COOK THE GO
TO SCHOOL I TO OBTAIN MY
CREDENTIAL- AND THERE ARE LIKE
CHEAP HAN SAID- IN THE TEACHING
WORLD WE DO HAVE INCENTIVES TO
CONTINUE OUR EDUCATION ON A
GIVE YOU EXAMPLE. THE MINIMUM
REQUIREMENT IS A BACHELOR'S
DEGREE IF YOU WANT TO MOVE UP
IN THE PAY SCALE THEN YOU
CONTINUE EITHER GET A MASTER'S
DEGREE OR CONTINUE YOUR
EDUCATION AND YOUR PAID. PAID
TO- BASED ON THAT- THE CONCERN
THAT I HAVE ABOUT THE
EDUCATIONAL REQUIREMENTS IS
THAT WE'RE GOING TO BE SHUTTING
PEOPLE OUT THAT LOOK LIKE AS-
TO BE- WITHIN THE COMMUNITY- AS
A TEACHER WE HAVE THE SAME
PROBLEM TEACHERS THE TEACHING
COMMUNITY HAS THE SAME ISSUES.
THERE'S NOT VERY MANY I
TEACHERS THAT LOOK LIKE THOSE
STUDENTS THAT THE TEACHERS
SPECIFICALLY THE BLACK AND
BROWN COMMUNITIES SO WE HAVE TO
BE CAREFUL WHEN WE'RE PUTTING
THESE REQUIREMENTS. THAT WE
DON'T DISENFRANCHISE ALREADY A
COMMUNITY ARE COMMUNITIES THAT
ARE DISENFRANCHISED AS IT IS
AND NOT ENCOURAGED TO GO TO
SCHOOL NOT ENCOURAGED TO GET A
DEGREE. BECAUSE NOW WE'RE GOING
TO HAVE LESS PEOPLE THAT LOOK
LIKE US- THAT THAT MAY OR MAY
NOT UNDERSTAND WHAT WE'RE GOING
THROUGH AND I USE THE EXAMPLE
OF ME. LIVING IN DOWNTOWN LA I
HAVE TO TELL YOU THE ISSUES AND
M. BOTH COMMUNITIES ARE FAR
BEYOND WHAT A DEGREE CAN TEACH
YOU. YOU NEED TO HAVE PEOPLE
THAT HAVE HAD THE EXPERIENCE AS
TO THE POINT I THINK I HEARD
YOU FOUND ALSO SAY THAT. THE
EXPERIENCE IS ALSO A FACTOR THE
EXPERIENCE FIRST OF ALL OF
BEING A LESBIAN OR A BLACK.
PERSON CAN ONLY COME FROM
PEOPLE THAT ARE LIVING THE SAME
EXAMPLES ARE LIVING THE SAME.
ISSUES THAT- THAT ARE WITHIN
THOSE COMMUNITIES I. HAVE ABOUT
ME LIVING IN DOWNTOWN BUT HAVE
NEVER SHARED THAT- ONE OF MY
COUSINS WAS SHOT IN THE HEAD.
AND PASS BECAUSE SHE WAS
INVOLVED IN GANGS AND DRUGS- SO
I HAVE THOSE EXPERIENCES EVEN
WHEN I SIT UP HERE AS AN
ASSEMBLY MEMBER- THE-
CONVERSATIONS. THAT THAT-
BASICALLY ARE. BACK AND FORTH
WITH THEM ARE JUST THE-
COMMUNITY UP IN SACRAMENTO ARE
VERY DIFFERENT THAN THE ONES
THAT ARE HAPPENING ON THE
GROUND AND I TELL YOU THAT
BECAUSE I. WE HAVE TO FIGURE
OUT YES WE SHOULD HAVE A
MINIMUM. REQUIREMENT I ALSO DID
I MENTION THAT I WORKED FOR THE
CITY OF VERNON AND HUMAN
RESOURCES AND PART OF MY JOB
WAS TO DO THE TESTING FOR
POLICE OFFICERS AND FOR
PROMOTIONS. SO I'VE HAD THOSE
EXPERIENCES AND I THINK WE CAN
COME UP WITH SOMETHING THAT CAN
CAN A SUPPORT THOUGH THE
COMMUNITIES OF COLOR THAT WANT
TO- BECOME POLICE OFFICERS.
BECAUSE WE NEED PEOPLE THAT
LOOK LIKE US ON THE GROUND
TRYING TO HELP THE COMMUNITY-
LEFT WE HAVE TO LIFT THEIR
COMMUNITIES AND UNLESS WE
UNLESS WE LIFT THEM UP WE
CANNOT. HAVE IN A CONVERSATION-
AN HONEST CONVERSATION ABOUT
HOW THOSE COMMUNITIES CAN TEACH
US WHAT THEY NEED OR WHAT WE
NEED ON THE GROUND- I KNOW THAT
THIS IS NOT THE END OF THE
CONVERSATION- BUT I ALSO WANTED
TO MENTION THAT AS A TEACHER-
WE ARE. ORIGINALLY GIVEN THE
PRINT WHAT WE CALL A
PRELIMINARY CREDENTIAL THE
PRELIMINARY CREDENTIAL IS IF
YOU MAKE THE BUT YOU MEET THE
BASIC REQUIREMENTS- IT'S YOU WE
HAVE A PRELIMINARY COULD ENTER
FOR FIVE YEARS AND WITHIN THOSE
FIVE YEARS OR OTHER
REQUIREMENTS THAT HAVE TO BE
FULFILLED IN ORDER. FOR US TO
GET A CLICK WHAT WE CALL A
CLEAR CUT THEIR CREDENTIAL
BASICALLY THAT'S- ALL WE HAVE
TO DO IS RENEW IT FOR THE REST
OF OUR LIVES AND CONNECT AND
CAN KEEP IT. AND THOSE
REQUIREMENTS ARE ADDITIONAL
EDUCATION AND SO IF WE CAN HAVE
A SYSTEM- THAT THAT- CAN
REFLECT WHAT THE TEACHING
COMMUNITY DOES I THINK WE CAN.
YOU KNOW ENCOURAGE POLICE
OFFICERS AND PEOPLE IN OUT
SAFETY POSITION TO CONTINUE
THEIR EDUCATION TO BE ABLE TO
HAVE THOSE QUALITIES THAT THAT-
YOU KNOW WE WERE DISCUSSING.
BUT WE ALSO NEED IN MID TO MAKE
IT- FAIR FOR PUT COMMUNITIES OF
COLOR TO BE ABLE TO APPLY TO BE
POLICE OFFICERS BECAUSE IF WE
DON'T HAVE COMMUNITY. OUR OF
OUR POLICE OFFICERS THAT LOOK
LIKE THE COMMUNITY THERE WERE
ALWAYS SPEAKING DIFFERENT
LANGUAGES AND I. AM AFRAID THAT
IF WE PUT MORE REQUIREMENTS
INSTEAD OF FACILITATING- YOU
KNOW ARE YOU ARE HELPING THOSE
FOLKS THAT WANT TO BECOME
POLICE OFFICERS. GET THROUGH
SOME OF THE REQUIREMENTS WE'RE
NOT GOING TO HAVE OUR
COMMUNITIES ARE REPRESENTED BY
FOUGHT BY FOLKS THAT LOOK LIKE
THEMSELVES. THANK YOU THANK YOU
VERY MUCH MISS GONZALEZ. THANK
YOU I HAVE A QUESTION I DON'T I
DON'T KNOW- IF ANY OF THE
PANELS COULD ANSWER IT FIRST
QUESTION IS. IS THE USE OF
FORCE ISSUES THAT WERE SEEN IS
IT PRIMARILY WITH NEW OFFICERS
OR OFFICERS WHO HAVE- BEEN ON
THE FORCE FOR AWHILE. BECAUSE A
LOT OF OUR DISCUSSION OF
COURSES- ABOUT TRAINING OF
INCOMING OFFICERS BUT IF WE
HAVE A CULTURAL PROBLEM OR
PROBLEM THAT EXISTED ACT. IT
DOESN'T SEEM LIKE THIS WOULD
NECESSARILY FIX THAT. THE
MYSTERY. MYSTERY A OUR CHIEF OF
CHIEF. YOU HAN I DON'T HAVE
THAT INFORMATION WITH US SOME
YOU KNOW ON ON THE TENURE OF
THESE OFFICERS OFFICERS
INVOLVED IN USE OF FORCE THAT
THAT'S SOMETHING I'D HAVE TO
LOOK INTO. THANK THE ACT EXACT
STATS IN FRONT OF ME BUT IT'S
PRETTY MUCH ACROSS THE BOARD
THERE'S VETERAN OFFICERS
YOUNGER OFFICERS SO- IT IT RUNS
THE GAMUT. IF I MAY I THINK I
WILL I WILL CONCORD THEY
STUDIES SEEM TO GET AND OF
COURSE THERE MAY BE VARIATIONS
FROM DEPARTMENT TO DEPARTMENT
CHIEF ARNOLDI FIVE TO YOU AND
IF YES WHAT. ARE THE FOSTER ARE
FIVE TO SEVEN YEARS- OFF OFFICE
THAT'S GONNA COME BACK WE'LL
KEEP. OUR HEADS TO BE MUCH MORE
CHALLENGING ON HIGHER RATES ARE
YOU STUDENTS ON OFTENTIMES IF
YOU'RE TRACKING AGAIN ACCORDING
TO THE STUDIES DONE A QUITE A
BIT OF TIME. YOU ARE MORE
LIKELY TO KEEP THEIR DOORS ONCE
IF NOT PROPERLY TAUGHT THAT
PRODUCTIVITY IS TAKING BACK
BECOME A PROBLEM. HOUSE NONTON
GET ON THE LINE. I IF I MAY
ALSO ON THE LIST MIGHT BE TO
KITCHEN AGAIN WHICH WE KNOW IS
THAT CONTENT INDICATOR. OVER
THE DISCUSSIONS CARE INCLUDE.
IF YOU GET PROGRAMS WHAT IT
MEANS WE TALK ABOUT THAT BILL
IS WALKING PRESENCE YOU
WRESTLING PROFIT. CURRENTLY
ACROSS MY ONE THOUGHT UP WITH
OFFICER THAT'S NOT THE COUNTRY
HOW ABOUT YOU KNOW YOU KNOW
BACHELOR'S DEGREE. BUT IT'S NOT
ON TO HAVE WHAT IS POLICE ASKS
WITH MASTER FROM SOUND LOG
PLEASE ARE IN FIRST I KNOW I'M
TO AS AN INDICATOR I THE BLACK
AS WELL IN TERMS OF CREATING A
CEASE OF EDUCATION TO WITH IT
WITHOUT WITH TRYING TO BRING IN.
I'M ALSO GRATEFUL TO FACT THAT
YOU HAVE PEOPLE LIKE CHIEF
HANDLE. NOT HAND ABOUT DEGREE
AND- MY NAME IN THE FORCE OUT
OF STOCK ON THE I'VE COME EVEN
HIGHER LEVELS YEP RIGHT CONCEPT.
BUT WE CAN LOSE OUR ARE NOT
ALLOWED REFORM TO NEXT THAT WE
TO THAT IS SPECIAL IF IT TIME
WHEN THEY IS DIFFICULT FOR
QUICKLY OFTEN TEN TO BE THOSE
FROM THE AMOUNT OF THE PROPER
OR WHAT'S TO BRING AND VERY
MUCH. INTO THE SYSTEM PAIN THEM
GIVING THEM A JOB I'M PAYING
THEM FOR TRAINING AND
CONTINUING THAT TRAINING
THROUGH- SO THAT YOU ALMOST ARE
ARE. BEGIN TO BE CREDENTIALED-
IF YOU WELL AS A POLICE OFFICER
OUR PEACE OFFICER- IN THE SAME
THOUGHT ON THE PEOPLE WHO ARE
DROPPING OUT OF OR OR BEING
KICKED OUT OF THE ACADEMY. IF
THEY COULD STILL GET INTO THE
SYSTEM CONTINUE TO DO THE
TRAINING- BEING PAID AS AN
EMPLOYEE- DOING THE TYPE OF
WORK WITHIN THE SYSTEM THAT
THEY ARE QUALIFIED TO DO AS
THEIR SKILLS INCREASE IN OTHER
AREAS. ARE THERE ANY KIND OF
PROGRAMS LIKE THAT READ I DON'T
THINK WE MEDIATION BUT ALMOST-
ENSURING THAT THAT WE GET
PEOPLE INTO THE SYSTEM THAT WE
WANT WE WANT A PEACE A POLICE
FORCE IT LOOKS LIKE OUR
COMMUNITY THAT REFLECTS OUR
COMMUNITY THAT COMES FROM OUR
COMMUNITY. GETTING THOSE WHO
ARE ARE ARE QUALIFIED TO BEGIN
WITH INTO THE SYSTEM I'M GIVING
THEM A JOB I MEAN I AGREE THAT
IF YOU MAKE PEOPLE WAIT FOR
MONTHS AND MONTHS- TO CLEAR.
SOMETHING OR OR ANOTHER OR YOU
PUT THEM THROUGH THE ACADEMY
AND THEN THEY GET KICKED OUT OF
ME NOT THAT THERE GOES ALL YOUR
RECRUITMENT EFFORTS BUT- I'M
GETTING THEM IN AND THEN DOING
SOME OF THE TRAINING AND SOME
OF THE- EXPERTISE. AFTER THE
FACT HAS THERE BEEN ANY KIND OF
PROGRAM LIKE THAT HAS CANNOT
WORK. ASSEMBLY MEMBER GOT
GONZALEZ I. ACTUALLY REALLY
LIKE THE WAY YOU THINK WITH
WHAT YOU JUST SAID- AND LET ME
EXPLAIN A LITTLE BIT HOW WE DO
THAT HERE SO. ONE OF THE
BENEFITS OF CREATING THESE
ENTRY LEVEL JOBS IS OUT ONE IF
YOU APPLY STRAIGHT AS A POLICE
OFFICER TO SAY. WE ALL MAKE
MISTAKES IN OUR YOUTH SO SAY
YOU HAVE SOME MISTAKES IN YOUR
BACKGROUND THAT NORMALLY WE
WOULDN'T PUT YOU IN THE
ACADEMY. BUT YOU HAVE A LOT OF
OTHER THINGS THAT MAKE YOU
THINK YOU COULD VERY WELL BEAN
AMAZING OFFICER. WILL HIRE YOU
AS A COMMUNITY SERVICE OFFICER.
WHICH IS A FULL TIME POSITION
SO. WE CAN SEE YOUR PERFORMANCE
AND SEE IF WHAT I BELIEVE IN
YOU IT'S ACTUALLY TRUE OVER SAY
SIX MONTHS TO A YEAR. AND
SHOULD YOU PERFORM REALLY WELL
AND- AND SHOW THAT THOSE
MISTAKES ARE IN THE PAST THEN
WE PUT YOU IN THAT CATEGORY.
SAME WITH THE PEOPLE THAT- YOU
TALK ABOUT THAT WE KICKED OUT
ACADEMY ONE WE'VE SOLVED A LOT
OF THAT WITH THE PRE ACADEMY
AND OTHER TRAINING BEFORE YOU
EVER GET THE ACADEMY. BUT IF
YOU ARE STILL SOMEBODY THAT WE
BELIEVE HAS A LOT OF POTENTIAL
WE PUT YOU BACK IN THE ACADEMY.
OR THERE'S SOME PEOPLE THAT GO
THROUGH THE WHOLE COUNTY THEY
PASS ALL THE TRAINING. BUT FOR
WHATEVER REASON WE DON'T THINK
THEY'RE QUITE READY TO BE A
POLICE OFFICER. SO WHEN THEY
GRADUATE WE MAKE THEM A
COMMUNITY SERVICE OFFICER SO
THEY GET MORE EXPERIENCE. AND
THEN WHEN THEY GET TO THE POINT
WHERE WE THINK THEY CAN HANDLE
THE RIGORS OF BEING A POLICE
OFFICER THEN WE UPGRADE THEM TO
PLACE ALSO. YES THERE'S MANY
WAYS WE DO THAT WHETHER THERE'S
SOMEBODY THAT HAS SOME ISSUES.
THAT WE THINK HAVE POTENTIAL OR
SOMEBODY THAT IS NOT PASSED THE
TEST. WE CAN PUT THEM BACK. IN
THE KASHMIR GIVE THEM ANOTHER
JOB. IF I COULD JUST ADD ON. IS
ONE PROGRAM. THAT DEALS. WITH I
THINK THE- PART OF QUESTION.
WHICH IS- AN LAPD IT'S KNOWN AS
THE POLICE OFFICER PREPARATION
PROGRAM. WHICH IS SPECIFICALLY
DESIGNED TO DEAL WITH THE GAP
BETWEEN HIGH SCHOOL AND THE AGE
OF- THE MINIMUM AGE TO COME A
POLICE OFFICER OR WHAT IT IS A
PROGRAM- IN CONJECTURE THE
COMMUNITY COLLEGE WHERE THEY
ACTUALLY OBTAIN A- AN
ASSOCIATE'S DEGREE. AND THEY
ALSO LEARN ABOUT POLICING AND
IT'S A IT'S A WAY TO BRIDGE
THAT GAP. PROVIDED AN
OPPORTUNITY FOR EDUCATION IT'S
LARGELY- WITH STUDENTS WHO WERE
FROM MINORITY COMMUNITIES AND
IT'S A WAY TO GET THEM INTO
POLICING WHETHER IT'S WITH THE
ONLY. OTHER AGENCIES AND I
THINK THAT IS ULTIMATELY THE
KEY TO MAKE SURE IT DOESN'T
HAVE A DISPARATE IMPACT IN ANY
REQUIREMENTS THAT ARE IMPOSED
IS THAT PROVIDE THE
OPPORTUNITIES FOR PEOPLE. AND
HAVE A PATHWAY TO AN EDUCATION
AND TO LAW ENFORCEMENT. JUST AS
THE MILITARY DOES JUST AS MANY
AGENCIES ON THEIR OWN HAVE
DONE. BUT I DO BELIEVE THAT IT
SHOULD BE SOMETHING ON A
STATEWIDE BASIS BECAUSE RIGHT
NOW WE RELY ON THE FORWARD
LOOKING LEADERSHIP OF CHIEF HAN
AND OTHER DEPARTMENTS. TO TAKE
IT UPON THEMSELVES TO MAKE
THESE REQUIREMENTS AND YOU END
UP WITH A PATCHWORK OF
DIFFERENT DEPARTMENTS WITH
DIFFERENT STANDARDS DIFFERENT
REQUIREMENTS. AND IF WE TRULY
BELIEVE THAT EDUCATION CAN HELP
US IN MAKING BETTER POLICE
OFFICERS ARE ADDRESSING THESE
CHALLENGES. EVERY COMMUNITY
DESERVES THE QUALITY OF THOSEOFFICERS AND SO A STATEWIDE
MANDATE I THINK IT'S SOMETHING
THAT'S IMPORTANT IT NEEDS TO BE
MEASURED IT NEEDS TO BE
COMPREHENSIVE AND IT NEEDS TO
BE DONE. WITH THE FULL
RESOURCES. NECESSARY TO BE
SUCCESSFUL. THANK YOU VERY MUCH-
MISS GONZALEZ WE WANNA GO TO
MR. LACKEY AND ALSO MR BONTA.
AND THEN WE SEEM IS FAISON WHO
ACT- WILL CERTAINLY GET TO YOU
AND HAVE BEEN A BRIEF MOMENT SO
WITH THAT MR LACKEY. YEAH THANK
YOU I'LL BE. VERY VERY QUICK I.
I WANT TO SAY THAT I WAS
THANKFUL TO HAVE A- MET WITH-
CHIEF ONE ABOVE I'M SURE HE
PROBABLY DOESN'T REMEMBER BUT I
MADE AN APPOINTMENT TO MEET HIM
AND HIS OFFICE TO DISCUSS THE
SUDBURY PROBLEM THAT WE'RE
TALKING ABOUT AND TRYING TO
INTEGRATE MORE PEOPLE OF
MINORITY STATUS AND HE
INDICATED TO ME THAT THE
SUCCESS AND FILL RATES A
LEARNING DOMAINS BETWEEN MEN
AND WOMEN AND MINORITY GROUPS
WERE ALL RELATED AT LEAST
PRIMARILY RELATED TO THE FACT
THAT THEY'RE HAVING DRIVING
PROBLEMS AND SHOOTING PROBLEMS
AND SHALL. WE- TOOK THAT
INFORMATION AND WE- HAVE
CRAFTED LEGISLATION AND YOU CAN
LOOK IT UP AND SAY ME THREE
THREE TWO IT WAS IN TWO
THOUSAND NINETEEN. WHICH
REQUIRES OPPOSED TO PUBLISH A
STUDY ON REMEDIATION STANDARDS
BECAUSE I DO BELIEVE THAT THAT
IS A VERY CRITICAL AN EASY FIX
IF WE JUST TO. ALLOW MORE
ATTENTION AND ESPECIALLY THESE
OF FOLKS THAT THE THEIR CULTURE
HAS NOT PREPARED THEM. IN THE
SAME WAY MANY OTHER CANDIDATES
HAVE HAD THAT PREPARATION ON
SHOOTING AND DRIVING AND SO
VERY THANKFUL FOR THAT AND THE
STUDY SHOULD THE COME OUT IN
APRIL OF TWENTY TWENTY ONE. AND
SO THANK YOU FOR YOUR YOUR
FORWARD THE- MAKING AND THE PRE
KATAMON THAT YOU'VE ESTABLISHED.
OF THOSE ISSUES ARE VERY VERY
VERY POWERFUL AND I THINK-
WE'RE ON THE RIGHT TRACK TO-
FINDING SOME REMEDY. THANK YOU
VERY MUCH WE LOOK FORWARD FOR
THAT STUDY TO COME OUT I WE
HAVE MR BONTA THAT WILL GO
RIGHT TO MRS BASED ON WHO IS
PART OF THE PRESENTATIONS
BEFORE MR BONTA YOU'RE UP TO
BAT. THIS IS CERTAINLY BEEN A
VERY ROBUST CONVERSATION SO I
APPRECIATE. YES YEAH THANK YOU-
MISTER SHARON THANK YOU TO OUR
PANELISTS AND ALL MY COLLEAGUES
WHO ARE HERE I PARTICIPATING IN
THIS IMPORTANT DISCUSSION AND I
DEFINITELY AM HEARING- I HAVE A
RIGHTFUL DESIRE TO HAVE WAVED
AT DIVERSE A LAW ENFORCEMENT-
FOCUSED WORKFORCE THAT REFLECTS
THAT I DUTIFUL DIVERSITY
CALIFORNIA AND ALSO TO MAKE
SURE THAT- FOR MEETING THE
STANDARDS THE HIGH STANDARDS
AND TRAINING. WHAT IT HOW DO WE
STRIKE THAT BALANCE HOW DO WE
HOW DO WE WHAT'S THE SINGLE-
MOST IMPACTFUL THINGS A
LEGISLATURE COULD DO OR POLICY
MAKING BODY STATEWIDE IN
CALIFORNIA TO HELP ACHIEVE THAT
RESULT- THAT- EIGHT HIGHLY
TRAINED- POLICE FORCE THAT
MEETS THE HIGH STANDARDS- THAT
LOOKS LIKE CALIFORNIA I THINK
THAT'S THE KIND ABOUT THAT'S
ABOUT TO TRYING TO GET AND-
WHAT INTERVENTIONS ARE
NECESSARY TO GET THAT. GREAT
THANK VERY MUCH- CHIEF POND OR-
ANY OF OUR PRESENTERS YOU WANT
TO TAKE A STAB AT THAT. THE
QUESTION. BUT DIVERSITY I THINK
THE CHIFFONS SACRAMENTO IS
CERTAINLY WORKING TOWARDS THAT
REGARD- CHIEF HAN ARE YOU STILL
WITH US- WHAT WELL BUT OKAY OR
MYSTERY. HE FROM STILL. YEAH IT
IS JUST AS GOOD YOU KNOW WE
REALLY WE UNDERSTAND THAT THE
CHALLENGES THAT. PEOPLE FACE
SUCH AS SHOOTING AND DRIVING IT
FOR THE POST AND THE POST
STANDARDS ARE THE POST MINIMUMS
IN SAN FRANCISCO WE'VE DOUBLED
THE AMOUNT OF TIME AT THE AT
THE THAT'S FINE RANGE WE DOUBLE
THE AMOUNT OF TIME IT EVOLVED.
TO COMPENSATE FOR- THE
GENERATIONS COMING IN THAT HAVE
BEEN HANDLED FIREARMS OR
HABITS- DRIVEN THEIR CARS IS
OFTEN AND- AS LONG AS THEY THEY
SHOULD HAVE THE PRODUCTS COMING
LEASE DEPARTMENT- SO REALLY.
RAISING THIS RAISING THE
TRAINING STANDARDS IS SOMETHING
THAT WE'VE DONE TO HELP
COMPENSATE FOR THOSE
DEFICIENCIES AT THOSE AREAS-
FORTY HOURS REALLY ISN'T ENOUGH
TO REALLY- EIGHT INDOCTRINATE
SOMEBODY ELSE HOW TO HANDLE
FIREARM THE SHOTGUN AND EIGHT
EXTENDED IMPACT WEAPON. THAT'S
REALLY A LOT TO CONGRESS TO
COMPREHEND AND UNDERSTAND IT TO
BE PROFICIENT AT IT ALSO
INCREASING THE TIME TRAINING
THE CONTINENT TRAINING AND ALSO
REALLY THE PRACTICAL EXPERIENCE
IS THE PRACTICE THE CRITICAL
MINDSET COORDINATE RESPONSE
PRACTICAL EXERCISES. THAT
OFFICERS CAN. IT INVOLVED
WORKING IN TEAMS- THOSE LEVELS
OF TRAINING DATA I REALLY THINK
ARE HELPFUL FOR ESPECIALLY FOR
OFFICERS IS BEING ABLE FOR THEM
TO. EXPERIENCE THOSE IN NOW
REAL REALITY BASED TRAINING
IT'S NOT SERIAL UNCLES CALLED
REALITY BASED TRAINING BASED ON
OUR USE OF FORCE INCIDENTS IN
SAN FRANCISCO WE CAN CREATE.
WELL REALLY STRANGE THAT
OFFICERS CAN REVISIT THOSE DEEP
X. EXPERIENCE IT WELL YOU BRIEF
THOSE SITUATIONS AND REALLY
HAVE A CONVERSATION ABOUT HOW
THOSE EXPERIENCES WHEN- AND
REALLY USING FORCE OPTIONS AS A
AND CRITICAL CRITICAL THINKING
AS PART OF OUR TRAINING
CURRICULUM. SO IF WE RAISE THE
LEVEL TRAINING. I THINK THAT BE
HELPFUL. IN THIS GOES TO THE
YEARS OF EXPERIENCE YOU KNOW
TWENTY FIVE YEARS OR A
BACHELOR'S DEGREE- TWENTY FIVE
IS AN AGE BUT YOU HAVE
DIFFERENT LEVELS OF MATURITY
THAT PEOPLE COME INTO THE
POLICE DEPARTMENT AND REALLY
THERE'S A BALANCE OF HOW DO WE
GET THE RIGHT CANDIDATES
DIVERSE CANDIDATES WITHOUT.
IMPACTING CERTAIN COMMUNITIES
WHO DON'T HAVE THE
OPPORTUNITIES TO ATTAIN THEIR
EDUCATION- ALSO SAN FRANCISCO.
IN ONE OF OUR PAST
RELATIONSHIPS WITH THE
COMMUNITY COLLEGE- WAS AT. THE
ACADEMY IS OURS ABOUT TWELVE
HUNDRED DOLLARS CLOSE TO EIGHT
MONTHS. SO USING THOSE. USING
CREEK ON THE CLOTHES CURRICULUM
IN TRANSLATING THOSE INTO
COLLEGE CREDITS. AND HAVING ARE
HAVING OUR POLICE RECRUITS THEN
APPLY THOSE CREDITS TOWARD A
DEGREE. I THINK THAT'S ANOTHER
OPPORTUNITY. THAT THAT HELPS
OUR MEMBERS. AND SEEKING THEIR
EDUCATIONAL. DESIRES AND GOALS
EVEN IF THEY DON'T HAVE THAT
OPPORTUNITY GROWING UP-
COMMITTEE CENTER. AND IT SOUNDS
AS THEY FACED. THANK YOU. LET
ME IF I FIND A- YEAH CHIEF ALL
UP THANK YOU- SORRY CONTACT YOU
OFF. YES YOU IN MY UPPER A-
SOUTHERN ONE OUT YOU'VE GOT GO
AHEAD PLEASE PROCEED AND THEN
WE'LL JUST TALK YEAH I THINK WE
ALL WE HAVE TO ACKNOWLEDGE THAT
THERE'S CERTAIN SEGMENTS THAT
WE'RE REALLY LOOKING FORWARD TO
BECOME. POLICE OFFICERS WITH
THE EXPERIENCE IS THE FIRST
EXPERIENCE WE WANT THEY THEY
HAVE A CERTAIN FEELING ABOUT
LAW ENFORCEMENT DOES NOT LIKE
THE REST OF OUR COMMUNITY I
DON'T TRUST LAW ENFORCEMENT
IT'S- SO WE HAVE TO ADDRESS
THAT ISSUE AND WE HAVE TO DO IT
MUCH YOUNGER AND SO I'VE
MENTIONED MANY OF THE ENTRY
LEVEL PROGRAMS WE DO BUT WE
ALSO HAVE. FOR PROGRAM TO INNER
CITY HIGH SCHOOLS FOR YOUR
PROGRAM FOR THE STUDENTS ARE
WITH US I USED TO RUN ONE AT
GRANT HIGH SCHOOL- AND WE HAVE
WE JUST HAVE TO ADDRESS THAT
ISSUE SO WE WORK WITH THAT-
SEVERAL HUNDRED TEENS THAT ARE
IN A GROUP CALLED IMPACTS ACT.
AND THEY CAME UP WITH A PROGRAM
WHERE WE'VE NOW PUT LIKE THREE
OR FOUR HUNDRED STUDENTS
THROUGH IT WHERE THEY HAVE AN
EXPERIENCE AT THE ACADEMY THAT
LASTS ABOUT HALF A DAY THEN WE
EAT LUNCH TOGETHER AND WE HAVE
THOSE CONVERSATIONS SO WE
REALLY JUST HAVE TO START
ADDRESSING THE ISSUE OF
DISTRESSED. AND NEGATIVE
EXPERIENCES WITH LAW
ENFORCEMENT AND OUR YOUNGER
PEOPLE AND SO WE ARE TRYING TO
DO THAT AND PART OF THAT IS
ASKING YOUNG PEOPLE HOW CAN WE
DO THAT AND SO THAT PROGRAM I
MENTIONED AT THE ACADEMY THAT
CAME FROM THE IMPACTS ACT YOU
HAVE THE ONES THAT CAME UP WITH
THAT IDEA AND NOW WE'VE HAD PUT
SEVERAL HUNDRED PEOPLE. THANK.
YOU VERY MUCH DOCTORS OTHERS.
GANTI FONG MY FAULT. UP I JUST
WANNA SAY CHEAPER REALLY ARE.
WELL BRING THAT YOUNGER DEMO
EXTREME IMPORTANT I THINK WE
HAVE CAREER DAYS AT SCHOOLS AND
ELEMENTARY SCHOOLS I KNOW WHEN
I WAS ASSISTANT CHIEF WE WENT
OUT WITH OUR UNITS TO THE
SCHOOL THAT OUR CANINES AND
OTHER SPECIALIZED UNITS. WITH
ALL DUE RESPECT IT WAS AN
AFRICAN AMERICAN POLICE
OFFICERS SANTA MONICA WHO
RECRUITED ME TO SMPTE I GOT
RECRUITED THE F. B. I. BY TWO
BLACK AGENTS. I'M ENCOURAGED BY
THE PROGRESS WE'VE MADE LA
SHERIFF'S DEPARTMENT NOW 61%
AND SPENT. ON THE OTHER END OF
THE SPECTRUM MY TEACHING A
GRADUATE SCHOOL AT USC. MANY OF
MY STUDENTS AFTER YOU GET THEIR
MASTERS IN PUBLIC POLICY
THEY'RE STUDYING CLASS. WITH
LAUNCH FORTH RASS LOOSELY
LARGELY FROM LAPD WORKING ON
MASTER'S DEGREES. LAST YEAR I
HAD THREE OF MY STUDENTS
GRADUATE IN MAY WITH MASTERS.
AND APPLIED THE LAPD SO IT'S
INTERACTION I THINK THAT'S
REALLY IMPORTANT WITH PEOPLE
THAT LOOK LIKE YOU. TALK TO YOU
COME FROM YOUR COMMUNITIES. AND
YOU SAY WHAT DO YOU LIKE ABOUT
THAT JOB THOSE CONVERSATIONS
RELATIONSHIPS START. AND I
THINK AGAIN TO THE CHIEF'S
COMMENTS WE HAVE TO START MUCH
YOUNGER. AND ENGAGE PEOPLE A
LOT MORE POSITIVELY THANK YOU.
THANK YOU VERY VERY MUCH-
DOCTORS OTHERS WHAT WE WANT TO
MOVE TO MISS FAISON. WE WANNA
CHECK ONE MOMENT GET YOUR
MICROPHONE OPENED. ARE WE CAN
HAVE YOU COME BACK IS THAT
READY. DOES IT WORK YES OKAY WE
GOT YOU THINK SO I WANTED TO
ADDRESS- THERE WAS A QUESTION
THREE QUESTIONS AGO THAT WAS IT
ENDED WITH- ASSEMBLY MEMBER
RUBIO SPEAKING ON HER
EXPERIENCE IN HIGH SCHOOL. AND
THAT'S WHAT I WANTED TO
ADDRESS- SO I HAD THE SAME
EXPERIENCE INHIGH SCHOOL MY
COUNSELOR DISCOURAGED ME HE
WASN'T SO BLATANT TO SAY THAT
HE THOUGHT I WOULD HAVE
CHILDREN AND JUST YOU KNOW
WHATEVER BUT- HE WAS HE DID
DISCOURAGE ME FROM ATTENDING
COLLEGE AND ENCOURAGED ME TO DO
R. O. P. INSTEAD. AND SAID THAT
YOU KNOW HE USED THE FACT THAT
IT BE QUICKER TO GET THROUGH IT
AND YOU KNOW SO FORTH AND SO
ON. AND THAT CREATED- ME HAVING-TO GO TO JUNIOR COLLEGE AND
START FROM THE LOWER LEVEL
CLASSES TO GET THROUGH TO EVEN
START TAKING COLLEGE REQUIRED
CLASSES- SO THAT EXPERIENCE. IS
COMMON IT'S NOT UNCOMMON SO I
WANTED TO SAY ALSO THAT I AGREE
THAT I AM IT'S A LITTLE BIT
BOTHERING TO HEAR ABOUT AN
EDUCATION REQUIREMENT- I'M SAD
THAT MCCARTY LEAVING BECAUSE
I'M GOING TO REFERENCE HIS
STATEMENT AS WELL- BUT- I DON'T
THINK THAT IT SHOULD BE
CENTERED AROUND EDUCATION JUST
BECAUSE IT DOES. DISENFRANCHISE
A LOT OF PEOPLE BUT ALSO IT
DOES ANOTHER THING IT THE FOLKS
THAT ARE NOT IN OUR COMMUNITY
THAT ARE DETACHED ALREADY FROM
OUR COMMUNITIES. PUTTING THEM
INTO A COLLEGE AND GIVING THEM
COLLEGE LEVEL CLASSES IS GOING
TO FURTHER DO YOU CATCH THEM
FROM THE COMMUNITIES THAT DON'T
HAVE THOSE EXPERIENCES. SO
THOSE ARE TWO WAYS I FEEL THAT
IT HARMS BUT EVEN IF WE DO LOOK
AT EDUCATION AND IT DOES BECOME
IMPLEMENTED. WHAT MCCARTY SAID
IS TAKING COLLEGE COURSES ARE
HAVING TO GREASE THAT ARE IN-
STUDIES THAT ARE EITHER SOCIAL
SCIENCE STUDIES OR STUDIES THAT
TEACH PEOPLE TO TEACH YOU HOW
TO LEARN ABOUT THE HUMAN BRAIN
AND- HUMAN- ACTIONS. THAT WOULD
BE ENCOURAGED YOU KNOW MAYBE
WHILE SOMEBODY IS ALSO BEING A
POLICE OFFICER GIVING THEM THE
OPPORTUNITY TO- GIVEN AN
OPPORTUNITY TO ACTUALLY BE
EDUCATED IN PAYING FOR THEIR
EDUCATION- THAT'S THAT'S ALWAYS
A PLUS IT'S AN OPPORTUNITY SO.
THAT'S GOOD BUT I ALSO WANT TO
LOOK AT THE FACT THAT WE'RE
TALKING ABOUT EDUCATION WE'RE
TALKING ABOUT DIVERSITY AND
WITH BOTH OF THOSE THINGS IN
PLACE EVEN IF WE CREATE THE
BEST. YOU KNOW REFORM TO.
REQUIRE THAT THESE THINGS TAKE
PLACE. THERE'S STILL A POLICE
CULTURE. THAT IS PROBLEMATIC
AND SO YOU CAN GET. ALL THE
DIVERSITY THAT YOU WANT INTO A
POLICE DEPARTMENT. AND YOU CAN
EDUCATE PEOPLE AS MUCH AS YOU
WANT TO BUT IT COULD ALSO BUILD
SOMETHING. REALLY BAD IF YOU
HAVE A CULTURE OF POLICING.
THAT HAS ALWAYS BEEN
PROBLEMATIC PROBLEMATIC AND
EGOTISTICAL. SO I JUST WANTED
TO BRING THAT. THANK YOU VERY
MUCH- AND REALLY APPRECIATE
YOUR COMMENTS- EXPRESSLY OF
DIRECTING TOWARDS WHAT MEMBERS
HAVE ALREADY SAID. ALSO WANT
TO. THINK AGAIN A DEPUTY CHIEF-
YOU FOR- REPRESENTS EVER SAN
FRANCISCO AND ALSO- ADDRESSING
SOME OF THE QUESTIONS. I THINK
AGAIN THIS CONVERSATION HAS
ABSOLUTELY BEEN. EYE OPENING
EXPERIENCE AND VERY ROBUST I
APPRECIATE EVERYONE. AND WE ARE
ABSOLUTELY ON TIME SO WE-
GLOBAL MOVE- WE'VE COMPLETE
THIS- THIS PORTION OF OUR
AGENDA AND WE'RE GOING TO MOVE
ON TO THE NEXT PORTION. WE WILL
NOW MOVE INTO THE NEXT PADDLE
ON TRAINING AND LAW ENFORCEMENT
OFFICERS. EACH PANELIST WILL
HAVE AGAIN EIGHT MINUTES. AND
I'LL TRY TO BE- MORE CAREFUL
EIGHT MINUTES AND- SO YOU HAVE
EIGHT JUST AND ALL IN TO DO
SELF- AND PRESERVE- YOUR
PARTICULAR TOPIC- WE WERE JUST
ABSOLUTELY ASK THAT YOU ARE
YOU'RE QUEUED UP IN THE ORDER.
THAT YOU APPEAR ON THE AGENDA.
FIRST UP WILL HAVE A MISTER
ALVAREZ SMASHED OPERAS WILL BE
JOINING US VIRTUALLY- IS
ALVAREZ WHEN YOU ARE ON JUST
FEEL FREE TO- BEGAN- I DON'T
SEE HIM YET- VERY GOOD THANK
YOU VERY MUCH AND WELCOME AND
THE FLOOR IS YOURS. THANK YOU
SIR GOOD AFTERNOON SURE GIPSON
GIPSON AND- SO EVER SINCE AFTER
THE SELECT COMMITTEE MY NAME IS
MANNY ALVAREZ AND I. SERVIZI
EXECUTIVE DIRECTOR OF THE
COMMISSION ON PEACE OFFICER
STANDARDS AND TRAINING. WE ARE
COMMONLY KNOWN. POSTED FORCES
HIRING STANDARDS TRAINING AND
CONDUCTS AUDIENCE OF FORTY ONE
POLICE ACADEMIES AND SIX
HUNDRED ELEVEN LAW ENFORCEMENT
AGENCIES APPROXIMATELY EIGHTY
FOUR THOUSAND THREE HUNDRED
FULL TIME POLICE OFFICERS FOR
PEACE OFFICERS IN EIGHT
THOUSAND ONE HUNDRED PUBLIC
SAFETY DISPATCHERS. FALL UNDER
THE POST PROGRAM IF I MAY
DIGRESS FOR ONE MINUTE. AND I
SOME OF THE TOPICS THAT YOU ALL
TALK ABOUT THAT I THINK THE
INFORMATION MIGHT BE USEFUL WE
WERE FUTURE DELIBERATIONS I
WANTED TO I JUST QUICKLY TOUCH
ON- ON THE RACE AND ETHNICITY
IN THE GENDER OF THE CURRENT
POLICE OFFICERS IN THE STATE OF
CALIFORNIA JUST FOR
INFORMATIONAL PURPOSES- BASED
ON THE LAST DISCUSSION. EIGHTY
SIX IN AROUND THE NET PRESENT.
EIGHTY SIX PER OF. SAUCE FARM.
14% ARE FEMALE. BREAKING IT UP
BY- RAY AND ETHNICITY JERRY
BROWN MISLED BY. ONE THREE
THREE FORTY ARROGANT. SIX ASIAN.
6% BLACK OR AFRICAN AMERICAN.
1% FILIPINO 32% HISPANIC OR
LATINO. IRAN THIS ONE UP OR
DOWN EITHER AT POINT THREE
SEVEN- PACIFIC ISLANDER. JOINT
42% OTHER IN 52% WHITE. I ALSO
WANTED TO AND MAKE A COMMENT
ABOUT THE- THE LAST JUST. ABOUT
A MEDICAL SCREENING AND
PSYCHOLOGICAL SCREENS ARE
REQUIRED FOR ALL HIGHER
STANDARDS LATERAL TRANSFERS
GORDON WE HIRED INDIVIDUALS.
ASSEMBLY MEMBER- LACKEY
MENTIONED EIGHTY THREE THIRTY
TWO WE COLLECTED DATA ON NOW
FOR ONE FULL YEAR ON ALL
ACADEMY GRADUATES NOT TO
DISTURB YOU BALK ON DRIVING
TRAINING FIRM STRAIGHT. WE ALSO
COLLECTED DATA ON. EXAMS
PHYSICAL FITNESS EXAM IN THE
SCENARIO TEST THAT REPORT WILL
COME OUT BY APRIL AND IT'S
BASED ON A HONOR GENDER AND
RACE. NOW I WILL GET BACK TO
ADD TO MY TOPIC WHICH IS. THREE
IN THE INTEREST OF BREVITY AND
KEEP FOCUSED ON WHAT YOU LIKE
TO HEAR ABOUT. MY PREPARED
REMARKS WILL ONLY ADDRESS THE
PEACE OFFICER POSITION- THE
LIVER MY REMARKS IN THREE PARTS
ENTRY LEVEL TRAINING. IN
SERVICE TRAINING FOR EXISTING
PERSONNEL AND POST TRAINING
COURSE CERTIFICATION QUALITY
CONTROL. IN REGARD TO ENTRY
LEVEL TRAINING CALIFORNIA PEACE
OFFICERS WHO ARE IN THE
POSITION OF POLICE OFFICER OR
DEPUTY SHERIFF ARE REQUIRED TO
ATTEND WAS CALL THE REGULAR
BASIC COURSE THREE RBC. PRIOR
TO APPOINTMENT AS A PEACE
OFFICER. MOST LAW ENFORCEMENT
AGENCIES IN CALIFORNIA PROVIDE
SOME FORM OF PREPARATORY
TRAINING PRIOR TO THE RBC. ONE
TWO THREE WEEKS UP WITH ONE
AGENCY- PROVIDING THE FIVE
WEEKS OF TRAINING I BELIEVE
CHIEF HAHN REFERRED TO THAT IS
A PRE ACADEMY AND THAT'S WITH
OTHER AGENCIES ON. THIS
PREPARATORY AFTER INCLUDES
TREATMENT SUCH AS WELL WERE
WRITING ADMINISTRATION RADIO
USAGE AS A WHOLE FITNESS AND
FIREARMS JUST TO NAME A FEW.
COAST DOES NOT TRACK THIS
INFORMATION. THE MINIMUM THE
MINIMUM TRAINING HOURS FOR THE
RBC IS ESTABLISHED BY POST SIX
HUNDRED AND SIXTY FOUR HOURS
DELIVERED IN A SERIES OF FORTY
THREE LEARNING DOMAINS LEARNING
DOMAINS COVER SUCH TOPICS AS
LEADERSHIP. PROFESSIONALISM AND
ETHICS RAIMES AGAINST PERSON'S
VEHICLE AND VEHICLE OPERATIONS.
WE CONDUCT REGULAR UPDATES OF
ALL THE LEARNING DOMAINS AS
NECESSARY WHERE EXAMPLE IN
TWENTY TWENTY WE UPDATED TWELVE
LEARNING DOMAINS ADDED A TOTAL
OF SIXTEEN HOURS OF NEW
TRAINING. TO ENCOMPASS
PRINCIPLE POLICING AN IMPLICIT
BIAS INTO LEARNING DOMAIN THREE
SPOKE POLICING IN THE
COMMUNITY. AND DE ESCALATION
AND LEARNING DOMAIN TWENTY USES
FOR SOME DE ESCALATION.
ADDITIONALLY THE POST
COMMISSION RECENTLY ADDED ONE
STANDARDIZED SCENARIO TEST ON
THE TOPIC OF DE ESCALATE SHE-
IT IS IMPORTANT TO NOTE THAT
CATALANS HAVE THE ABILITY. TO
INCLUDE ADDITIONAL TRAINING
HOURS TO THE STANDARD
CURRICULUM. THE CURRENT AVERAGE
THE BASIC ACADEMY TRAINING IS
APPROXIMATELY EIGHT HUNDRED
FIFTY HOURS WITH ONLY ONE
ACADEMY RUNNING UNDER SEVEN
HUNDRED AND FIFTY HOURS.
SEVERAL ACADEMIES PROPER RATE
AT OVER TWELVE HUNDRED HOURS.
IN ONE ACADEMY OPERATES IS ONE
THOUSAND FOUR HUNDRED FIFTY
TRAINING HOURS. SIX COMPLETION
OF THE BASIC ACADEMY IS NOT THE
COMPLETION OF A THREE LEVEL
DISASTER TRAINING. SUCCESSFUL
COMPLETION OF THE BASICALLY
KADAM MEANS THAT THE INDIVIDUAL
IS SUFFICIENTLY PREPARED TO
ENTER INTO FIELD TRAINING.
WHICH IS THE SECOND CRITICAL
PIECE OF ENTRY LEVEL TRAINING.
ONLY BE SHERRY OFFICERS OR WHAT
SOME CALL OSTER TRAINEES
REQUIRED TO COMPLETE THE POST.
FILTERING PROGRAM WHICH
CONSISTS OF A MINIMUM OF FOUR
HUNDRED HOURS FOR TEN WEEKS OF
ONE ON ONE TRAINING AND
MENTORING. STANDARDIZED
POSTVILLE TRAINING PROGRAMS ALL
PROGRAM ALIGNED ACADEMY
INSTRUCTIONAL METHODS INTO ON
THE JOB TRAINING PROCESS.
DESPITE THE MINIMUM REQUIREMENT
OF FOUR HUNDRED HOURS THE
MAJORITY OF FIELD TRAINING
PROGRAMS IN CALIFORNIA AVERAGE
BETWEEN- INSISTED USUALLY SIX
HUNDRED AND FORTY TO SEVEN
HUNDRED AND TWENTY HOURS OF
FIELD TRAINING FOR SIXTEEN TO
EIGHTEEN WEEKS. YES ENTRY LEVEL
TRAINING FOR ALL PEACE OFFICERS
IS A MINIMUM OF A THOUSAND
SIXTY FOUR HOURS MADE UP OF THE
SIX HUNDRED SIXTY FOUR HOURS
AND THE BASIC ACADEMY IN THE
FOUR HUNDRED HOURS. OF FIELD
TRAINING. UNLESS MOST
DEPARTMENTS EXCEED TOTAL
TRAINING TIME. OF A THOUSAND
FIVE HUNDRED TRAINING HOURS. OF
COMBINED BASICALLY ACADEMY
INSTRUCTION IN FIELD TRAINING
AND SOME DEPARTMENTS-
APPROACHING TWO THOUSAND HOUSE.
IF YOU'RE TRAINING PROGRAM IS
OF CRITICAL IMPORTANCE BECAUSE
IT PROVIDES ONE ON ONE TRAINING.
FIELD TRAINING OFFICER FOR SCO
IS REQUIRED BY POST REGULATION
TO COMPLETELY DALY OBSERVATION
REPORT TO HELP TEACH VIA THE
OFFICER TRAINEE PROGRESS AND BE
ABLE TO MEET THE MINIMUM-
COMPETENCIES. THIS REQUIRES A
TOTAL OF EIGHTEEN CORE
COMPETENCIES BE ADDRESSED
DURING FIELD TRAINING. THINGS
SUCH AS ETHICS TRAFFIC REPORT
WRITING JUST TO NAME A FEW. THE
POST FIELD TRAINING PROGRAMMING
INCLUDES THE STANDARDIZED
TEMPLATE FOR DEPARTMENTS TO
FOLLOW AND IT ALLOWS
DEPARTMENTS TO TAILOR THE
TRAINING TO THEIR LOCAL
COMMUNITY THE LAST PART IS TO
INCORPORATE LOCAL POLICY
DISCUSSIONS INTO THE TRAINING
CURRICULUM. I KNOW THIS
COMMITTEE IS INTERESTED IN THE
TRAINING. ENTRY LEVEL OFFICERS
RECEIVED TO ENSURE INTEGRATION
WITH THE COMMUNITIES THEY
SERVE. I WAY SOME EXAMPLES TO
DEMNSTRATE HOW THIS IS
ACCOMPLISHED IN THE BASED
ECONOMY. LEARNING DOMAIN THREE
POLICING IN THE COMMUNITY
COVERS SIX OVERARCHING TOPICS.
POLICING PARTNERSHIPS PROBLEM
SOLVING PRINCIPLE POLICING
HISTORICAL AND CURRENT EVENTS
AND IMPLICIT BIAS IN LEARNING
DOMAIN THIRTY CRIME SCENE AT
CRIME SCENES AND EVIDENCE AND
FORENSICS. TRAINEES MUST
COMPLETE A LEARNING ACTIVITY ON
HOW A PEACE OFFICER MAY
COLLABORATE WITH THE COMMUNITY
TO SOLVE A CRIME CAN IDENTIFY
UNDERLYING CONDITIONS. ARE THEY
CONTRIBUTE TO CRIME PROBLEMS
LEARNING DOMAIN FORTY TO
CULTURAL DIVERSITY THE TREES
WAS COMPLETELY LEARNING
ACTIVITY. IMPACT RACIAL
PROFILING MAY HAVE HAD ON THEM
AS INDIVIDUALS OR THEIR
COMMUNITY. AS WELL AS LAW
ENFORCEMENT'S OBLIGATION TO
VARIOUS CULTURES WITHIN THE
COMMUNITY AND WHAT LAW
ENFORCEMENT MUST DO TO. CREATE
TRUST WITH THE- IN REGARD TO
THE FIELD TRAINING PROGRAM
COMPETENCY NUMBER SIX IN FIELD
TRAINING PROGRAMS TOTAL
COMMUNITY RELATIONS. TRAINEES
RECEIVE TAILORED LOCAL
DEPARTMENT INSTRUCTION ON
COMMUNITY RELATIONS AND SERVICE
PROFESSIONAL DEMEANOR IN
COMMUNICATIONS CULTURAL
DIVERSITY RACIAL PROFILING.
CRIME PREVENTION AND COMMUNITY
ORIENTED POLICING. FOR EXAMPLE.
IN COMMUNITY ORIENTED POLICING.
ONE SUBSECTION IS WORKING WITH
THE COMMUNITY TO SOLVE PROBLEMS
THREE OFFICER MUST DESCRIBE THE
VANTAGE'S OF WORKING WITH THE
COMMUNITY TO FIND SOLUTIONS TO
PROBLEMS RELATED TO COMMUNITY
SAFETY QUALITY OF LIFE ISSUES.
ANOTHER SUBSECTION PROBLEM
SOLVING. YOU ALSO MUST EXPLAIN
PURPOSE PROBLEM SOLVING MODEL
INCLUDING HOW TO DEVELOP PLANS
WITH CITIZENS TO ADDRESS CRIME
AND DISORDER PROBLEMS. AND WORK
WITH CITIZENS TO IT TO ASSESS
THE RESULTS OF THEIR EFFORTS.
SO HOW DOES THAT WORK. I TOLD
POLICE ACADEMY REQUIRES CADETS
TO ENGAGE IN A MULTI DAY
CULTURAL DIVERSITY PROJECT WITH
LOCAL COMMUNITY MEMBERS
CULMINATED BY REPORT BACK TO
THE ACADEMY CLASS. IT DOESN'T
THE STANISLAUS COUNTY SHERIFF'S
ACADEMY PARTICIPATE WITH
COMMUNITY MEMBERS IN MOCK
MUNICIPAL ADVISORY COUNCIL
MEETINGS. IN TERMS OF FIELD
TRAINING CALIFORNIA STATE PARK
TRAINEE OFFICERS PARTICIPATE
NATIONAL NIGHT OUT. WHEN POLICE
DEPARTMENT REQUIRES IT'S TRADED
ON OFFICERS TO ATTEND CITY
COUNCIL MEETINGS. TORRANCE
POLICE DEPARTMENT REQUIRES EACH
TRAINEE OFFICERS. DO A RIDE
ALONG WITH SCHOOL RESOURCE
OFFICERS INTO A TENT
NEIGHBORHOOD WATCH MEETINGS.
PENAL CODE SECTION EIGHT THIRTY
TWO POINT FOUR B. REQUIRES THAT
THE MAJORITY OF CALIFORNIA
PEACE OFFICERS UNDER THE
PURVIEW OF POST SUCH AS POLICE
OFFICERS AND DEPUTY SHERIFFS
OBTAINED THE POST BASIC
CERTIFICATE. UPON COMPLETION OF
PROBATION BUT NO LATER THAN
TWENTY FOUR MONTHS AFTER A
POINT. NOW I WILL SHIFT TO THE
TRAINING FOR EXISTING PEACE
OFFICE POST REGULATION REQUIRES
PEACE OFFICERS OBTAINED TWENTY
FOUR HOURS CLOSER IF I'D
CONTINUING PROFESSIONAL.
TRAINING OR CPD DURING EVERY
TWO YEAR CYCLE. FOURTEEN OF THE
TWENTY FOUR HOURS MUST BE IN
FOUR AREAS WRESTING CONTROL
FARMS DRIVING IN STRATEGIC
COMMUNICATIONS- THE CPT
REQUIREMENTS ARE ONLY TWENTY
FOUR HOURS EVERY TWO YEARS.
PEACE OFFICERS AND PUBLIC
SAFETY DISPATCHERS AVERAGED
FORTY FOUR POINT THREE HOURS
PER YEAR. CERTIFIED TRAINING
DURING THE LAST TWO YEAR
TRAINING CYCLE WHICH ENDED IN
DECEMBER OF TWENTY EIGHTEEN.
CURRENTLY TRANSSEXUAL THIS. WE
DO ANTICIPATE A REDUCTIONIN
TRAINING OUR TO. IN SERVICE
OFFICERS HAVE ADDITIONAL
TRAINING REQUIREMENTS MANDATED
BY BOTH HOST AND LEGISLATURE.
FOR INSTANCE OPPOSE COMMISSION
REQUIRES ONLY SURGEONS TO
COMPLETE IT AB OUR POST
PROVIDES RECOURSE WHEN YOUR
APPOINTMENT. SIMILARLY NEW
TENANTS AND COMMANDERS MUST
COMPLETE THE ONE HUNDRED TWENTY
OUR POST MANAGEMENT COURSE.
WITHIN ONE YEAR APPOINTMENT
FIELD TRAINING OFFICERS WERE F.
HEROES ARE REQUIRED TO ATTEND
THE FORTY HOUR CLOSED FTO
COURSE AMOS REFRESHER TRAINING
EVERY THREE YEARS BY ATTENDING
THE TWENTY FOUR HOUR POST. F.
T. O. OF THE COURSE- REQUIRES
SCHOOL DISTRICT IN COMMUNITY
CALL. POLICE OFFICERS TO ATTEND
THE FORTY HOUR CLOSE TO CAMPUS
ONE FOR SENATE COURSE WITHIN
TWO YEARS OF APPOINTMENT.
SIMILAR SIMILARLY LOCAL
REQUIRES PEACE OFFICERS TO
PARTICIPATE IN YEARLY PURSUIT
DRIVING TRAINING AS WELL AS
RACIAL PROFILING EVERY FIVE
YEARS THESE ARE JUST A FEW
EXAMPLES OF MANDATED TRAINING
ABOVE AND BEYOND THE STANDARD
C. B. T. REQUIREMENTS. ALL IN
ALL POST CURRENTLY HAS FOUR
THOUSAND THREE HUNDRED POST
CERTIFIED TRAINING COURSES IN
THE COURSE CATALOG. PROXIMALLY
ONE HUNDRED OF THESE COURSES.
ARE POSTED DEVELOP TRAINING
COURSES WITH THE MAJORITY OF
THE TRAINING COURSES DEVELOPED
BY LAW ENFORCEMENT AGENCIES
COMMUNITY COLLEGES AND PRIVATE
PRISONERS. ALL FOUR THOUSAND.
OF THESE COURSES MUST ADHERE TO
POST CERTIFICATION STANDARDS.
AND MUST GO THROUGH AT LEAST
TWO LEVELS OF REVIEW BY CO
STAFF. ADDITIONALLY A NEW
REGULATION RECENTLY APPROVED BY
THE COMMISSION REQUIRES EACH
POST CERTIFIED TRAINING COURSE
TO BE PLACED INTO MODIFICATION
EVERY TWO YEARS. ROSS SAYS
WHICH ESSENTIALLY PUTS THE
COURSE INTO A ENDING INACTIVE
STATUS TRAINING COURSE PUT
PLACED IN THE MODIFICATION
REQUIRES THE PRESENTER TO
CONDUCT A THOROUGH REVIEW AND
TO RESUBMIT THE TRAINING COURSE
FOR RE CERTIFICATION THIS IS
DONE TO ENSURE THE TRAINING
CURRENT. AND CONTEMPORARY ONCE
AGAIN CHUPA STAFF MEMBERS MUST
REVIEW AND RE APPROVE THE
TRAINING COURSE. DURING THE
COURSE CERTIFICATION PROCESS WE
REVIEWED THE TRAINING OUTLINED.
TO MAKE SURE IT'S CONSISTENT
WITH MARK AND HIS CONTEMPORARY.
WE CHECK TO MAKE SURE THE
PROPER STUDENT TO INSTRUCTOR
RATIO WE MAKE SURE SAFETY PLAN
IS IN PLACE FOR CERTAIN
TRAINING AND WE REVIEW AND
SCRUTINIZE THE QUALIFICATIONS
OF EACH INSTRUCTOR. ON THE
BACKEND THE REVIEW SURVEYS AND
QUESTIONNAIRES PREPARED BY
STUDENTS WE EMPLOY A ROBUST
QUALITY ASSESSMENT PROGRAM WERE
QUEUING BE. MISSED OPERAS
ARTICULATE YES- COMMITTEE CAN
SUPPOSE YOU CAN WRAP UP WE
LIVED OVER- CAN YOU DO IT AND
LOCAL AGENT KNOWS OKAY WE YOUR
INFORMATION IS AB ONE
MEDICALLY. NEEDED SO THANK YOU
VERY MUCH. OKAY I WILL DO IT
ONE DAY I PAULA. AS PER THE Q.
EIGHT. ARE WE GONNA TRAIN
COURSES WHICH REYES FOR REQUEST.
OUR CONCERN OR SIMPLY WHEN THEY
BEEN RE. CHIU AP PROGRAM. AT
WILL JUMP AHEAD HERE AS A
RESULT OF THE Q. EIGHT PP
PROGRAM TWENTY TWENTY. WE
PROTECT PREPARED VARIOUS
WRITTEN FINDINGS AND
RECOMMENDATIONS TO SEVERAL
AGENCIES AND PRESENTERS. WE
DECERTIFIED AND REMOVE ONE
PRESENTER FROM DOING FURTHER
CLOSER TO FIND TRAINING. THE
MAJORITY OF IN SERVICE TRAINING
IS CLASSROOM BASED HOWEVER
EXISTING REGULATION PERMITS IN
SERVICE TRAINING TO BE
CONDUCTED ONLINE. WITH PRIOR
APPROVAL FRM POST MANY
PRISONERS HAVE TAKEN ADVANTAGE
OF CONDUCTING ONLINE TRAINING
DURING OPEN. ADDITIONALLY IT
HAS ITS OWN LEARNING MANAGEMENT
SYSTEM OR WHAT WE CALL THE
LEARNING PORTAL. WHICH HOUSES
VARIOUS POST DEVELOP SELF PACED
IN VIDEO BASED TRAINING COURSES.
TWENTY TWENTY ALONE WE RELEASED
ON LEARNING PORTAL NEW POST
DEVELOP TRAINING COURSES ON DE
ESCALATION. EIGHT CRIMES GUN
VIOLENCE RESTRAINING ORDERS
BIAS AND RACIAL PROFILING
WELLNESS HUMAN TRAFFICKING.
MENTAL HEALTH WERE NOT
RESPONDING TO INDIVIDUALS IN
CRISIS AN INITIAL RESPONSE TO
NATURAL DISASTERS. THE LAST CBT
TRAINING CYCLE. AT 13% OF POST
CERTIFIED TRAINING WAS
COMPLETED ARMY POST LEARN. MR
CHAIRMAN MEMBERS OF. I THANK
YOU FOR THE OPPORTUNITY TO
TESTIFY BEFORE YOUR COMMITTEE
THE POSITIVE THINGS WE ARE
DOING IN CALIFORNIA AND I'M
HAPPY TO TAKE YOUR QUESTIONS
AND EVERY. THANK YOU VERY MUCH
MR RAZOR PRECIADO YOU'RE VERY
THOROUGH- INFORMATIONAL ON
POST- AND REALLY APPRECIATE
YOUR BEING HERE THERE WERE I'M
SURE THEY'LL BE SOME QUESTIONS
I'M WITH YOU WE ASK IF YOU
COULD JUST PLEASE- JUST STAY ON
STAY ON WILK- CERTAINLY COULD
GO DO YOU. NEXT WE HAVE A MRS
LAND WOULD YOU PLEASE COME
FORWARD AND- HAVE YOU SEE SEAT
AT THE TABLE SO YOU CAN PRESENT
TO ONE OF OUR PRESENTERS WE
HAVE. EIGHT MINUTES- AND HOPE
THAT YOU WITHIN EIGHT MINUTES
YOU COULD JUST PLEASE INTRODUCE
YOURSELF AND JUST MOVE ON TO
YOUR PRESENTATION THANK YOU
VERY MUCH AS GOOD TO SEE YOU
AGAIN AND- THANK YOU FOR TAKING
TIME OUT OF YOUR BUSY SCHEDULE
TO JOINING US AND BEING PART OF
THIS CONVERSATION IS ABSOLUTELY
IMPORTANT SO. WITH THAT BEING
SAID- GREAT. PLEASE PROCEED
GOOD AFTERNOON MISTER CHAIR
GOOD AFTERNOON- THANK YOU FOR.
THANK YOU THANK YOU FOR HAVING
ME OF FIRST AND FOREMOST I
WOULD LIKE TO ACKNOWLEDGE THAT.
SITTING IN THE GALLEY WE HAVE
THE FAMILY OF AUGUSTINE MORALIS
WHO WAS SHOT AND KILLED BY
SACRAMENTO POLICE DEPARTMENT ON
NOVEMBER FOURTEENTH HE IS ONE
OF TWO KILLINGS THAT OCCURRED
WITHIN A TEN DAY PERIOD OF
TIME- I WOULD ALSO LIKE TO
ACKNOWLEDGE MY GOOD FRIEND
CHIEF DANIEL HAHN- SO THERE'S
BEEN A LOT OF CONVERSATION.
THAT I'VE HEARD AND I'VE BEEN
TAKING NOTES- AND THERE'S A FEW
THINGS THAT I WOULD LIKE TO
ADDRESS I WOULD LIKE TO THANK
YOU. FOR YOUR COMMENTS AND YOUR
UNDERSTANDING BEING NOT ONLY A
MINORITY BUT ALSO A WOMAN- SO.
ONE OF THE THINGS A HERE IS
WHAT WE'RE TALKING ABOUT
TRAINING- ANDTHERE ARE FEW
THINGS THAT OFTENTIMES IN THE
AFRICAN AMERICAN COMMUNITY WE
TALK ABOUT AROUND TRAINING- DE
ESCALATION IS ONE OF THOSE
THINGS- FROM THE AFRICAN
AMERICAN COMMUNITY PERSPECTIVE
WE OFTENTIMES DO NOT THINK THAT
TRAINING IS NECESSARILY AN
ISSUE NOW TO SPEAK FOR THE
WHOLE COMMUNITY BUT I SPEAK
JUST FOR A SELECT FEW MEMBERS
OF THE COMMUNITY AND WHY I SAY
THAT IS BECASE WHEN WE TALK
ABOUT VERY SPECIFICALLY DE
ESCALATION TACTICS. OR TRAINING
WE NOTICED THAT WHEN IT COMES
TO KILLINGS OR EXCESSIVE USE OF
FORCE IN OUR COMMUNITIES THAT
IT IS ALWAYS THE CONVERSATION
COMES ABOUT TRAINING HOWEVER
WHEN IS A NON WHITE SHOOTER
THAT HAS GONE INTO A SCHOOL OR
INTO A CHURCH AND WE KNOW THAT
HE HAS KILLED NUMEROUS PEOPLE
WE OFTENTIMES CAN'T SEE HIM
BEING PEACEFULLY ARRESTED HE
HAS NOT BEEN TASTY HAS NOT BEEN
BETTER BEERS HE MAY EVEN BE
TAKEN FOR ONE OF HIS FAVORITE
MEALS AND SO THEREFORE WE DO
NOT BELIEVE THAT TRAINING
AROUND THE ESCALATION IS AN
ISSUE BECAUSE CLEARLY. LAW
ENFORCEMENT KNOWS HOW TO DE
ESCALATE WHEN THEY DEEM IT TO
BE APPROPRIATE- ALSO THERE IS
THE ISSUE OF CENTER MASS
SHOOTING. OF THE CENTER- WE ARE
OFTENTIMES SEEING THESE TYPES
OF KILLINGS WHERE. WHETHER
ARMED OR UNARMED PEOPLE OF
COLOR ARE BEING SHOT AT CENTER
MASS. AND THEIR BODIES ARE
BEING RIDDLED WITH NUMEROUS
BULLETS OFTENTIMES LEADING INTO
THEIR DEATH- WE WOULD LIKE TO
SEE DIFFERENT TRAINING AROUND
THAT- WHY IS IT THAT WE
CONTINUE TO SEE VIRAL VIDEOS
WHERE WE HAVE A WHITE
ASSAILANTS- OR SUSPECT WHO IS
ABLE TO. WRESTLE WITH OFFICERS
TAKE THEIR WEAPONS TO BE ABLE
TO JUMP INTO THEIR VEHICLES AND
TAKE ALL OF THEM YET. WE GET
BACK TO THE ISSUE OF AFRICAN
AMERICAN AND OR LATINOS BEING
KILLED- THERE WAS A QUESTION
THAT WAS POSED TO ME HOW THIS
TRAINING ENSURE AN OFFICER IS
INTEGRATED INTO THE COMMUNITY-
I BELIEVE THAT A LOT OF AND I'M
GOING TO DEVIATE HERE FOR A
MOMENT A LOT OF MY EXPERIENCE
HAS COME FROM MY- RELATIONSHIP
WITH CHIEF DANIEL HAHN. AND I
BELIEVE IT IS IMPORTANT THAT
ASKED COMMUNITY MEMBERS THAT WE
BE ABLE TO DEVELOP THOSE TYPES
OF RELATIONSHIPS IT IS BECAUSE
OF THAT THAT I HAVE BEEN ABLE
TO GO OUT TO THE ACADEMY THAT I
HAVE BEEN ABLE TO GO THROUGH
THE USE OF FORCE SIMULATOR
BECAUSE WHEN WE HEAR THE PUSH
BACK FROM LAW ENFORCEMENT WILL
YOU DON'T KNOW WHAT WE GO%
THROUGH YOU DON'T KNOW WHAT WE
HAVE TO DO. IN SPLIT SECONDS
WELL IN ORDER FOR ME TO BE ABLE
TO ENGAGE IN THAT CONVERSATION
NOT JUST WITH LAW ENFORCEMENT
BUT ALSO WITH MY COMMUNITY TO
GET THEM TO HAVE A DIFFERENT
UNDERSTANDING ON BOTH AISLES OF
THE SPECTRUM- I WENT OUT TO THE
ACADEMY. I'VE BEEN OUT OF THE
ACADEMY ON SEVERAL OCCASIONS
WE'VE BEEN OUT OF THE ACADEMY
WITH YOU- AND CONSULTING WITH
YOU. HOW THEY PERCEIVE LAW
ENFORCEMENT WHAT THEY WOULD
LIKE TO SEE HAPPEN DIFFERENTLY-
I WALKING A UNIQUE SPACE
BETWEEN. THE CHIEF OF POLICE-
FAMILIES WHO HAVE BEEN DIRECTLY
IMPACTED BY EXCESSIVE AND OR
DEADLY USE OF FORCE. AND THEN
THERE IS ALSO ANOTHER
DEMOGRAPHIC- THAT WE OFTENTIMES
DON'T TALK ABOUT WHEN WE TALK
ABOUT INTERACTIONS WITH LAW
ENFORCEMENT. AND THAT THOSE ARE
THE FAMILIES OF CRIME VICTIMS-
WE OFTENTIMES HEAR THERE IS
WHAT I NOW CALL AFFECTIONATELY
CALL HASHTAG ACTIVISM. AND THAT
IS NOT TO DEMEAN ANY OF WHAT IS
BEING SAID. BUT I WOULD LIKE TO
KIND OF. EXPAND ON THAT A
LITTLE BIT AND THAT IS THIS
CONCEPT THAT HAS COME OUT OF.
THE KILLING OF GEORGE FOLLOWED
WHERE WE HEAR DEFINED THE
POLICE. OKAY OFTENTIMES WHEN
YOU HEAR PEOPLE SPEAK OF THIS
THEY ARE TALKING ABOUT RE
ALLOCATING CERTAIN PORTIONS OF
LAW ENFORCEMENT'S BUDGET. IN
ORDER TO RE ENFRANCHISE THE
COMMUNITY. BUT WHAT DOES THAT
REALLY LOOK LIKE BECAUSE AGAIN
THERE'S TWO DIFFERENT SPECTRUMS
HERE WE HAVE. COMMUNITY
MEMBERS. WHO HAVE BEEN VICTIMS
OF CRIME WHO ACTUALLY LOOKED TO
LAW ENFORCEMENT. IN ORDER TO BE
ABLE TO HELP THEM SOLVE THE
CRIME OR GET JUSTICE FOR THAT
WHICH HAS BEEN PERPETRATED
AGAINST THEM. IF WE DEFINE LAW
ENFORCEMENT THERE WE ARE
REMOVING THE NECESSITY OF THE
RESOURCES THAT THESE FAMILIES
NEED IN ORDER TO GET THE
JUSTICE THAT THEY'RE SEEKING-
BUT- UP ON THE ISSUE OF THE
FUNDING. I BELIEVE THAT IT'S
MORE THAN JUST A FUNDING LAW
ENFORCEMENT BECAUSE THE REALITY
OF IT IS. DEFINING LAW
ENFORCEMENT IS NOT GOING TO
MAKE THE KILLINGS STOP.
LEGISLATION IS NOT GOING TO
MAKE THE KILLINGS STOP YOU
CANNOT LEGISLATE AWAY SYSTEMIC
RACISM. NOR CAN YOU LEGISLATE
AWAY HATRED- I ABSOLUTELY LOVE
HEARING ABOUT MR APPEALS.
PERCEPTION OF WHAT LAW
ENFORCEMENT SHOULD LOOK LIKE
BUT WE ALSO HAVE TO BE
REALISTIC AND THAT HERE IN THE
UNITED STATES OF AMERICA-
POLICE CAME OUT OF. SLAVE
PATROLS WHICH IF WE LOOK AT THE
VIOLENCE THAT HAS BEEN
PERPETRATED AGAINST AFRICAN
AMERICANS AND LATINOS BUT VERY
SPECIFICALLY AFRICAN AMERICANS
IN THIS COUNTRY- IT HAS BEEN
ROUTED IN VIOLENCE. UP YOU CAN
GOOGLE LYNCHINGS RIGHT NOW AND
YOU WILL SEE BLACK MEN WOMEN
AND CHILDREN HANGING FROM TREES
BEING BURNED TO THEIR BODIES
BEING MUTILATED OFTENTIMES. YOU
KNOW SKIN EARS. FINGERS BEING
TAKEN AS SOUVENIRS SURROUNDED
BY A GROUP OF OFTENTIMES WHITE
MEN WOMEN CHILDREN SOMETIMES
WITH BABIES IN THEIR ARMS AND
SO WE HAVE TO BE COGNITIVE
AWARE OF THE FACT THAT THIS IS
NOT NECESSARILY AN ISSUE OF
TRAINING. THIS IS NOT
NECESSARILY AN ISSUE OF HOW DO
WE REFORM A SYSTEM THAT WAS
NEVER DESIGNED TO PROTECT AND
OR SERVE. MEMBERS OF THE
COMMUNITY WHO LOOK LIKE ME-
THIS IS AN ISSUE OF DEEP
SYSTEMIC RACISM- AS FAR AS SOME
OF THE EXPERIENCES THAT I HAVE
PERSONALLY BEEN ABLE TO HAVE
AND AGAIN THAT HAS BEEN-
THROUGH DANIEL HìNH. THAT I
HAVE BEEN ABLE TO ATTEND THE
ACADEMY- I HAVE GONE THROUGH
TRANSFORMATIONAL POLICING MODEL
COURSE- WE HAVE SPOKEN AT THE
BLACK CAUCUS ANNUAL LEGISLATIVE
CONFERENCE I'VE BEEN THROUGH
THE USE OF FORCE SIMULATOR- WE
HAVE GONE ON A WEEKLY WALKS
UNTIL THE PANDEMIC IT WHERE HE
TAKES- CADETS FROM THE ACADEMY.
AND HE TAKES THEM ON A
COMMUNITY WALK EVERY FRIDAY
THROUGH ALL PARK WHERE WE HAVE
DOGS BARKING WE HAVE PEOPLE
SITTING ON THEIR PORCHES
CONSUMING MARIJUANA WE HAVE
LOUD MUSIC AND THE MAJORITY OF
THESE OFFICERS IN TRAINING ARE
WHITE AND THEY ARE IN A
PREDOMINATELY BLACK
ENVIRONMENT- I COMMEND HIM. FOR
DOING THAT BECAUSE OFTEN TIMES
WHAT IS THE ISSUE WE DO NOT
HAVE LAW ENFORCEMENT OFFICERS
IN OUR COMMUNITY WHO LOOK LIKE
US. AROUND THE ISSUE OF AND
SOMETHING THAT'S REALLY BEEN.
PRESSING ON ME AS I SIT AND I
LISTEN AROUND THE EDUCATIONAL
COMPONENTS- WE HEAR ABOUT THE
DIFFERENCES BETWEEN A
BACHELOR'S DEGREE OR AN
ASSOCIATE'S DEGREE BUT YET HAVE
I HEARD HOW DO WE ACTUALLY.
RAISE THE EDUCATIONAL STANDARDS
AND GIVE TO THE COMMUNITIES
INSTEAD OF LOWERING OR CHANGING
THE REQUIREMENTS HOW DO WE RE
ENFRANCHISE THE COMMUNITIES OF
PEOPLE WHO LOOK LIKE ME TO BE
ABLE TO GIVE THEM MORE THAN A
SUB PAR OR SUB STANDARD
EDUCATIONAL SYSTEM SO THAT THEY
CAN THEN BEGAN TO QUALIFY FOR
THESE TYPES OF. JOBS THAT IS
WHAT IS MOST INTERESTING TO ME
AND SO AS WE TALK ABOUT THE
FUNDING IT'S NOT JUST THE
FUNDING LAW ENFORCEMENT IT'S
ABOUT THE FUNDING OF A RIGHTY
OF DIFFERENT SYSTEMS TO RE
ENFRANCHISE THE COMMUNITIES. SO
THAT WE DO NOT CONTINUE TO HAVE
CHILDREN OR PEOPLE IN OUR
COMMUNITIES WHO ARE
EXPERIENCING ADVERSE CHILDHOOD
EXPERIENCES THAT CONTINUE TO
LEAD THEM TO ACCEPTING OR
CHOOSING CRIMINAL BEHAVIOR AS
COPING MECHANISMS. WE HAVE
CONTINUED TO BE CRIMINALIZED ND
VALUE WISE IN THIS COUNTRY AS
LONG AS WE HAVE STOOD FOOT ON
IT AND SO THOUGH I RESPECT THE
CONVERSATION AROUND THE
NECESSITY FOR REFORM AGAIN I
POSE THE QUESTION HOW DO YOU
REFORM A SYSTEM THAT WAS NEVER
DESIGNED TO PROTECT AND OR
SERVE. ANYONE WHO LOOKS LIKE ME
OR LIKE YOU. IN REGARDS TO
EXCESSIVE OR DEADLY USE OF
FORCE I PERSONALLY BELIEVE THAT
THAT IS AGAIN AN EXTENSION OF
THE OF AMERICAN FOUNDATIONAL
PRACTICES. HEY WE HAVE
CONSISTENTLY SYSTEMATICALLY
INTENTIONALLY BEEN TREATED AS
SUB STANDARD WE SEE THAT AND
LEGISLATION DOES NOT ALWAYS
NECESSARILY HELP IT WAS WRITTEN
IN THE CONSTITUTION THAT PEOPLE
WHO LOOK LIKE ME OR THREE
FIFTHS OF A HUMAN BEING WE MUST
LOOK AT THE FOUNDATIONAL
DOCUMENTS OF THIS COUNTRY. AND
SEE HOW IT CONTINUES TO
PERPETUATE THE OVERALL
MENTALITY OF PEOPLE HERE THE
STATISTICS ARE STARK TO HEAR
THAT OVER 50% OF LAW
ENFORCEMENT IN THIS COUNTRY IS
PREDOMINANTLY WHITE MALES.
AGAIN THESE ARE NOT PEOPLE WHO
ARE IN OUR COMMUNITIES. WHO
RECOGNIZE US AS BEING HUMAN
BEINGS. THE MAYOR COMPLEXION OF
MY SKIN MAKES ME A CRIMINAL IN
THIS COUNTRY THAT IS
PROBLEMATIC. WHEN WE COMPARED
THE UNITED STATES TO OTHER
COUNTRIES IN REGARDS TO
POLICING I THINK AGAIN THAT WE
WOULD BE A MESS IF WE DID NOT
RECOGNIZE THAT THE UNITED
STATES OF AMERICA HAS SOCIALLY
CONSTRUCTED PSYCHOLOGICALLY
INDOCTRINATED THIS THING CALLED
RACE. WHICH LEADS TO RACISM.
WHICH ALLOWS US TO CONTINUE TO
OTHER ONE ANOTHER. WE SAY THAT
POLICING IS SUPPOSED TO BE
INCLUSIVE THAT IT IS THE
COMMUNITY HOWEVER THERE IS THAT
US VERSUS THEM MENTALITY SO
THEREFORE LAW ENFORCEMENT NOR
THE COMMUNITIES. ARE ABLE TO
BRIDGE THE GAP IT IS THROUGH
THE TYPE OF WORK IT IS THROUGH
THE TYPE OF PROGRAMMING THAT
CHIEF DANIEL HAHN IS
IMPLEMENTING- THAT WE ARE ABLE
TO BEGIN TO OPEN UP AND HAVE
THESE CONVERSATIONS AND LOOK AT
WHAT DOES IT LOOK LIKE FOR US
TO COME TOGETHER TO BUILD
SOMETHING NEW DIFFERENT
SUSTAINABLE- ARM. WHEN WE LOOK
AT A PROFESSIONALISM OR WE TALK
ABOUT THE CORE OF POLICING AND
THAT THAT THE CORE POLICING IS
TO SOLVE PROBLEMS AGAIN WHEN WE
TALK ABOUT COMMUNITIES THAT
LOOK LIKE ME. THAT'S
PROBLEMATIC- WE RECENTLY HAD A
KILLING OF TWO YOUNG MEN AT
ARDEN FAIR MALL AND OUR MAYOR
CAME OUT AND MADE A COMMENT
ALLUDING THAT THIS MAY BE GANG
RELATED VIOLENCE. I PERSONALLY
KNOW THESE TWO YOUNG MEN. THEY
WERE FRIENDS OF MY DAUGHTERS
THIS WAS NOT GANG RELATED
HOWEVER OUT OF THAT
CONVERSATION CAME. WE NEED
THERE'S A NECESSITY FOR
ADDITIONAL GANG TASK FORCE
OFFICERS ARE THESE OFFICERS IN
OUR COMMUNITY TO ACTUALLY DEAL
WITH THE ISSUES THAT MAY
CONTRIBUTE TO ONE JOINING A
GANG. ARE WE REALLY LOOKING AT
THE FACT THAT A LOT OF THESE
YOU COME FROM ECONOMICALLY
DEPRIVED AND DISENFRANCHISED
COMMUNITIES THAT A LOT OF THEM
ARE FOSTER YOU A LOT OF THEM
ARE BEING RAISED BY A NON
PARENT THAT THEIR PARENTS ARE
EITHER CAUGHT UP IN MASS
INCARCERATION OR MAY YOU KNOW
SUFFER FROM SUBSTANCE ABUSE
ISSUES. IT'S EASY FOR US TO
CONTINUE TO CRIMINALIZE OUR
CONDITION BUT WE ARE NOT
TALKING ABOUT THE SYSTEMIC
ISSUES THAT CREATE THE ISSUES
THAT WE AND WE THEN IN TURN
HAVE TO ENCOUNTER LAW
ENFORCEMENT WE HAVE BEEN
CRIMINALIZED FROM THE TIME WE
SET. FOOT ON THE SOIL SO HOW DO
WE ACTUALLY START TO DEAL WITH
THOSE ISSUES BECAUSE THOSE ARE
THE ISSUES. THAT LEAD TO POLICE
VIOLENCE AGAINST PEOPLE WHO
LOOK LIKE US. SO YOU KNOW FOR
ME IT IS MUCH IT'S MUCH DEEPER-
THEN HOW DO WE DEAL WITH ISSUES
OF REFORM- THERE HAVE BEEN-
BEEN SEVERAL OPPORTUNITIES. FOR
US TO DO THINGS DIFFERENTLY YET
WE FAIL TO DO THAT- I'M LOOKING
AT THE WAY THAT. WE CONTINUE TO
MILITARIZE THE POLICE MISS LANE
I'M SORRY CAN YOU- WE HAVE ONE
MORE MINUTE FOR YOU CAN JUST
WRAP IT ONE MOMENT THANK YOU
VERY MUCH NO PROBLEM SO TO
CLOSE OUT WEEK WE CONTINUE TO
MILITARIZE POLICE IN THIS
COUNTRY. HOWEVER IF OUR
MILITARY PERSONNEL ENGAGED IN
THE SAME TYPE OF BEHAVIOR THAT
OUR POLICE OFFICERS DO THEY
WOULD BE SITTING UNDERNEATH
FEDERAL PENITENTIARIES SO I AM
WONDERING WHY IS IT THAT WE
CONTINUE TO ALLOW CERTAIN
PRACTICES TO OCCUR IN THE
POLICE DEPARTMENTS THROUGHOUT
THIS COUNTRY YET THERE IS NO
LEVEL OF ACCOUNTABILITY. THANK
YOU. THANK YOU VERY VERY MUCH
MISS LAND WE APPRECIATE ALL
THAT YOU HAVE SHARED WITH US
THUS FAR- MY COLLEAGUE- IS
RUBIO WANTS TO MAKE ONE COMMENT
BEFORE WE GO TO OUR NEXT-
SPEAKER. MAYES RUBIO YES I
THANK YOU HI YOU'RE SPEAKING MY
LANGUAGE I AM SO EXCITED TO
HEAR YOU SAYING WHAT YOU JUST
SAID BECAUSE I FELT LIKE A
BROKEN RECORD AND I FELT- THAT
MY COLLEAGUES ARE LOOKING AT
ME. WEIRD BECAUSE I KEPT SAYING
THE HASH TAG- YOU KNOW THE FROM
THE POLICE IT WAS A JUST A HASH
TAG BUT I WANT TO GIVE YOU MY
NUMBER I AM IN SACRAMENTO FOR A
FEW DAYS AND I WANT TO MEET
WITH YOU AFTERWARDS BUT I JUST
WANT TO GIVE YOU ONE EXAMPLE
I'LL HAVE HOW- DIFFERENT FOLKS
ARE TRICK OR TREATED. I LAST
YEAR I DON'T KNOW IF YOU RECALL
THAT IN THE SENATE THERE WERE
SOME BLOOD THROWN ON THE
SENATORS. RIGHT IF YOU LOOK AT
THE VIDEO OF WHAT HAPPENED TO
THAT WHITE WOMAN WHEN SHE WAS
pCOMING OUT THEY THEY THEY GAVE
HER THE OPPORTUNITY TO STAND
THERE IF IT WAS OUT. OF MY
PENAL OR OF AFRICAN AMERICAN
PERSON THAT PERSON WOULD HAVE
BEEN ON THE GROUND WITH THEIR
HANDS AND THEIR BACK AND I MADE
THAT COMMENT I REMEMBER I MADE
THAT COMMENT TO SOME OF MY
COLLEAGUES. THAT IT'S HAPPENING
EVEN HERE WITHIN OUR YOU KNOW
THE THIS AMAZING BUILDING THAT
WOMAN WAS TREATED VERY
DIFFERENTLY AS IF IT WAS UP UP
AND NOT BEING OR AN AFRICAN
AMERICANS WILL THINK YOU AND I
DEFINITELY WANT TO. SIT WITH
YOU AND TALK TO YOU ABOUT WHAT
YOU'RE SAYING BECAUSE- WE CAN
SAY ALL OF THESE AMAZING THINGS
OF NOTE NOTICE. MISTER GIBSON
BUT IF NOTHING COMES OUT OF
THESE CONVERSATIONS THAT I'M
JUST WASTING MY TIME HERE AND
SO I WANTED TO TALK TO YOU
ABOUT HOW WE CAN MOVE FORWARD
AND REALLY HAVE. HAVE YOU KNOW
THESE CONVERSATIONS AND I KNOW
MISTER GIBSON PERSONALLY AND HE
WILL DO EVERYTHING POSSIBLE FOR
US TO COME UP WITH SOLUTIONS.
BUT IT HAS TO BE MULTI FACETED
COMMUNITY MEMBERS AS AND THE
POLICE- YOU KNOW THAT THE
POLICE COMMUNITY ALREADY THAT
PEACE OFFICER COMMUNITY BECAUSE
WE CAN'T DO IT BY OURSELVES BUT
WE NEED. THAT HONEST
CONVERSATION THAT YOU JUST HAD
AND A LOT OF US. ARE FREE TO
HAVE SO THANK YOU. IN THANK YOU
VERY. MR OF YOUR- AND THAT'S
THE REASON WE HAVE THIS ROBE.
COVER TO. SO THAT WE CAN.
DIFFERENT PERSPECTIVES
DIFFERENT INPUT DIFFERENT
IDEALS SOME DIFFERENT BACKS
BACKGROUND THE WALKS OF LIFE-
TO HAVE BEEN BLEND THEIR VOICES
IN WITH THIS CONVERSATION SO I
THINK WE'RE GOING IN THE RIGHT
DIRECTION I BELIEVE THAT WE
WILL HAVE- SOMETHING VERY VERY
SIGNIFICANT AS I KNOW. NOT ONLY
THOSE WHO ARE HERE BUT WE HAVE-
COLLEAGUES WHOSE. STAFFS ARE
WATCHING AND TAKING NOTES-
WE'RE LOOKING FOR REAL- WE'RE
LOOKING TO RE IMAGINE LAW
ENFORCEMENT THAT CALIFORNIA AND
THIS. HELPS GETS A SLAP
POLITICAL POINT TIME. SO AT
THIS TIME AGAIN THANK YOU VERY
MUCH WAS LAST FOR YOUR COMMENTS
WE REALLY APPRECIATE. YOUR
VOICE IN THIS IN THIS SPACE-
NEXT ONE GO TO OUR NEXT-
PRESENTER. MISTER HAD NEW-
WOULD YOU PLEASE- OPERATE WOULD
YOU PLEASE. ALLOW ME TO HANDLE
TO PLEASE COMMAND- AND PLEASE I
DON'T WANT TO PUT YOUR LAST
NAME TO COMPLETE IS A NANCY
IT'S OUR LAST NAME FOR SO WE
CAN HAVE IT ON RECORD. AND WE
APPRECIATE YOU TAKING THE TIME
OUT OF YOUR BUSY SCHEDULE
JOINING US. SO MODERATE THE
COULD PLEASE LET ME TO HANDLE
IN. TO- JOIN US. HELLO MY
AFTERNOON YOUR LINE IS OPEN GO
AHEAD PLEASE. THANK YOU VERY
MUCH- GOOD AFTERNOON- CHAIRMAN
AND THE MEMBERS OF THIS
COMMITTEE ON POLICE REFORM- MY
NAME IS TYLER TIE MY I'M A
DIRECTOR SOME OF YOU KNOW YOU
KNOW ME AS DEGENHARDT- I AM A
DIRECTOR. OF THE LOS ANGELES
POLICE PROTECTIVE LEAGUE THE
UNION THAT REPRESENTS RANK AND
FILE OFFICERS- AND OUT AS I
WRITE OFF INTO THE SUNSET OF
RETIREMENT. IN THE NEXT MONTH
I'M THANKFUL FOR THE
OPPORTUNITY TO SHARE LESSONS
THAT I HAVE LEARNED. AS A
POLICE OFFICER. THE UNION
LEADER AND AN ADVOCATE FOR
PROFESSIONAL LIGHTING. THE
PROFESSIONAL LAW ENFORCEMENT-
BIELIK HAD ABBOTT OF
PROFESSIONAL CITING POLICE. IT
IT IT'S- WITH CHINA BILL TWO
TWO TWO YEAR AGO- WE BELIEVE
THAT OUR POLICING SHOULD BE.
MOLD MORE- STANDARDIZED AND OUR
STANDARDS SHOULD BE RAISED- WE
HAVE ADVOCATED PUSHING OUT RATE
TO STOP THIS FROM POLICING WE
HAVE ADVOCATED EARLY WARNING
MONITORING PROGRAMS AND SYSTEMS
LIKE WE HAVE IMPLEMENTED HERE
IN. LOS ANGELES I HAVE ALWAYS
ASK FOR MORE TRAINING NOT LESS-
WE HAVE USED IMPORTANT WORDS
TODAY LIKE PROTECT AND TO SERVE
AND MUTUAL RESPECT WHICH
HIGHLIGHTS THE IMPORTANCE OF
GETTING ABOVE WORK IN
COLLABORATION WITH THE
LEGISLATURE AND COMMUNITY
REPRESENTATIVES AND EXPERTS
BOTH FROM THE ACADEMIA LAW
ENFORCEMENT- THE AND LAW
ENFORCEMENT BEING THE PEOPLE
WHO ARE ENTRUSTED WITH THE
SACRED DUTY OF. A PROVIDING
EQUITABLE AND PROFESSIONAL
SERVICE TO ALL CALIFORNIANS
REGARDLESS OF RACE. CREED COLOR
BACKGROUND OR THE COMMUNITY
WHERE THEY LIVE IN. AND I
APPRECIATE DOLLAR TO BE PART OF
THIS CONVERSATION- WHEN IT
COMES TO TRAINING THE
IMPORTANCE OF TRAINING AND
TOUCHES MANY DIFFERENT THINGS I
APPRECIATE- THE PRIOR TO
SPEAKERS WHO HIGHLIGHTED MANY
IMPORTANT THINGS- IT TRAINING
IMPROVES. THE OUR SERVICE TO
THE COMMUNITY TO THE VERY
PEOPLE THAT WE ARE SERVING.
FIVE IT CAN ALSO HAS A VERY BIG
IMPACT ON AND IF WE BELIEVE
THAT THERE IS- THERE ARE ISSUES
WITH THE POLICE CULTURE IT
STARTS AND WITH THE WITH
RETRAINING POLICE OFFICERS. AND
THE BIGGEST THING BEING
OBVIOUSLY- WHICH TRAINING IS TO
IMPROVE THE COMMUNITY AND
PLEASE CONTACT AND OUTCOMES- I
HAVE BEEN ASKED TO SHARE
INSIGHT FROM THE PERSPECTIVE OF
RANK AND FILE POLICE OFFICER
ABOUT THE IMPORTANCE OF
TRAINING AND ONGOING TRAINING.
I WANT TO LEAVE YOU WITH THESE
TOPLINE POINT- LAW ENFORCEMENT
OFFICERS DO NOT RECEIVE MUCH
ONGOING TRAINING PERIOD. NOT
ALL TRAINING IS CREATED EQUALLY-
JUST BECAUSE AN OFFICER IS
QUOTED TRAINED ON AN ISSUE DOES
NOT MEAN THE TRAINING IS
QUALITY MEANINGFUL. SOME OF THE
CLOSE TRAINING- AND WHETHER OR
NOT THEY ARE ACTUALLY
EFFECTIVE- AND SO DO MANY OF
MANY OTHER OFFICES THAT I'VE
SPOKEN WITH AND I'M NOT TO
CRITICIZE POST BUT I THINK WE
CAN ALWAYS DO BETTER IF WE
START TO DO THAT THE DEPARTMENT
AND I THINK WE SHOULD DO THE
SAME THING WITH THE POST- WOOD
BUT I DO APPRECIATE THEIR
TRAINING- IT'S ALSO NOT ALWAYS
TRAINED TO DO WHAT LAWMAKERS OR
THE PUBLIC EXPECT THEM TO DO-
MANY TIMES. AND IT'S JUST THE
FORM THAT IT- IT IS DONE AND-
LOG OUT FIRST PASSED AND THEN
WE BECOME- A LOT OF TIMES. THE
IMPLEMENTATION AND BECOMING. OR.
PROVIDING TRAINING. FIVE SO
SOMETIMES THERE'S A ONE OR TWO
YEAR GAP IN OPTIONS NOT PROPER.
TRAINED IN WHAT THE LAWS HAVE
BEEN PASSED BUT WE ARE HELD
ACCOUNTABLE TO THOSE LAWS IN
THAT TIME- ONE OF THE STARKEST
EXAMPLE OF THIS WOULD BE THAT
PROPOSED HAS COMPLETED THE
MODEL DE ESCALATION TRAINING-
IN THE AST FEW MONTHS. EVEN
THOUGH POLICE OFFICERS ARE
BEING HELD TO THE STANDARD
ESTABLISHED IN THE ASSEMBLY
BILL THREE NINETY TWO FROM A
COUPLE OF YEARS BACK. OFFICERS
HAVE NOT BEEN TRAINED ON HOW TO
COMPLY WITH THE NEW STANDARD. I
HAD A CHANCE TO SPEAK WITH ONE
OF OUR TRAINERS IN THE LOS
ANGELES POLICE ACADEMY THE
CHANGE THAT CHANGED OUR-
RECRUITING TACTICS. AND SHE
WAS- ARE STILL CONFUSED AFTER
SOME OF THE LANGUAGE AND SOME
OF THE- DIRECTION THAT SHE HAD
GOTTEN. AND FROM A COMPUTER
TRAINER TO THE NEW RECRUITS YOU
CAN SEE THE PROBLEM THAT WE ARE
NOT PREPARING OUR OFFICERS
SUFFICIENTLY. BOB FOR THE
STREET. EVEN THOUGH IT MAY
THINK. MORE FIREARMS TRAINING
WILL HELP OFFICERS- AND- IT'S
EASY TO. I'VE HEARD THESE
THINGS THAT OFFICES ARE GETTING
TOO MUCH FIREARMS TRAINING AND
THAT WE'RE CREATING KILLERS AND
THAT TYPE OF STUFF AND THAT
SIMPLY IS NOT TRUE- MORE SELF
DEFENSE TRAINING- ALL. FIREARMS
TRAINING- WILL ONLY RESULT IN
MORE SELF CONFIDENT OFFICERS
WHO HAVE COMPETITION THEIR
SKILLS. AND BIG WILL DEREK
BENNER TO DEPLOYED ITS TACTICS
AND THE PROPER POLICY APPROVED
TACTICS. BECAUSE IN HER
COMPETENCE AND- AND- ABILITY TO
CONTROL THE SITUATION IN HIGH
STRESS SITUATIONS WE FALL BACK
ON TRAINING AND MUSCLE MEMORY
IN ORDER TO DEVELOP MUSCLE
MEMORY THOUGHT PATTERNS AND
PHYSICAL MOVEMENTS HAVE TO BE
TRAINED THOUSANDS OF TIMES OVER
SO THAT IT BECOMES NOT OF
AUTOMATION. WHEN CALLED UPON.
THE COMPETENT AND CONFIDENT-
AND STATE POLICE OFFICER THERE
FOR STATE POLICE OFFICER THEY
ARE LIKELY TO USE LESS FORCE
THAN THOSE WHO HAVE NO
COMPETENCE OR LITTLE CONFIDENCE
IN THEIR TRAINING. RIGOROUS
TRAINING MUST BE ONGOING. IT IS
IT IS GOING TO YIELD THE RESULT
THAT LAWMAKERS HOPING FOR. THIS
MEANS RECOGNIZING THE
RECOGNIZING THAT WHEN
DEPARTMENTS ARE DECLINED IT THE
FIRST THING THAT CAUGHT OUR
EQUIPMENT AND TECHNOLOGY THE
SECOND THING IS CUT OUR
CIVILIAN EMPLOYEES. THE THIRD
TIER OF CUTS ARE TRAINING.
WELLNESS PROGRAMS OFFICERS AND
SPECIALIZED UNITS. THE FUNDING%
DEPARTMENT PRODUCES LOWER
QUALITY DEPARTMENTS WERE
STRETCHED THIN AND ARE NOT-ACCOUNTABLE FOR THE SYMPTOMS OF
PROBLEMS BEFORE THEY BECOME
REAL PROBLEMS. IT'S ACTUALLY
YOU GET WHAT YOU PAY FOR. I'M
GOING TRAINING FOR PEACE
OFFICERS IS VITAL BECAUSE MANY
OF THE SKILLS THAT I LEARNED IN
THE ACADEMY ARE PERISHABLE
SKILLS. AND NEED TO BE
CONTINUOUSLY REFRESHED IN ORDER
TO PROTECT THE SAFETY OF THE
OFFICER THE SUSPECT AND THE
BYSTANDERS. POST REQUIRED
ONGOING TRAINING TWENTY FOUR
HOURS EVERY TWO YEARS BUT THIS
TRAIN DOES NOT PREPARE OFFICERS
FOR THE EXPECTATION TWENTY
FIRST CENTURY. BOB PERSONAL
SKILLS TRAINING CONSISTS OF A
MINIMUM OF FOURTEEN HOURS EVERY
TWO YEARS. THE FOCUS OF THIS
TRAINING HAS TO BE ON THE
ARREST OF CONTROL- IT'S USUALLY
HAND CUPPING SUSPECT DRIVING.
IT COULD BE SLOW SPEED DRIVING
AND PARKING THE VEHICLE AND
QUALIFYING WITH A FIREARM. BOB
ALTERCATION IS- WHATEVER HAS
BEEN ESTABLISHED AS MINIMUM
STANDARDS AND OFTEN TIMES-
DEPARTMENTS ARE STRETCHED JAN
AND BARE. BOB DONNAN UNABLE TO
PROVIDE FURTHER. MEANINGFUL
YEAH INSTRUCTION IN FIREARMS
TRAINING IN REALITY WE DO WE
SPEND ABOUT FIVE MINUTES AT THE
RANGE QUALIFYING FIVE TIMES A
YEAR WITHOUT SIDE SIDE ARM AND
WITH A SHOT GUN ONCE A YEAR-
AND THAT IS THE EXTENT OF OUR
TRAINING SO THAT AMOUNTS ABOUT.
ABOUT TWENTY FIVE MINUTES OF
REQUIRED- LOG OF FIREARMS
SHOOTING AND TRAINING. SO THE
THOSE ARE THE REAL QUALITIES-
OF THE REALITIES OF LOG A LOT
OF TRAINING. SO I WOULD NOT
CONSIDER THESE REQUIREMENTS TO
BE A RIGOROUS AT ALL- AND THEN
I JUST TOUCHED UPON THE PUBLIC
FIREARMS QUALIFICATION IS FOR A
LOT OF DEPARTMENTS SOME DO
QUARTERLY COME TO EVERY OTHER
MONTH- BUT- OFTENTIMES UNLESS
YOU WORK IN A SPECIALIZED UNIT
YOU'RE NOT RECEIVING THE
TRAINING THAT YOU NEED. A
SPECIALIZED UNITS ARE NOT- FOR
THE MOST PART- FIRST RESPONDING
PATROL UNITS BOB THAT YOU YOU
RECEIVE WHEN YOU CALL NINE ONE
ONE- LAW ENFORCEMENT OFFICERS
HAVE BEEN TAUGHT TACTICAL. AND
INTERPERSONAL COMMUNICATION
TECHNIQUES BUT WE RECEIVED TWO
HOURS EVERY TWO YEARS. THIS IS
NOT ENOUGH TRAINING TO PRODUCE
OFFICERS SKILLED AT DE
ESCALATION TECHNIQUES. ALTHOUGH
MANY DEPARTMENTS THEY ATTEMPT
TO DO THE BEST JOB THAT THEY
CAN PROVIDING NEEDS- THAT THE
TRAINING AND IT VARIES- IT'S
JUST NOT ENOUGH- SO WHEN I
LISTEN TO. SOME TALK ABOUT DE
ESCALATION IT SOUNDS TO ME LIKE
WHAT HAS BEEN ASKED IS PHONE
OFFICER WHO WAS ADVANCED- QUITE
ADVANCED TRAINING IN CRIMINAL
PSYCHOLOGY CLINICAL
CRIMINOLOGY. AND ADVANCING
GLACIATIONS SKILLS AND- THAT IS
JUST SIMPLY NOT- TRUE AND THAT
IS NOT THE REALITY AND- WE DID
FOCUS GROUPS ON A COUPLE OF
YEARS AGO STATEWIDE FOCUS
GROUPS AND WE ASK PEOPLE WHAT
THEIR PERCEPTION OF WHAT THEY
BELIEVED. AN OFFICERS TRAINING%
TO BE. AND THE PERCEPTION THAT
THE PUBLIC GENERAL PUBLIC HELD
IN CALIFORNIA BUT LAW
ENFORCEMENT OFFICERS AND THEIR
TRAINING- WHAT ABOUT NIGHT AND
DAY BETWEEN WHAT THEY THINK AND
WHAT ACTUALLY IS- THERE WERE
PEOPLE WHO ACTUALLY THOUGHT
THAT WE STATE WE NEED TO START
THE DAY AT THE RANGE. BAYAT
BECOMING EXPERT- SHOOTERS WE
ARE NOT EXPERT SHOOTERS WE ARE
NOT- THE MOST ABOUT THAT EXPERT
SHOOTERS- WE ARE NOT A TRAINED
MARTIAL ARTISTS- WE GET SOME
TRAINING AND ALL THAT. GOES UP
HARASSED- I AM LOVE WE GET
COURTNEY COURSES IS NOT THAT
MUCH FROM WHAT IS BEING ACTUAL
POLICE OFFICERS AND I AM MOST
FORTY HOURS OF TRAINING- SO.
THAT IS NOT THE LEVEL OF
TRAINING THAT THE LEGISLATURE
PROVIDES TO OFFICERS AND WHAT
I'M ALSO TALKING ABOUT IS IT
SUPPOSED BEING FUNDED PROPERLY-
IT REALLY BOILS DOWN TO
RESOURCES AND BUDGETARY ISSUES
AND FUNDING AND I REALIZE THAT
THE LEGISLATURE IS A VERY
DIFFICULT JOB. IN A MAKING
MONEY LAST FOR ALL PASSAGE OF
CALIFORNIANS NEEDS- BUT CAN'T
IT HAS BECOME SUCH A BIG ISSUE
WE WOULD ASK THE LEGISLATURE
TO. MAKE SURE THAT THERE IS
PROPER FUNDING FOR- ENHANCING
POLICE TRAINING- SO WE REALLY
NEED TO TAKE MORE INTENSE LOOK
AT INVESTING IN THE QUALITY
TRAINING THAT REFLECT THE TYPE
OF POLICE ORGANIZATIONS. ARE
YOU WANT TO SEE ESPECIALLY
MEETING THIS TIME IN OUR IN
OUR- IN OUR COUNTRY WHERE ABOUT
POLICING HAS BECOME SUCH A HOT
TOPIC AND IT SHOULD BE- I
REMEMBER GOING TO THE ACADEMY
NINETEEN NINETY SEVEN AND I
REMEMBER- THAT. AND IS
EXPECTING STATE AND MATURED
IMPROVED BUT- WE DIDN'T HAVE
EXTRA COOK REAL QUESTION A ROLE
OF THE POLICE IN OUR SOCIETY
COMMUNITY. I THINK THAT'S VERY
IMPORTANT COURSE SUIT TO BE HAD
AND IT SHOULD BE MANDATED.
ANOTHER ONE SHOULD BE
CONSTITUTIONAL TRAINING AT THE
APPLICATION. IN EVERYDAY KILL
CONTACTS. CASHING IN THE CAR
THE FREE SHOULD BE A PICNIC
IMPACT IN OFFICE IT SHOULD
UNDERSTAND THAT- WE SHOULD HAVE
CLEAR ARTICULABLE FACTS TO
SUPPORT EVERY STOP THAT WE MAKE-
WHAT WE HAVE DONE ALSO AND I
APPRECIATE SOME OF THE COMMENTS
FROM THE PREVIOUS SPEAKER.
ABOUT HAVING GONE THROUGH THE
USE OF FORCE OPTION SIMULATOR-
WE HAVE ALSO DIED ON THAT WE
HAVE ALSO BROUGHT IT SHOULD BE
KEPT STATE CAPITOL FOR THE
LEGISLATORS TO GO THROUGH
DURING THE AB THREE NINETY TWO-
YEAH. THE TICKET MATCHED AND-
WE APPRECIATE EVERYONE GOING
THROUGH AND GIVEN OUR OUR
PERSPECTIVE OF HOW- HOW THINGS
CAN. HAPPEN AND HOW QUICKLY
THEY HAVE BEEN AND HOW VOLATILE
THINGS CAN BE. AND I HAVE I
HAVE ATTENDED MY SHARE OF
POLICE GENERALS AND THOSE ARE
REAL LIFE AFFECTED JUST THE
WAY- ARE- YEAH ACTIVISTS TALK
ABOUT LIFE THAT ARE LOST IN
PLEASE BEEN COUNTER SO- CUTS
BOTH WAYS- WE HAVE ALSO
CONDUCTED COMMUNITY POLICE
ACADEMIES- IN IN HIGH CRIME
AREAS. THAT WE FIND TO BE VERY
HELPFUL ALL THESE I THINK THAT
SHOULD BE TRIED IN EVERY- EVERY
COMMUNITY- THAT. THERE'S A NEED
FOR AND MAYBE NOT EVERY
COMMUNITY I THINK ONE THING TO
REMEMBER IS THAT WE ARE NOT
MONOLITHIC. WE ARE NOT-
COMMUNITIES ARMAND NOT
MONOLITHIC AND I THINK THERE
SHOULD BE SOME ECONOMY FOR TO
EACH JURISDICTION BE GIVEN AND
SEE WHAT THEIR PRIORITIES IS IT
NOT IN TRAINING- BUT THERE
SHOULD BE SOME THINGS THAT ARE.
ARE STANDARDIZED AND WE CAN
ALWAYS WE SHOULD ALWAYS AIM TO
HAVE BILLS STANDARDIZATION IS
ADS- HIGH. VALUE IN TRAINING AS
POSSIBLE- WHAT I STATED- I'LL
GIVE AN EXAMPLE OF- OF
DISCONNECT WHEN I STATED
EARLIER THAT THE PEACE OFFICERS
ARE NOT TRAINED TO DO WHAT
LAWMAKERS OR THE PUBLIC EXPECT
THEM TO DO. I MEANT THAT THERE
IS A DISCONNECT BETWEEN THE
OFFICERS ARE TRAINED WHAT
THEY'RE TRAINED IN DOING AND
WHAT IS EXPECTED OF OFFICERS.
OPERATE THE DAY BETWEEN NINETY
TWO AND I REFER TO THAT. AS
ABOUT EARLIER WHEN OUR OWN SOME
OF OUR OWN TRAINERS. ARE
CONFUSED. TWO YEARS LATER-
DAHLE PROTECT PROPORTIONALITY
ABOUT THE LANGUAGE ABOUT ARE.
NOT GETTING ENOUGH DIRECTION-
FROM MODEST STATE- YOU CAN YOU
CAN EXPECT. TO HAVE- A SUB
STANDARD TRAINING- REGIMENTS
AND SUB STANDARD RESULTS. AND
WE HAVE TO DO ALL RIGHT. FOR
THE OCCASION AND MAKE SURE THAT
THIS DOESN'T HAPPEN- FOR THERE
HAVE BEEN- MHM I HAD ACTUALLY
MAKE MY- I DON'T HOW MUCH TIME
YOU HAVE A SECURE WAS GOING TO
JUST JUMPING WE HAVE ONE MINUTE
FOR YOU. OKAY WELL I'M JUST
GONNA WRAP IT UP I HAD A MANY
MANY NEEDS TO STATUS OF FACE ON
THE FIFTEEN MINUTES THAT I- I'M
TRYING TO DO MY BEST HERE- I
THINK THERE'S A LOT OF AREA
WHERE- WE HAVE A GREAT CHANCE
TO WORK TOGETHER WITH THE
COMMUNITY MEMBERS. OF THE
LEGISLATURE THE POLICE UNION
POLICE CHIEFS- AND THE EXPERTS-
AND YAKKING DAY OUT FROM THE
ACADEME AND I APPRECIATE THEM
BEING PRESENT HERE TODAY AS
WELL- I THINK IT'S BECAUSE
COULD BE SOMETHING SIGNIFICANT.
THAT WE COULD BE A MODEL TO-
OTHER STATES IN THE UNION. ALL
DOGS WE ARE LOOKING FORWARD TO
ALL OF THESE ROBUST DISCUSSIONS
WANT TO BE PART OF IT WE WANT
TO ARKANSAS- WE WANT. TO BE.
PERCEIVED AS A PARTNER. AND WE
WANT TO IMPROVE OUR IMAGE IN
EVERY COMMUNITY IN OUR STATE
AND THAT IS OUR COMMITMENT FROM
ALL THE POLICE UNIONS. OFTEN
CALIFORNIA. THANK YOU THANK YOU
VERY MUCH DIRECT WE APPRECIATE.
YOU AND REPRESENT LOS ANGELES
PROTECTIVE LEAGUE IN YOUR
COMMENTS- THEY WERE VERY MUCH
WELL WELL RECEIVED AND AGAIN
THANK YOU VERY MUCH AND WISH
YOU WELL ON YOUR RETIREMENT. SO
THANK YOU VERY MUCH FOR YOUR
YOUR SERVICE TO OUR COMMUNITY
OF LOS ANGELES COMMUNITY. SO
WITH THAT- WE'VE CONCLUDED OUR
PANEL- WE'RE GOING TO OPEN IT
UP FOR MEMBERS- TO ASK
QUESTIONS AGAIN MEMBERS WHO ARE
WITH US VIRTUALLY. WILL ASK YOU
TAX ME SO I CAN PLACE YOU IN
THE QUEUE. BUT WE DO HAVE ONE
MEMBER- RB K. YOU'RE UP- YOU
THE FIRST ONE IN THE- ON THE-
AGAIN. ENCOURAGE MEMBERS TO. ME
THAT ALSO. YOU IN THE- WITH
THAT BEING SAID YOUR- THANK YOU
MISTER CHAIR I'M ALWAYS READY
WITH MY QUESTION- SO I THINK
THE PANELISTS FOR AT THAT
INFORMATIVE DISCUSSION ABOUT
TRAINING I ALSO ANYTHING MISS
LAND. REALLY HITTING HOME THE
POINT OF HOW MUCH WORK WE HAVE
TO DO TO CHANGE THE CULTURE AND
THE OVERALL STRUCTURE OF THE
SYSTEMS. AND THAT'S WHAT WE'RE
HERE TO TALK ABOUT. BUT WE HAVE
A LOT OF WORK AHEAD OF US. I
WOULDN'T REALLY ONE THING WHICH
IS THE WORK OF CHIEF TO HOT AT
IN EMERYVILLE ON TRAINING
RELATED TO MINDFULNESS I THINK
THAT IT IS SOMETHING THAT IS.
TOO OFTEN DISMISSED SHE'S DONE
INCREDIBLE WORK FOCUSED ON HOW
DO WE GET POLICE OFFICERS. IN
THE MOMENT TO MAKE THE RIGHT
DECISIONS IN WHAT IS THAT
TRAINING LOOK LIKE ON AN
EVERYDAY BASIS I THINK WE NEED
MORE. CREATIVE AND INNOVATIVE
SOLUTIONS AROUND TRAINING THAT
WILL CHANGE THE CULTURE AND I
THINK SHE'S BEEN AT THE
FOREFRONT OF THAT WORK AND
HOPEFULLY SHE- I KNOW SHE
RETIRED FROM THE EMERYVILLE
POLICE PART BUT I KNOW SHE
CONTINUES TO BE IN THESE
CONVERSATIONS AND I THINK IT'S
IMPORTANT THAT WE LEFT UP.
DIFFERENT AND NEW VOICES ABOUT
WHAT OUR POLICE TRAINING SHOULD
LOOK LIKE- MY QUESTION THOUGH.
FOR THE PANELISTS IS TO ADDRESS
THE QUESTION WE HEARD. IN THE
FIRST PANEL WHICH IS THAT THERE
ARE PIECES OF THE TRAINING.
THAT LEAD TO DISQUALIFICATION.
OF PEOPLE OF COLOR AND WOMEN
DISPROPORTIONATELY RIGHT THEY
HIGHLIGHTED AND- SHOOTING. AND
DRIVING IS THE TWO KEY ELEMENTS
THE TWO DEPARTMENTS THEIR
ONLINE BOTH SAN FRANCISCO AND
SACRAMENTO TALKED ABOUT. THEIR
OWN WORK TO ADDRESS THAT
LOCALLY. BUT CLEARLY THIS NEEDS
TO CHANGE AT THE STATE LEVEL
SHOULD WE TALK A LITTLE BIT
ABOUT WHAT POST IS DONE TO
ADDRESS THIS. MISTER ARBORISTS
FROM POST WE LIKE TO TAKE THAT
QUESTION TO STAY WITH US. SO WE
DID AN ANALYSIS IN TWENTY
NINETEEN SO YOUR RATES AT THE
ACADEMY AND THE FAILURE RATES
WERE NOT BASED ON. OUR SIX- I'M
SORRY CHECK- OR RACE OR
ETHNICITY THE FAILURE RATE WAS
APPROXIMATELY 15% OF THE CABIN
RECRUITER CAN DEBTS WERE
FAILING OUT OF THE ACADEMY AT
THAT POINT IN TIME. 10% WERE
SELF DISMISSALS AND 5% WERE
ACTUALLY FIELD TESTS.
PREDOMINANT AREAS IF THEY ARE
FAILING IS A FIREARMS TRAINING
AND- AMERICAN C. VEHICLE
OPERATIONS TRAINING. TO GIVE
YOU AN IDEA THE MINIMUM
STANDARDS FOR EMERGENCY VEHICLE
OPERATIONS TRAINING OR FORTY
HOURS OF TRAINING I BELIEVE AT
THAT TIME WE ARE CONDUCTING
THAT STUDY- THE ACADEMIES ARE
AVERAGING SEVENTY SEVEN HOURS
OF DRIVER TRAINING. WE ARE VERY
MUCH REINFORCED WITH THE- WITH
THE DIFFERENT ACADEMIES NEED
FOR REMEDIATION FOR PROPER
REMEDIATION FOR THOSE
INDIVIDUALS ARE LEARNED SKILLS
ARE I THINK YOU WILL SEE LESS
ARE LESS PEOPLE. FAILING OUT
BECAUSE OF G. ROCKET FIRINGS
AND WE DID TWO YEARS AGO I
DON'T WANT TO GET OUT IN FRONT
OF THAT REPORT I'VE HEARD SOME
OF THE- BUT- I HAVEN'T READ THE
DRAFT REPORT UNITS FLOATING
AROUND BECAUSE RIGHT NOW. IT
WILL GO INTO GREAT DETAIL. ON
ALL OF THE TESTING NOT JUST
FARMS AND- AND DRIVING. BUT WE
HAVE HAD NUMEROUS DISCUSSIONS
WITH WITH THE ACADEMY
SPECIFICALLY ABOUT REMEDIATION
TO IMPROPERLY MEDIATION. OVER
THE LAST TWO YEARS IN BOTH
FIREARMS AND DRIVING AND I
THINK YOU'RE GONNA SEE SOME
RESULTS. THANK U. S. ROSE I
LOOK FORWARD TO THAT REPORT.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH NEXT WILL
HAVE- MEMORY YES MISS REYES.
THANK YOU MISTER CHAIRMAN OF
WHAT WE'VE HEARD DESCRIBED SOME
OF THE SIMILARITIES AND
DIFFERENCES BETWEEN THE VARIOUS
POST CERTIFICATION ACADEMY. SO
THE QUESTION IS TO WHAT EXTENT
ARE EACH OF THESE DIFFERENT
ACADEMIES INSTILLING A SENSE OF
DEDICATION TO THE COMMUNITY AND
THE POLICE RECRUITS THAT ARE
BEING THOSE ARE BEING RECRUITED
AB WHERE IS THERE ROOM FOR
IMPROVEMENT. THANK YOU FOR YOUR
QUESTION TO OUR RESIDENTS LIKE
TAKE THAT QUESTION. SURE SO THE-
EVERY EVERY COMMUNITY COLLEGE
ACADEMY I BELIEVE THERE'S
APPROXIMATELY EIGHTEEN OF THE
FORTY ONE POLICE ACADEMIES OUR
COMMUNITY COLLEGE CHINESE ARE
REQUIRED TO HAVE AN ADVISORY
BOARD OF LAW ENFORCEMENT
PERSONNEL AND OTHERS THEY
PROVIDE THEM CAN PUT ON WITH
THEIR LOCAL MEATS ARE FOR THEIR
COMMUNITY- THAT ALLOWS THEM TO
TAILOR THE TRAINING TO THOSE
AGENCIES THAT THEY'RE SERVING
OUR- EACH ACADEMIES. IS WRITTEN.
PROVIDE STANDARDIZED TRAINING
BUT THEY ALSO- HAVE THE ABILITY
TO MODIFY THE TRAINING IN
CERTAIN AREAS FOR THEIR LOCAL
COMMITTEE I GIVE YOU AN
EXAMPLE- LET'S SEE AN ACADEMY
AND- COLLEGES THERE- SISKIYOU
IN- INVERNESS COUNTY. THEY DO
NOT HAVE VERY MUCH OF AN URBAN
ENVIRONMENT IN THEIR COMMUNITY
AND THEIR DRIVING MAYBE OFF
ROAD TYPE OF DRIVING- THEY MAY
INCLUDE- DIFFERENT ASPECTS OF
DEALING WITH A WORLD. HE DOES
NOT THEY DON'T DO OFF ROAD
DRIVING ITS URBAN DRIVING IT'S
A VERY DIFFERENT TYPE OF-
TRAINING SO WE DO GIVE THEM THE
OPPORTUNITY TO- TO CHANGE HOW
THEY ARE. HOW THEY DO THEIR
ECONOMY AS LONG AS THEY MEET
THE MINIMUM STANDARDS. I THINK
SOME AREAS THAT. COULD
POTENTIALLY IMPROVE THE ACADEMY
AND I GUESS THIS IS MORE OF A
CHALLENGE- CRITICISM GAS BUT AT
TIMES WE TEND TO SHOW OF
EVERYTHING INTO THE BASIC
ECONOMY. AND THE BASIC ACADEMY
IS THE BASIC ACADEMY WE TEND TO
SHOVE THINGS INTO THE ACADEMY
OFFICER IS NOT GOING TO.
NECESSARILY HAVE TO DEAL WITH
FOR THE FIRST TWO OR THREE
YEARS OF THEIR CAREER AS A
PEACE OFFICER AND THERE WOULD
BE. I THINK BUT ARE TOO USED TO
REMOVE SOME OF THAT'S EVERY
ATOM. AND PROVIDED AT A LATER
TIME REGARDLESS IF IT'S
MANDATED ARE NOT MANDATED BUT
SOMETIMES WE JUST HAVE TO SHOVE
IT ALL INTO THE ACADEMY. AND
THAT MAY NOT ALWAYS BE THE BEST
PLACE FOR IT THAT WOULD BE THE
ONE- THE ONE THING THAT. I
WOULD. YOU KNOW I WOULD SAY- TO
YOU ALL IS A CONSIDERATION
FUTURE MANDATE TRAINING- EACH
OTHER AREAS AND I THINK IT WAS
IT WAS DISCUSSED. IN GREAT
DETAIL ABOUT FIREARMS AN EVIL
ACT. THE KID YOUNG YOUNG PEOPLE
THESE DAYS ARE PROPER NOT
LINING UP THE DMV UNDER
SIXTEENTH BIRTHDAY TO GET THEIR
DRIVER'S LICENSE. WHEN THEY
SHOW UP TO- TO THE ACADEMY. NOT
AT GROUND ZERO BUT PERHAPS-
EIGHT ZERO BUT PERHAPS NEGATIVE
THREE- THE ACADEMY IS CLOSED BE
ABLE TO TAKE THEM FROM ZERO TO
GRADUATION BUT IF THEY'RE
ALREADY IN A DEFICIT- SOMETIMES
IT'S HARD TO GET THEM TO CATCH
UP SO THERE ARE AREAS THAT
PERHAPS WE CAN ADD ADDITIONAL
TRAINING- IN THOSE AREAS THAT
THERE ARE STRUGGLING ON DRIVING
BEING ONE PERHAPS FIREARMS
BEING THE OTHER- I'M OBVIOUSLY
BY ADDING ADDITIONAL TRAINING
HOURS A PATH THAT'S CLOSE- ON
THE BACK AND NEEDED THE
AGENCIES OR THE STATE SERVERS
ARE ALL CONSIDERATIONS. IN
TERMS OF POST IN GENERAL COAST
IN CALIFORNIA IS RIGHT IN THE
MIDDLE OF THE PACK IN TERMS OF
OTHER STATE OTHER STATES
REQUIRE MOST TO CADDY MARIN
COUNTY TRAINING OTHER STATES
REQUIRE LESS. THE STATE'S
REQUIREMENTS. EIGHT HOURS SOME
DO NOT HAVE A FEW TRAINING. AT
ALL WHAT YOU'RE WHEN SHE
GRADUATE FOR THE ACADEMY YOU'RE
DONE. SO I'M PERHAPS ADDING
ADDING SINCE AREAS MIGHT BE OF
BENEFIT AND ALSO TAKING INTO
CONSIDERATION THAT SOMETHINGS
ARE NECESSARILY BUILT FOR THE
ACADEMY. VERY GOOD THANK YOU SO
MUCH. THANK YOU I HAVE A
QUESTION I DON'T HAVE ANYONE IN
THE QUEUE AT THIS POINT. WE
HAVE- THIS IS FOR MR ALVAREZ
WITH THERE'S A NUMBER OF
ACADEMIES IN THE STATE OF
CALIFORNIA- AND IT'S ACADEMY
HAS THEIR OWN IDENTITY IN TERMS
OF TRAINING. IS THERE ANY LOOK
AT TRYING TO CREATE A MORE I
KNOW THERE'S A BASS LINE. THAT
PLAYED A CALIFORNIA REQUIRES.
THEN AFTER THAT THEN IT'S UP TO
THE ACADEMY TECH AND TAYLOR
WHATEVER THEY WANT BASED ON
COMMUNITY AND OUR CONDITIONS IS
THERE ANY THOUGHT OR
CONVERSATION. AROUND I
CONSISTENT. FOR INSTANCE AND I
WANT TO USE MY COLLEAGUES- MR
LACKEY I WENT TO REAL HONDA HE
WENT TO THE HIGHWAY PATROL THE
HIGHWAY PATROL REQUIRES. A MUCH
LONGER TIME IN THE ACADEMY
THEN- ANY THEN- REAL HONDA IS
THERE ANY. TALK ABOUT CREATING
SOME KIND OF UNIFORMITY IN
TERMS OF TIME THAT'S
CONSISTENT- THROUGHOUT THE
TOWERS THE CALIFORNIA TERMS OF
ACADEMIES AND TRAININGS. YEAH I
THINK ONE OF THE BEAUTIES OF
THE WEIGHTY CAPPED ANDES
OPERATE NOW IS THE FACT THAT
THEY CAN CREATE SOMEWHAT OF A
MODIFIED WORK- A DIVERSE
ECONOMY FOR WHAT THEY NEED SO
FOR INSTANCE- YOU ASSEMBLY
MEMBER GET SENT YOU REFERENCED-
CALIFORNIA HIGHWAY PATROL THEY
DO A LOT OF DRIVING. ATOMI I
SUSPECT THAT THAT THAT LEVEL OF
DRIVING WHICH IS NECESSARY FOR
THEM MAY NOT BE NECESSARY FOR
THE REAL HARM DOES- ACADEMY
ALREADY WE ARE GOING TO COLLEGE
ACADEMY OR PERHAPS L. A. P. YOU
CAN RECEIVE DATA SHARES THEY
MAY NOT REQUIRE THAT LEVEL OF
TRAINING SO I THINK SETTING THE
MINIMUM STANDARDS IS THE
WAITING I DON'T KNOW WHAT A
MINIMUM STANDARDS SHOULD BE
RAISED IS A DIFFERENT
DISCUSSION BUT BEING ABLE TO
TAILOR THE CURRICULUM I THINK
IS VERY VERY IMPORTANT- HE SAID
YEAH COLLEGE OF THE REDWOODS
THERE WAS SOME DISCUSSION
ABOUT- CULTURAL DIVERSITY AND-
ADDRESSING- THE NATIVE
AMERICAN. COMMUNITY AND WORKING
WITH THE NATIVE AMERICAN
COMMUNITY- THEY- THE RESULT
RISK PART OF THAT COMMUNITY
EIGHT IN- IN ORDER TO. THAT
MAIN BE. THE BEST TRAINING FOR
LAPD IT MAY NOT BE I MEAN IT
MAY NOT BE BAD TREATING BUT-
THEY MAY WANT TO TAILOR IT TO
SOME OTHER. OTHERCOMMUNITY
THAT IS- MORE PREDOMINATE IN
THE CITY OF LOS ANGELES- STERN-
SO ACADEMIES DO LANGUAGE
TRADING I BELIEVE SOMETHING
SPANISH LANGUAGE TRAINING. WELL
IN YOU KNOW THE PRESIDENT-
FRESNO POLICE DEPARTMENT WANTS
TO DO- LANGUAGE TRAINING IN A
DIFFERENT LANGUAGE SUCH AS- YOU
KNOW. WHATEVER IT MAY BE I
THINK THEY SHOULD HAVE THAT
OPPORTUNITY SO I THINK IT'S
GOOD TO HAVE MINIMUM STANDARDS
AND LET THEM TAKE RIGHT THAT'S
JUST MY OPINION. THANK YOU VERY
MUCH I HAVE ONE ADDITIONAL
QUESTION FOR YOU AND THAT I
HAVE BECAUSE MY COLLEAGUES YOU
STILL HAVE THE OPPORTUNITY TO
TEXT ME SECOND PLACE IN THE
QUEUE. I WANT TO GO TO MISS
LANCE- IN A FEW MOMENTS WHY
FANCY THIS LAST QUESTION. DOES
TRAINING HIGHLIGHTS THE
IMPORTANCE OF TRUST BETWEEN LAW
ENFORCEMENT AND CIVILIAN AND
LET ME- UP REPEAT THE QUESTION
AGAIN AND THEN I'LL MAKE A
COMMENT DOES TRAINING
HIGHLIGHTS THE IMPORTANCE OF
TRUST. BETWEEN LAW ENFORCEMENT
AND CIVILIANS OR THAT OR THE
COMMUNITY- AND SO WHEN I WAS IN
THE CITY OF MAY WOULD- CALL OLD
SCHOOL WHATEVER YOU WANNA CALL
IT- OUR CHIEF LIEUTENANT.
CAPTAIN THEY REQUIRED US TO GET
OUT OF THE BOX GET OUT OF THE
CAR. AND MEET THE NEIGHBORS WE
DID COMMUNITY BASED POLICING.
AS I SAID BEFORE I KNEW THE
RODRIGUEZ FAMILY AND I KNEW
WHAT KIDS WANT TO RODRIGUEZ
FAMILIES AND THE GOOD THEY THE
GARCIA FAMILY AND SO YOU AND WE
KNEW EACH OTHER BY NAME. AND SO
THERE WAS A LEVEL OF RESPECT
THAT WHAT ON BOTH SIDES WHEN I
WAS THERE. SO AGAIN THE
QUESTION IS DOES THE TRAINING
HIGHLIGHT THE IMPORTANCE OF
TRUST BETWEEN THE LAW
ENFORCEMENT. AND CIVILIAN AND
OUR COMMUNITY. YES IT DOES IT
DOES IMPOSE THE ACADEMY. IT
DOESN'T FEEL TRAINING IT
DOESN'T VARIOUS INSERVICE
TRAINING COURSES. I TOUCHED ON
THE TINY ARMS AND WEARING THEIR
MAIN THREE. WHICH IS- PRINCIPLE
POLICING IN THE COMMUNITY IT
ADDRESSES THOSE TOPICS PACIFIC
ME. ON THE FIELD TRAINING
MANUAL WHICH I BELIEVE YOU CAN
FIND ONLINE ALSO ADDRESSES
THOSE TOPICS. IN SERVICE
TRAINING IN TERMS OF LEADERSHIP
TRAINING THAT WE PROVIDE. IN
TERMS OF. AB FIRST PERSONAL
JUSTICE IMPLICIT BIAS TRAINING
SPECIFICALLY TALKS ABOUT- TRUST
IN THE COMMUNITY AND WHY TIMES
THERE IS MISTRUST AND- TRYING
TO WORK ON IMPROVING THAT. WE
RECENTLY- ISSUE ESCALATION GUY
I BELIEVE THEY WERE ISSUE IN
AUGUST. OF THIS YEAR AS WELL AS
USE OF FORCE STANDARDS AND
GUIDELINES PURSUANT TO EIGHTY
THREE NINETY TWO AND SB TWO
THIRTY. AND BOTH OF THOSE
DOCUMENTS ADDRESS COMMUNITY
TRUST AND HOW TO- THE
IMPORTANCE OF COMMUNITY TRUST
AND HOW TO WORK ON IMPROVING
COMMUNITY TRUST. SO I BELIEVE
WE DO IN TERMS OF TRADING AS
WELL AS IN PUBLICATIONS ON IT
WE REGULARLY PUT OUT. THANK YOU
VERY MUCH- MISS LANCE THANK YOU
AGAIN FIRST I'M STAYING HERE
AND- ANSWERING SOME OTHER
FOLLOW UP QUESTIONS AND AGAIN
MEMBERS- IF YOU. WANT TO PLEASE
LET ME KNOW AND I'LL PUT YOU IN
THE QUEUE- WHAT WOULD YOU DO
WHAT CAN WE DO BETTER. IF YOU
CAN GIVE ME THREE POINTS
BECAUSE YOU COME FROM A
DIFFERENT LANDS AS A COMMUNITY
BUT I ALSO WANT TO MAKE-
REFERENCE AN UNDERSCORE. YOUR
WILLINGNESS TO ONE GO TO THE
ACADEMY TO DO RIDE ALONGS AND
ALSO GO TO THE ASSEMBLY
TRAININGS AND THINGS OF THAT
NATURE- AS A CITIZEN HERE IN
SACRAMENTO. SO YOU'VE DONE ALL
THAT WHAT THREE POINTS WOULD
YOU WANT TO LEAVE WITH US THAT
WE SOULD BE LOOKING AT- FROM
WHAT FROM YOUR LANDS TO MAKE- A
REIMAGINING LAW ENFORCEMENT
CALIFORNIA DOES THAT MAKE SENSE.
SO IF I MAY REAL QUICK I ALSO
HAVE SIXTEEN HOURS OF POST
CERTIFICATION TRAINING UP. THAT
I RECEIVED OUT AT THE ACADEMY-
SO JUST FOR A LITTLE CLARITY ON
YOUR QUESTION ARE YOU ASKING MY
OPINION FROM A LEGISLATIVE
PERSPECTIVE OR FROM AN OVERALL
COMMUNITY. YEAH COMMITTEE
PERSPECTIVE PLEASE SO- NUMBER
ONE I THINK THAT WE MUST BE
COGNITIVE AND AWARE OF THE TRUE
HISTORY IN THIS COUNTRY MMHM
RELATED TO RACE RELATIONS AND
HOW IT IMPACTS LAW ENFORCEMENT.
NUMBER TWO THAT WE MUST BEGIN
TO BRIDGE THE GAP BETWEEN THE
US VERSUS THEM MENTALITY THAT
WE CANNOT CONTINUE TO. OTHER
ONE ANOTHER THAT IT IS LAW
ENFORCEMENT COMMUNITY AND THEN
THERE IS THE CIVILIAN
COMMUNITY- BECAUSE WITHIN THAT
THERE'S TWO DIFFERENT
COMMUNITIES THERE'S THE AFRICAN
AMERICAN LATINO AND OR
IMPOVERISHED COMMUNITY AND THEN
THERE IS THE WHITE COMMUNITY-
AND SO WE MUST BE MINDFUL THAT.
A LOT OF WHAT WE ARE TALKING
ABOUT THE ROOT OF IT ALL IS OUR
BONDING AGENT OF HUMANITY THAT
WE ARE ALL HUMAN BEINGS AND
ONCE WE CAN BEGIN TO SHAPE THE
LANGUAGE. THAT HELPS TO
FORMULATE THE THOUGHT PROCESSES
THAT CHANGES THE OVERALL
PERCEPTION THAT WE ARE ALL. ONE
HUMAN RACE- I THINK THAT WE'RE
GOING TO CONTINUE TO HAVE THESE
PROBLEMS AND SO WE CAN CONTINUE
TO GO ROUND AND ROUND AND HAVE
CONVERSATIONS ABOUT THE
NECESSITY FOR POLICE REFORM BUT
AGAIN AS I SAID- SOME OF THESE
THINGS DON'T NEED TO BE
REFORMED THEY NEED TO BE
DECONSTRUCTED. AND THEY NEED TO
BE RECONSTRUCTED INTO A SYSTEM
THAT IS MORE INCLUSIVE OF
EVERYONE- AND WE CANNOT FORGET
THE FACT THAT- WE S. PEOPLE OF
COLOR IN THIS COUNTRY HAVE BEEN
RELEGATED TO THE DARK CORNERS
OF BEING CRIMINALIZED BASED ON
OUR MERE EXISTENCE IN THIS
SOCIO ECONOMIC SOCIETY THAT A
LOT OF WHAT WE DEAL WITH HAS
BEEN SOCIALLY CONSTRUCTED TO BE
THAT WAY. AND THE MINDSETS OF
THE PEOPLE NEED TO BE RE SHAPED
AND RE FASHION TO UNDERSTAND
THAT A PART OF THAT IS BEING
INCLUSIVE OF ON ITS HISTORY.
WELL THANK YOU VERY MUCH WE
APPRECIATE YOUR COMMENTS- WITH
THAT BEING SAID- I WANT TO- WE
WANT AT THIS POINT TIME WE WANT
TO GO INTO OUR- OUR PUBLIC
COMMENTS- SEGMENT OF THE
ARGENTA. BUT BEFORE WE DO THAT
I WANT TO THANK YOU AGAIN EVERY
PRESENTER EVERY MEMBER EVERYONE
WHO WOULD LEND THEIR VOICES- IN
THIS CONVERSATION IS ABSOLUTELY
CRITICAL- THE YOUR VOICE IT IS
A FACT THE CONNECTICUT IN THIS
PROCESS I WANT TO SAY THANK YOU
VERY VERY MUCH. NOW WE WILL GO
TO- THE PUBLIC I WOULD ASK THAT
ANYONE FROM THE COMMUNITY TO
LAUGH WE HAVE TWO MINUTES
DURING THIS SEGMENT TO PLEASE
APPROACH THE MICROPHONE THAT'S
BEHIND THE PLEXIGLASS PLEASE DO
NOT TOUCH THE MICROPHONE WE
WILL. ADJUSTED TO YOUR
SPECIFICATION- SO THAT YOU CAN-
SPEAK. WE WOULD ALSO INSTRUCT
YOU THAT YOU CAN FEEL FREE TO
LEAVE I'M AFTER YOU FINISH YOUR
pCOMMENTS AND WE'LL HAVE WILL
ESCORT YOU OUT OF THE BUILDING
BECAUSE OF COLD IF WE WANT TO
MAKE SURE EVERYONE IS. IS
PROTECTED- AND INTO OR YOU CAN
JUST FEEL FREE TO HAVE A SEAT
AND WE CAN ALL LIVE TOGETHER AT
AT ONE TIME AND WE WANT TO ALSO
MAKE MENTION TO AN ELEVATOR
WHAT ONE PERSON ELEVATOR AT A
TIME SO WITH THAT BEING SAID.
THE PUBLIC PORTION OF THIS
HEARING IS OPEN FOR TWO
MINUTES. OF MISLED. SO THIS IS
KIND OF OFF SUBJECT BUT I THINK
IT IS STILL RELEVANT-
YESTERDAY. THANK YOU ASSEMBLY
MEMBER CARTY WE WERE OUT FRONT
AND WE WERE HAVING A PRESS
CONFERENCE IN REGARDING TO KEEP
THE SEAT. THE SENATE SEAT FORCE
US INTO QUALIFIERS- WHAT WE
TALK ABOUT SYSTEMIC RACISM IN
THE THINGS THAT WE HAVE SEEN
GROWING IN OUR COUNTRY FOR
HUNDREDS OF YEARS BUT MORE
SPECIFICALLY SINCE THE KILLING
OF GEORGE FLOYD- WE TALK ABOUT
ACCOUNTABILITY TRANSPARENCY- I
THINK THAT IT IT. WE ARE AT A
PIVOTAL MOMENT IN CALIFORNIA'S
HISTORY RIGHT NOW WHERE. WHILE
WE TALK ABOUT ACCOUNTABILITY
ESPECIALLY AROUND LAW
ENFORCEMENT I WOULD LIKE TO
ENCOURAGE ALL OF YOU AS I WILL
CONTINUE TO DO SO THAT WE
CONTINUE TO SUPPORT PEOPLE IN
POSITIONS WHO REPRESENT US WHO
ARE WHO HAVE A PROVEN TRACK
RECORD OF ACCOUNTABILITY- AND
SO I AM ASKING YOU ALL. TO
SUPPORT ME AND SUPPORTING PAUL
HENDERSON FOR THE ATTORNEY
GENERAL'S POSITION AS THE TOP
COP IN THE STATE OF CALIFORNIA
IT IS IMPORTANT THAT WE ALSO
HAVE REPRESENTATION WHO LOOK
LIKE US BUT NOT JUST LOOK LIKE
US BECAUSE EVERYONE WHO LOOKS
LIKE US DOESN'T NECESSARILY.
THINK LIKE WE DO- I THINK THAT
IS VERY IMPORTANT THAT WE AS WE
TRANSITION AND WE CONTINUE AND
WE'RE GETTING READY TO WELCOME
IN A NEW PRESIDENT- AND VICE
PRESIDENT THAT IS MORE
REFLECTIVE OF WHAT I BELIEVE
THE OVERALL AMERICAN PEOPLE ARE
LOOKING FOR THAT WE IN
CALIFORNIA CONTINUE ON THAT
TRAJECTORY AS WELL. AND SO I'M
ASKING THAT YOU ALL AS MEMBERS-
OF CALIFORNIA STATE ASSEMBLY
SUPPORT ME IN SUPPORTING PAUL
HENDERSON AS THE NEXT ATTORNEY
GENERAL. THANK YOU VERY MUCH DO
WE HAVE ANOTHER MEMBER OF THE
PUBLIC WHO WISHED TO ADDRESS
THE BODY. THANK YOU VERY MUCH
PLEASE ARMS BEHIND THE
PLEXIGLAS AND THE NEED A
MICROPHONE REYES WILL BE MORE
THAN HAPPY TO DO THAT PLEASE
STATE YOUR NAME. BUT I SPECIAL
BANKING- COULD NOT PROVIDE
MENTAL ONE SHERMAN GIPSON AND
ALL THE MEMBERS OF THE-
COMMITTEE- THE MONEY. OKAY
HELLO WE'LL WE'LL JUST A MONTH
OKAY. FIND A VERY GOOD IF WE
GOT MAYES ALL. GERMAN GIPSON
AND I'M GONNA MEMBERS OF THE
COMMITTEE- ON. THAT SAY HOW
HAPPY I AM TO BE SPEAKING WITH
YOU I'D LIKE TO SAY. THANK YOU
SO MUCH TO THE ON SECOND
SHERIFF'S DEPARTMENT- THEY ARE
SUCH HEROES I CANNOT SAY ENOUGH
GOOD THINGS ABOUT THEM ALL THE
GOOD MEN AND WOMEN IN THE
SEGMENTS AS DEPARTMENTS INSPIRE
ME EVERY SINGLE DAY WITH THEIR
CARS AND FIRE THEY HAVE IN
THEIR HEARTS- SACRAMENTO PD-
RANCHO CORDOVA POLICE
DEPARTMENT HER HEROES YOU KNOW
THEY INSPIRE ME EVERY SINGLE
DAY AND I THINK THAT'S WHAT
GOOD MEN AND WOMEN DO NOT PLACE
TO FIND YOU KNOW THEY- THEY
BASICALLY LIMIT THE PAST ME
TOWARDS TREATED AND SO
SUPPORTED ME FOR THINGS I MEAN
GOING TO ACT. YOU KNOW HOW
DESPERATE I FEEL LIKE I'M NOT
GOOD ENOUGH TO EAT ME SPEAK
INTERNET NOW OKAY I'M NOT GONNA
SAY THAT IF YOU ALLOW ME PLACES
FAILED MISERABLY. AND SAY HOW
MUCH YOU KNOW ABOUT HERO YOUR
CHIEF FINANCE AND- I ALSO WAS
HOPING I COULD SMACK YOU SAY
THAT ON THE CHEEK OF SOMEONE AS
BEAUTIFUL WOMAN WHO ARE SERVING
OUR COMMUNITY SHE IS PROUD MOST
WHEN WAS BEAUTIFUL WOMEN
WHOEVER LIVES AND I'M SO
HONORED TO BE ABLE TO SPEAK
ABOUT HER I'M NOT GONNA STEVEN
SAY HER NAME. I'LL BE ON THE
HOUSE AND I'M SURE YOU ALL CAN
AGREE WITH ME THAT YOU KNOW I
DON'T ACTUALLY HE SAID I KNOW
FOR SURE FOR CERTAIN AND SHE'S
UP IN HEAVEN RIGHT. NOW LOOKING
DOWN ON US AND JUST. THE PRICE
BLESSING ALL IT'S- ARE. YOU
KNOW I KNOW SHE- STARTED- EARLY
EDUCATE. SHE'S A HERO TO ME AND
I'M SO. I FEEL SO BLESSED BE
ABLE TO SAY. STATE TO SPEAK
ABOUT HER. NANA I'M SO PROUD OF
HER. AND I CAN'T SAY GOOD
THINGS ABOUT HER MORE SHE MUST
ONE MUST BE WOMEN I DON'T KNOW
A MOTHER. MOTHERS ARE HEROES
TAKES LIKE FOR RACED. YEAH
HIRVONEN MINISTER. AROUND YOU
KNOW THERE'S BEEN SOME AND
NATURAL WITH MANTA STE GIVE ME
A HARD TIME NOW WITH KANTAR
NANOTECHNOLOGY WHATNOT ANNA
RADIOS AND STUFF LIKE THAT GIVE
ME A HARD TIME FOR. FACT OVER
FIVE YEARS BUT YOU KNOW WHAT I
WAS GONNA SAY. THAT I'M I'M
CLAIMING THE FIRST MINUTE YOU
KNOW FRIEDMAN MY FREEDOM OF
CONSCIENCE AND FREEDOM. RIGHT
I'M ARGUING IS BASICALLY OUT
RIGHT TO A- PROVIDE PRIVACY
WHICH I THINK OUR FOUNDING
FATHERS WOULD EVEN HAVE A STATE
ARE YOU. SEE YOU KNOW- NAY.
ARGUMENTS ABOUT THE TIME. ON
CRIME IN THE MY ARGUED
WHICHEVER TO PRIVACY BROWN BODY.
DOWN TREES A SIMPLE YOU KNOW
HOW MEN AND- COME TO EACH OTHER
WHEN I READ. STE AND ON. I'M
ALSO A CLEANING ATTACHMENT TO
IN KNOW NOT BE ABLE TO TALK TO.
IF THEY WANT TO ME- I'M ALSO
GOING TO FIT THE MOMENT A- YOU
KNOW. HI THIS PROPERTY SKINNER
YOU HAVE THIRTIES. TO FINISH A
PRIVATE. ON SHOULD NOT BE USED
FOR. USE AND- I'M CLAIMING UP
FOR THAT IF FOR ALL THIS FOR MY
WOMAN. YOU KNOW WHO LET ME LET
ME PERFECTLY. I'M COMING OUT
FOR MY CHILDREN AND I. I'M
CLAIMING THAT FOR ALL THE CHARM
THIS TOWN- I'M COMING UP FOR
ALL THE CHILDREN. AND I'M GOING
OUT FOR ALL THE POLICEMEN AND
WOMEN. AND ALL THEIR CHILDREN.
AND I WOULD JUST LIKE TO SAY
THE IMAGE OF ALL THEIR CHILDREN
ARE PER THE WAY THAT THEY MIGHT
NOT YOU THE. GOD MAN I'M- GONNA.
AND I ALSO I WOULD LIKE TO SAY.
ENZYMES CAN HELP FOR. YOU KNOW
HAS A- WITH. I CAN. TO FUNCTION.
OF THEM. SEPARATE CURRENT AMPLE.
CONCERNS RIGHT. THE LECTURE
SITTING. HELP AND IT'S STILL
GOING. CAN HELP- PROTECTION AND
REYES HOW BEYOND REPAIR THEY
GOT ME. YES I WILL. THANK YOU
FOR. VERY AND WE- YOUR COMMENTS.
ME JUST. SAY YOU ARE. SIGNATURE
AND THANK YOU VERY MUCH FOR.
INVOKING THE NAME OF A MISS
O'SULLIVAN. REPRESENTED THESE
SACRAMENTO PD AND- MAY GOD REST
HER SOUL SO THANK YOU VERY
MUCH. DO WE HAVE. ADDITIONAL
MEMBERS OF THE PUBLIC. THAT
WISHING TO SPEAK AND ADDRESS
THIS BODY. PLEASE STEP TO THE
MICROPHONE. PLEASE PROCEED
THANK YOU VERY MUCH. YEAH TWO
MINUTES. GOOD MORNING MEMBERS.
MY NAME IS RYAN HARRISON I AM
THE GENERAL COUNSEL- NORTHERN
CALIFORNIA GENERAL COUNSEL FOR
THE CALIFORNIA. ASSOCIATION OF
BLACK LAWYERS. I WANNA COME YOU
GUYS ON THE DISK. TODAY A LOT
OF GOOD MATERIAL- WAS DISCUSSED
AND- OUR ORGANIZATIONS-
CONTINUES TO STAND READY AND
WILLING TO WORK WITH YOU GUYS
ON POLICE REFORM IN THE STATE
OF CALIFORNIA. AND PART OF THAT
THEM. REFORM MOVEMENT INCLUDES
THE ATTORNEY GENERAL- POSITION
NOW THAT THE CALIFORNIA
ASSOCIATION OF BLACK LAWYERS
HAS DISPATCHED. A SHORT LIST OF.
HIGH LEVEL CONTENDER FOR THIS
POSITION- TO THE LEGISLATIVE
BLACK CAUCUS AND WE LOOK
FORWARD TO THE ULTIMATE
DECISION- BY THE GOVERNOR FOR
THAT POSITION THANK YOU. THANK
YOU VERY MUCH FOR YOUR COMMENTS.
HI MY NAME IS MARISSA MORALIS-
JUST WANNA THINK JIMMY LOVE FOR
WRITING YOU TO BE HERE THANK
YOU GUYS ON FOR HOSTING THIS.
THIS COMMITTEE- FIRST OF ALL OF
THAT I HAVE HIGH HARSH
PERSPECTIVE REGARD FOR LAW
ENFORCEMENT SO I'M GLAD TO BE A
PART OF THIS TOPIC- I KNOW THAT
LAW ENFORCEMENT IS A IT'S A
VERY VERY DIFFICULT JOB IT'S
HARD SALUTE. PLEASE TAKE MY
COMMENTS IN MY- SUGGESTIONS YOU
KNOW WITH RESPECT NOT TO BE
DISRESPECTFUL OR ANYTHING- BUT-
IN REGARDS TO THE- EDUCATION
PIECE AND THE TRAINING PIECE-
BEING A WAY TO BUILD TRUST
BETWEEN LAW ENFORCEMENT AND
COMMUNITY. I DON'T THINK THAT
THAT IS THE ANSWER ALTHOUGH
EDUCATION IS GOOD AND SHOULD
ALWAYS BE ENCOURAGED. YOU KNOW
IT'S ALL ABSOLUTELY ENCOURAGED-
I DON'T THINK THAT'S THE ANSWER
I THINK THAT THE ANSWER IS
ACCOUNTABILITY OF OUR LAW
ENFORCEMENT AND OUR CIVILIANS
ALIKE. IF THERE IS YOU KNOW IF
A LAW WAS BROKEN OR EXCESSIVE
FORCE IS USED. THEY SHOULD BE
HELD ACCOUNTABLE SO I THINK
ACCOUNTABILITY IS THE FIRST
THING THAT WILL BUILD TRUST
WITH THE COMMUNITY AND LAW
ENFORCEMENT SECOND IS GETTING
TO KNOW US GETTING FINALISED-
BECAUSE THERE IS A DISCONNECT
RIGHT NOW. AND AS OF RIGHT NOW
IF YOU DON'T KNOW SOMEBODY. YOU
DON'T KNOW YOUR COMMUNITY
YOU'RE LESS LIKELY TO ACTUALLY
PROTECT AND TO SERVE THEM IF
YOU DON'T EVEN KNOW WHAT THEIR
NEEDS ARE- AND AGAIN IT CREATES
THE US VERSUS THEM MENTALITY
BECAUSE YOU FEAR. WHAT OR WHO
YOU DON'T KNOW SO I THINK
THAT'S NEEDS IT THAT'S KEY.
ALSO- WITH THE EDUCATIONAL
PIECE REQUIREMENT IT CAN. MAKE
IT HARDER FOR MINORITIES TO
MOVE UP THE SOCIAL MOBILITY
LADDER SO I THINK THAT'S
ANOTHER REASON WHY YOU'RE NOT
MAKING IT A REQUIREMENT- BUT I
DO LIKE THE TWO YEARS THAT YOU
KNOW CHIEF HAN HAS IMPLEMENTED
AND THAT THE AGENT CREASE-
ANOTHER THING SUGGESTION THAT I
HAVE FOR OUR AFFECT PD. AND
ESPECIALLY BECAUSE IT SEEMS
LIKE WE'VE DONE THINGS REALLY
GREAT THUS FAR HOWEVER. THEY'RE
STILL AB- THERE'S STILL A
PROBLEM WITH POLICE KILLING OUR
COMMUNITY MEMBERS AND SOUL WHAT
I WOULD LIKE TO SEE IS
SITUATIONAL AWARENESS-
ASSESSMENT TESTING I'M SURE
GOES ON IN THE ACADEMY BUT IT
NEEDS TO GO ON THROUGHOUT LIKE
THE WHAT WOULD YOU DO CASE
SCENARIOS SO IF THIS IF THIS
TYPE OF THING WAS TO HAPPEN IF
THERE'S A CRISIS SITUATION HOW
WOULD THEY HANDLE IT SO THAT
THEY'RE- THINKING BEFORE THEY
ACT SO THAT THEY CAN ACTUALLY.
TAKE A MOMENT TO THINK IF IN
THIS SITUATION IF THERE'S A
PERSON WHO WAS ARMED HOW SHOULD
I REACT VERSUS JUST. YOU KNOW
REACTING BY SHOOTING- YOU KNOW
JUST HAVE YEAH JUST MAKE IT
MORE SITUATIONAL AWARENESS
ASSESSMENT AND SO THAT WOULD BE
MY SUGGESTION IS TO HAVE MORE
CASE SCENARIOS AND- THINGS OF
THAT NATURE THANK YOU. THANK
YOU VERY MUCH FOR YOUR COMMENT
I WILL GO TO THE MODERATOR
MODERATE- IS THERE ANYONE ON
THE LINE WISHING TO BE HEARD
DURING THE PUBLIC COMMENT
SECTION. THANK YOU CHAIR LADIES
AND GENTLEMEN THE FARM LANDS IF
YOU WOULD LIKE TO MAKE A PUBLIC
COMMENT AT THIS TIME. PLEASE
PRESS ONE FOLLOWED BY THE ZERO
DOWN AT T. OPERATOR WILL GIVE
YOUR LIGHT NUMBER OFFLINE SO
YOU CAN ASK YOUR QUESTION AGAIN
PLEASE PRESS ONE ZERO. TO ASK
YOUR QUESTION OVER THE PHONE
LINE. AND WE WILL GO TO LINE
NINETEEN PLEASE GO AHEAD. I
COMMITTEE AND- MISTER
CHAIRPERSON BEER LUCIEN NEAR ON
BEHALF OF THE- SAN FRANCISCO.
POLICE OFFICERS ASSOCIATION WHO
REGRETS THAT THEY- THINK ONE
ABLE TO ADJUST TO THE- THE
RESCHEDULE TIME FRAME BUT- BUT
NONETHELESS WANTED TO. CONVEY A
FEW COMMENTS THROUGH ME-
REGARDING- THIS THESE IMPORTANT
TOPICS. I PERSONALLY FORMAL- I
THINK THEY WANTED TO CONVEY
THAT YOU CAN WAITING A LONG
TIME TO HAVE A COMPREHENSIVE
CONVERSATION. ABOUT REFORMS
RATHER THAN THE BILL BY BILL
APPROACH SO MISTER CHAIRMAN WE
ABSOLUTELY APPRECIATE YOUR
WORKING YOUR DILIGENCE TO BRING
ALL PARTIES TO THE TABLE ON
THIS- AND ALL THE COMMITTEE
MEMBERS AS WELL- ONE OF THE
STATE- BELIEVE VERY IMPORTANT.
TO BE VERY IMPORTANT AND VERY
STRONGLY IN. THE IDEA OF
ONGOING TRAINING- REALLY SORT
OF BRANDING THAT UP IN A WAY.
THAT JUST REALLY HADN'T BEEN
PREVIOUSLY DISCUSSED. THE
IMPORTANCE OF PERISHABLE SKILLS
AND DOUBLING DOWN ON ENSURING
THAT THOSE SKILLS ARE ARE KEPT-
IN BETWEEN COULD TOP SHAPE. SO
THAT OFFICERS WHEN THEY GET
INTO THE MOMENT- BETTER VERY
TENSE WHERE SOME INCOMING IS
WHERE THEY JUST. SIMPLY DO NOT
HAVE ENOUGH TIME TO THINK- THAT
DATE OF BIRTH SHE QUALITY
TRAINING. THAT PRODUCES THE
BEST OUTCOMES POSSIBLE- AND WE
BELIEVE THAT THERE SHOULD BE
MUCH MORE OUR ONGOING
DISCUSSION ABOUT SPECIFICS OF
ONGOING TRAINING. INCLUDING BUT
NOT LIMITED TO. YES GOING SOME
OF THE OTHER THING- WERE
DISCUSS AND THEN THE SECOND
THING THAT- WHAT IMPORTANT TO
KNOW. IF IDEA OF EARLY POSITIVE
INTERACTIONS- THERE'S AN
INTEREST IN FIGURING OUT HOW WE
INSTITUTIONALIZE THAT STATEWIDE
THERE ARE A NUMBER OF THE
EARLIER- COMMENTATORS WHO
SUGGESTED. THAT YOU KNOW THE
SIGNIFICANCE AND IMPORTANCE OF
STARTING EARLY. ON WE'VE
ENTERED ENVIRONMENT HERE WHERE
YOU KNOW THERE ARE SOME SCHOOL
BOARDS ACROSS THE STATE WHO
ARE. EIGHTEEN LAW ENFORCEMENT
OUT OF SCHOOL- AND PRECLUDING
OPPORTUNITIES TO HAVE VERY
EARLY POSITIVE IN- INTERACTIONS
WITH STUDENTS. I KNOW
PERSONALLY MYSELF FOR THE-
ELEMENTARY SCHOOL- KIDDING-
WHEN WAS. THE L. A. COUNTY
SHERIFF'S OFFICE USED IN THE
DEADLY BY- YOU KNOW EVERY OTHER
WEEK TO YOU KNOW COME READ TO
THE CLASS AT THE TALK ABOUT
THEIR PROFESSION- SO I HAD. WE
HAD THE BENEFIT OF IN ADDITION
TO BEING SURROUNDED B FAMILY
MEMBERS WHO WERE LAW
ENFORCEMENT BUT HAVE A
SIMILARLY POSITIVE INTERACTION.
INTEL I THINK WE WOULD WE WOULD
CONCUR WITH THAT- LOOK FOR
OPPORTUNITIES TO GROW THOSE
INTERACTIONS- BUT OBVIOUSLY THE
DYNAMIC AT PLAY- OVER THE LAST
FEW MONTHS IT MADE THAT
CHALLENGING INTEL. OR HOPEFUL
TO- TO DISCUSS A LITTLE BIT
MORE ABOUT INSTITUTIONALIZING
ARE POSITIVE INTERACTIONS AND
ENGAGEMENTS WITH THE PUBLIC SO
THAT WHEN. POLICE ARE CALLED
IT'S MORE THAN JUST SOMEONE'S
IN TROUBLE- YOU AGAIN THAT'S ON
BEHALF OF THE SAN FRANCISCO-
POLICE OFFICERS ASSOCIATION I
THANK YOU VERY MUCH MISS JIM.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH FOR YOUR
COMMENTS. MY IS A ANYONE ON THE
ELSE ON THE LINE. WE DO HAVE
ANOTHER QUEUED UP AND- JUSTIFY
REMINDER PLEASE PRESS ONE ZERO
FOR PUBLIC COMMENT ONE THIRTEEN
PLEASE GO AHEAD. YES HI MY NAME
IS MISTY JONES I LIVE IN
SACRAMENTO CALIFORNIA I'M FROM
SAN FRANCISCO. AND MY QUESTION
IS IF I KEEP TALKING ABOUT
TRAINING AND SOMEONE MENTIONED
ABOUT QUICK DECISIONS WHEN
THEY'RE- MURDERING PEOPLE
SHOOTING PEOPLE. ABOUT WHAT WAS
11-3 THERE THREE DAYS AGO
SACRAMENTO PD IN CONNECTION
WITH THE H. P. JUST MURDERED A
MAN AFTER PUBLICLY THE
ESCALATING FOR TWENTY MINUTES
THIS MAN HAD AROUND. IF IT'S
RATED NIGHT THIS MAN WAS IN A
MENTAL HEALTH CRISIS. THEY SHOT
HIM TO HELP THAT A QUICK
DECISION MADE WHEN THEY SPENT.
PROBABLY TWENTY MINUTES.
TALKING TO THE MAN. IN A MENTAL
HEALTH CRISIS AND IT'S STILL
MURDERED THIS MAN HOW DOES THAT
A QUICK DECISION THAT ALL OF IN
A MATTER OF QUICK DECISIONS
THEY COULDN'T. THEY COULDN'T
LOOK ARM THE MAN IN A MENTAL
HEALTH CRISIS. WELL I'M I'M
CONFUSED BY WHAT PEOPLE ARE
SAYING ABOUT. THINGS LIKE THAT
WHEN THEY'RE MAKING COMMENTS
ABOUT THESE QUICK DECISION AND
THEY'RE GOING TO THEY'RE NOT
GOING TO. HAPPEN THESE OFFICERS
THAT SPENT ALL THIS TIME
BUILDING A REPERTOIRE WITH THIS
MAN IN A CRISIS AND THEN THE
BILL MURDERED HIM AND THAT'S
JUST HAPPENED. SACRAMENTO IT
JUST HAPPENED. SACRAMENTO YEAH
THAT WOULD BE COULD YOU CALL IN
ANY ELSE ONE THAT IS IN.
ENFORCEMENT AND ALLOW YOUR ALL.
TO MURDER PEOPLE RIGHT NOW
DURING A UP. AGAINST THE
VIOLENCE. THANK YOU VERY MUCH
FOR COMMENT. OPERATORS ANYONE
ELSE AND IN THE QUEUE ON THE
LINE WAITING TO BE HEARD. NOT
AT THIS TIME MISTER CHAIR.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH WE WILL AT
THIS POINT CLOSE THE PUBLIC
COMMENT PORTION- LET ME JUST
SIMPLY SAY THIS I WANT TO THANK
ALL OF OUR SPEAKERS FOR
PROVIDING THEIR THOUGHTFUL
INSIGHT ON THESE IMPORTANT
TOPICS MY COLLEAGUES AND I ARE
HERE BECAUSE WE SHARE THE SAME
COMMITMENT INTO RESTORING THE
TRUST BETWEEN LAW ENFORCEMENT
AND THE COMMUNITIES. WE SERVE
IN OUR PERSPECTIVE DISTRICTS I
WANT TO THANK ALL OF THEM FOR
PARTICIPATING ON THE SELECT
COMMITTEE HEARING- ONE REMIND
EVERYONE ON FRIDAY. THIS FRIDAY
WHICH IS THE EIGHTEENTH OF
DECEMBER WE HAVE OUR NEXT
HEARING AND WE'LL BE DISCUSSING
DISCIPLINARY DISCIPLINE AS WELL
THE DISCIPLINE PROCESS AND
LITIGATION I. ALSO LIKE TO
REMIND EVERYONE THAT THE
COMMITTEE WILL BE MAKING
RECOMMENDATIONS ON ALL OF THESE
TOPICS WE DISCUSS- HERE IN THIS
HEARING SO PLEASE UNDERSTAND
THAT THIS IS- A MULTI PRONGED
APPROACH WE WANT TO GET
DIFFERENT PERSPECTIVES AND
EVERYBODY LETTING THEIR VOICES
AND SO THAT WE CAN MAKE SOME
VERY CONCRETE RECOMMENDATIONS
MOVING FORWARD. I WANT TO
POSSIBLE AND ASK ANY OF MY
COLLEAGUES WHO ARE PRESENT IN
THE MEETING ROOM IF THEY HAVE
ANY CLOSING REMARKS. HOURS ARE
WOOD MISTER MCCARTY. MISTER
LACKEY MISS RUBIO PLEASE GO
RIGHT AHEAD THANK YOU- THIS IS
NOT BEEN AND- EXTREMELY EYE
OPENING OPPORTUNITY I THINK FOR
ALL OF US TO HAVE REAL
CONVERSATIONS ON HOW WE CAN
MOVE FORWARD AGAIN I JUST WANT
TO REITERATE THAT IF WE'RE NOT
GOING TO COME UP WITH. SOME
SOLUTIONS REAL SOLUTIONS TO
THIS THEN I THINK WE'RE JUST
WASTING OUR TIME BUT TODAY FELT
LIKE WE WERE MOVING ON THE TO
RIGHT DIRECTION AND OPENING UP
THOSE CONVERSATIONS THAT HAVE
TO BE HAD. IT'S NOT ONE- ONE.
WAY OF FIXING THIS I THINK WE
ALL HAVE TO COME TOGETHER AND
FIGURE OUT HOW ALL OF THESE
COMPONENTS. ARE WE'RE GOING TO
BE A PUT TOGETHER AND I WANT TO
THANK YOU MISTER CHAIR FOR
REITERATING THAT AND- HOPEFULLY
WHEN WE COME OUT OF THIS WEEK
YOU KNOW I DON'T CLAIM TO BE
ABLE TO FIX EVERYTHING BUT AT
LEAST TAKE THE STEPS IN THE
RIGHT DIRECTION SO THAT WE CAN
ALL COME TOGETHER AND FEEL
SAFE. WHEN WE'RE DEALING WITH
OUR LAW ENFORCEMENT. COMMUNITY
AND FOR THOSE OF US TO FEEL
SAFE IN OUR COMMUNITIES AS WELL
BECAUSE WE ARE BEING PROTECTED
BY LAW ENFORCEMENT CELL THANK
YOU AGAIN AND LOOK FORWARD TO-
FRIDAY. THANK YOU VERY MUCH
MISS RUBIO. MEMBERS ARE THERE
ANYONE WHO MEMBERS OF VIRTUALLY
WANT TO MAKE ANY CLOSING
REMARKS WE DON'T WANT TO FORGET
YOU. ANY MEMBER WHO ARE NOT
DOES NOT PHYSICALLY WITH US BUT
VIRTUALLY OF. OPEN YOUR
MICROPHONE AND PLEASE. SHARE
ANY CLOSING REMARKS YOU MAY
HAVE. MISTER CHAIR YES A BIG
RECOGNIZE MS RANSOMWARE IS
PLEASE THANK YOU THANK YOU SO
MUCH I AGAIN I WANT TO THANK
YOU FOR CONVENING THIS SELECT
COMMITTEE. WHAT A DIFFERENCE IT
MAKES WHEN WE HAVE PEOPLE FROM
THE COMMUNITY. REMINDING US
THAT THE COMMUNITY THAT IS MOST
IMPACTED SHOULD LEAD THIS
DISCUSSION THANK YOU FOR ALSO
HAVING LAW ENFORCEMENT THE
REMIND US THAT THEY GO THROUGH
TRAINING AND THEY RECOGNIZE
THAT THERE'S MORE THAT HAS TO
BE DONE- THE THIS THE SYSTEM
THAT IS IN PLACE IS NOT.
PERFECT AND WE HAVE TO IMPROVE
AND I APPRECIATE THAT THEY ARE
AT THE TABLE I ALSO APPRECIATE
THE COMMENTS ABOUT REFORM. THAT
REFORM HOUSE TO BE FROM THE TOP
DOWN. A WEEK WE TAKE THAT TO
HEART AND THAT THE LUIS
REGISTRY THAT WAS DISCUSSED. I
APPRECIATE THE NAME OF COURSE
BUT I APPRECIATE ALSO WHAT IT
DOES DO- FINALLY THE THEIR
DISCUSSION ABOUT DIGNITY AND
COLLABORATION WITH THE
COMMUNITY. WHAT I ATE THE ONE
OF THE MOST IMPORTANT THINGS I
HEAR ABOUT THIS IS THE
IMPORTANCE OF COMMUNITY AND ALL
OF THIS DISCUSSION WE CAN'T
TELL PEOPLE HOW WE'RE GOING TO
FIX THE SYSTEM IF WE DON'T
INCLUDE THEM. SO I SINCERELY
APPRECIATE MR CHAIR THE WAY YOU
WHO PUT THIS TOGETHER TODAY AND
I LOOK FORWARD TO THE REST OF
OUR SELECT COMMITTEE HEARINGS
THANK YOU THANK YOU VERY MUCH
MISS REYES APPRECIATE YOUR
COMMENTS AGAIN WE'RE ALL IN
THIS THING TOGETHER BECAUSE THE
PEOPLE.IS ABSOLUTELY DEMANDING
THAT WE DO SOMETHING OUR TERMS
ARE REIMAGINE LAW ENFORCEMENT
THEY TO CALIFORNIA- I ALSO
WANNA MAKE MENTION. WE WANNA
THANK THE AUDIENCE FOR THOSE
WHO CAME. AND GAVE THEIR
TESTIMONIES I ALSO WANT TO
THANK THOSE IN THE AUDIENCE AND
WE APPRECIATE YOU BEING HERE I
ALSO WANT TO LET EVERYONE KNOW
THAT WE HAVE A WEBSITE UP- AND
ON THE WEBSITE WE ARE ASKING
PEOPLE. TO UP TO READING TO
VIDEOTAPE YOUR EXPERIENCE GOOD
BAD OR INDIFFERENT- AND SO
UPLOAD IT TO THE WEBSITE
BECAUSE WE WANT MEMBERS TO
HEAR. WHAT YOU HAVE
EXPERIENCED- TERMS OF LAW
ENFORCEMENT GOOD BATTER AND OR
INDIFFERENT WE WANT TO KNOW
ABOUT IT AND SO WE HAVE- THIS
PORTAL- MADE AVAILABLE TO YOU
SO PLEASE CHECK OUT THE WEBSITE
AND FEEL FREE TO UPLOAD- SUCH A
VIDEO- WILL SHARE WITH THE
COMMUNITY- IN ADDITION TO THAT
I WANT TO THANK OUR SPEAKER FOR
AGAIN- LEADING THE WAY IN THIS
REGARD FOR ALLOWING US TO HAVE
THE SELECT COMMITTEE. WE
WOULDN'T BE HERE WITHOUT IT HAD
NOT BEEN FOR THE LEADERSHIP IN
THE FOR SIDE OF OUR SPEAKER MR
ANTHONY RENDON APPRECIATE THAT
AND ALSO WANT TO GIVE KUDOS TO
MY TEAM WHOSE WORK LITERALLY
ROUND THE CLOCK- MISTER GLIOMAS
LEON MR CHUCKLE OTHERS AND-
AND- IS RUBIO SAID SOMETHING. I
WANT TO PIGGY BACK ON- EACH
STAFF MEMBER- OR EACH MEMBER
HERE WHO'S ON THE SELECT
COMMITTEE. WE MEET WHICH YOUR
STAFF WHO'S BEEN Y. IT. NOTE
AND WE CAN THAT INFORMATION.
AND IT HELPED LEAD US ON THE
NEXT AGENDA TOPIC AND OR AREAS
WE SHOULD BE LOOKING AT. SO
IT'S NOT JUST YOU BUT ALSO YOUR
STAFF THAT YOU POINTED TO
WATCH. TAKE NOTES SO I WANT
EVERYONE TO KNOW THIS IS A TEAM
EFFORT EVERYONE IS ENGAGED IN
THIS BECAUSE WE TAKE THIS VERY
VERY SERIOUSLY. I WANT TO THANK
YOUR TEAM FOR I'M ENGAGING WITH
OUR TEAM IN THIS WORK AND
APPRECIATE EACH AND EVERYONE OF
YOU. SO WITH THAT BEING SAID
ALL THE WORK HAS BEEN COMPLETED
THE JETTA HAS BEEN I'M
COMPLETED THIS MEETING STANDS
ADJOURNED TO TRUMP UNTIL.
FRIDAY DECEMBER THE EIGHTEENTH
AT TEN AM THANK YOU IN THIS
ROOM.